Okay, the board will reconvene and we will start with item 8 on the update of our assessment system called CASP and we also have an information and action item here.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kirst, Chief Glenn Price, members of the board.
I'm Michelle Senner, Director of the Assessment Division here.
And it has been a while since I have come before the board and provided you an update on where we are with our CASP program.
Or at least it seems like it's been a while.
Maybe that's because I took a nice vacation to Ireland in between.
Well, I keep threatening my staff that I might start scheduling my vacations at board meeting times, and they don't think it's very funny.
I don't know.
So I'm here today to give you an update.
And because it's been a while, we might pause in between some of the topics and see if you have questions, because they are so different, a lot of standalone topics in the item.
So if you think that would be helpful, we can go ahead and do that.
So let's start off by saying I'm happy to report that we had our first test takers for this year's Smarter Balanced summative administration.
We had those brave 550 students take their first test on February 26.
So they are in the system and they are testing.
And since that time, we have about 10,000 students right now that have completed at least one of their Smarter Balanced summative tests.
So that's fine.
It's still early.
It could be a balloon drop behind me.
Just imagine it with this announcement.
Our districts are doing their interim assessments.
Yesterday, we just got news that we hit the $5 million mark for the number of interim assessments that were given this year.
So, I had to modify my tacking points this morning because we were at, just yesterday I told Glenn that it was 4 million and now we have crossed the 5 million mark.
So that's about 900,000 more administrations than what we had at this time last year.
So, quite a bit of information there for our teachers to get from those interims.
In terms of that, I'm happy to announce information on our Connections Playlist.
So, I've talked about the Connections Playlist in many items and many information memorandums before this board.
What's new this time in my announcement is that we have a Connections Playlist now for each of our interim assessments.
So, what those connection playlists, I see a smile on member Rucker's face, that's good.
So, the connections playlists were built by educators across our consortium member states.
The teachers evaluated student results on the interims and then determined what skill students were working to solidify.
And they use that information to come up with this connections playlist, which really is the link between our interim assessments and what is in our digital library.
The teachers can use the playlist with student interim assessments to quickly pinpoint resources that support their instruction.
Like I said, it is actually active links within those playlists that they can just click on to get to a specific resource in that digital library.
One of the benefits of that is it reduces the need for our teachers to log into the digital library and search and know what they are looking for and have to put in search terms.
This really simplifies the use of the digital library and we have heard great feedback and positive feedback on the connections playlist.
Just recently, I had the opportunity to do a presentation with my colleague, Director Barbara Murchison.
She's from the Educator Excellence and Equity Office.
We were lucky to do a presentation at the CISC Symposium in lovely Monterey.
That wasn't sarcasm.
It was lovely, unlike some of the other places I get to go to.
The presentation focused on these connections playlists and how they can be used to inform teaching.
We did this by walking through a scenario or an example of how a teacher might use that.
how that connections playlist can be used before instruction.
There's information up there on the connections playlist about what, for example, students who score in the above standard area, what they are still needing to solidify.
You can use that information along with other information to develop lesson plans or to develop student learning goals.
prior to even starting your instruction on a unit.
And then you can use that when you are progressing through that unit to check whether or not students have actually mastered what you have set forth as your learning goal.
So when we talk about it like that, it really helps provide a scenario or an approach that you might use to connect these two different elements of our comprehensive assessment system.
And so that was very well received.
The other thing that was very important to us for Barbara and myself was to really model collaboration between two sides of the house, which is our assessment side of the house and our curriculum and instruction side of the house.
And we were very deliberate in our presentation about talking about that.
and talking about encouraging that same type of collaboration to occur locally in our districts.
That was very deliberate.
We spoke about it.
We were very honest about it.
This is the first time we have actually presented together.
I'm not really that proud to say that, but we recognize that and we hope to do that more often throughout the state.
I think it's a great lesson and a good thing for us to really champion in our state.
I was a little nervous about doing a PowerPoint today after the last meeting, so I don't have one.
If there are questions on the Connections playlist, I could pause and see if there are questions on that particular document.
Well, I have both a question and a comment.
I'll give the comment first.
I had the opportunity in a different capacity at the invitation of Smarter Balanced to visit a meeting where the development of the playlist was done.
And it was interesting to watch teachers from multiple states along with teachers from California
who took basically a week out of their classroom to come to a hotel in Nevada, actually a surprisingly nice hotel in Reno, Nevada, by the way.
In other words, I couldn't smell the smoke from the cigarette.
And to spend time actually doing a very deep dive, not only into the assessment blueprints and student outcomes, but to really do an assessment or evaluation
of the content in the digital library and to look at how the content has matured since the time the library actually started being under development.
So getting a chance to sit in the room and listen to those conversations to talk about teaching and learning and using
the interim assessments in their classroom and using these tools in the library was very interesting.
But my question is concerning the development of the content in the digital library, this has become a kind of chicken and the egg conversation for me.
What do you believe has driven the development of the content?
In other words, how did the people who are working on that content
make decisions about what type of information to create, because teachers were questioning the application or usability of some of the lesson plans and activities that were created, and how will that change going forward?
Having watched what they did with this, how is that development going to, do you have any ideas on how that, I'm asking that because I know Tony's sitting there and he might be able to answer it instead, but how is that going to change going forward to continue improving the library itself?
That is a great question because it does highlight one of the lessons learned.
We have done two things.
One, right now we are going to focus development.
By having those meetings, we were able to identify gaps in the digital library.
As we are trying to develop connections playlists associated with the interim and the digital library, we were able to identify gaps.
Now we can focus development on those gaps.
In the future, as we develop our interim assessments, it makes more sense to develop the connections playlist along with the development of that interim block.
In the future, I believe we can do it in that direction, but for now, we have identified our need and we are doing the focus development.
Just to mention, Tony Alpert is here, Executive Director of Smarter Balanced, so I will send the tough questions to him.
Other board member questions on this.
Can you describe a little bit more just for the audience what a playlist would look like?
That's sort of a generic term.
Sure.
So imagine there might be an interim assessment on geometry.
I'm going to throw out geometry as an example.
And you would have a connections playlist that basically has two columns.
The column on the left would be organized into three blocks, above standard, at or near standard, and then below standard.
In each of those three blocks, it would describe skills that students are still working to solidify if they are scoring within that score area on that particular interim of geometry.
But then on the right side are listed suggestions for digital library content, which are formative assessment resources that an educator might be interested in for students that are scoring at that particular score level on that specific interim.
Does that help?
Tony Alpert, Executive Director for Smarter Balanced.
So Michelle did a great job describing the playlist.
The other piece, though, that principally Michelle and her staff and educators in California have driven is taking that playlist, which is right now in the form of a PDF, and integrating it into the open source reporting system that California educators are using to look at those results.
I think Michelle is going to talk more about the reporting system and the enhancements.
What we did is we have now integrated the playlist directly into the reporting system.
As teachers are looking at those interim results, they are able to look at this connection playlist and make a direct connection into the digital library.
It's still in the form of a PDF, and so we're going to work on making that more flexible, so having it be machine-readable text so that it's more, they're not looking at the full PDF, they're looking maybe at an intermediary page that highlights the skills that they're looking at, and then they'll click on that.
But the other piece that we added is we know that we can't describe all the resources that a district believes a teacher needs to have access to in light of the results of the interim assessment, so we're allowing districts to upload links to their resources.
that they think teachers should look at based on results of the interim assessment.
So then teachers have the benefit of resources identified by the consortium and resources identified by both the county office of education and the district or school as they see fit.
And so what it really does is this becomes a resource that informs the other work that Smarter Balanced is doing to create an online teacher's workbook or resource guide.
And this is just one iteration in that process that they're doing.
They still have other elements and other projects across the country and work groups that are putting this interactive guide together.
But this segment of that interactive guide that connects to work districts are doing locally
has actually matured faster than the rest of the process of developing that teacher's guide, and that's related to work that President Kirst has allowed me to continue working with Smarter Balanced on, so that's the reason why I know a lot about this thing that's going on right now.
So, yes, and Tony mentioned the new reporting system, which we plan on having some screenshots or demo for you at the next board meeting on the new reporting system.
So the next resource that I wanted to highlight was a resource that we developed for IEP teams.
We had heard a need that some IEP teams were finding it a little difficult to find the resources that they thought they needed to appropriately select the correct assessment for a student, as well as appropriately select the accessibility resource for that student.
We do have many resources available to help make that decision, but they are in various places.
We put together a flyer that provides links to all of the resources that we think an IEP team might find useful in making those particular decisions.
We also have a great stakeholder group, and included in that stakeholder group is someone who represents our SELPAs, and so we also ask that they assist us in getting that information out to the appropriate staff within California.
So there are many other resources under development.
One of them, and so let me just talk about one of them because it has a little bit of a connection to that.
And in a recent conversation that I had with CTA,
I received some feedback that our educators are finding it difficult to read our connectors and what you might remember what is a connector that is what links the content on our alternate assessments with our content standards and they're finding that document a little
How do I read that, and what can it be used for?
We are putting together a document to help explain what might be useful from that document.
How do we use it in assessment, and how might you use that locally?
We are putting together a document to help our educators use a resource that we already have available on our website.
That is in development right now.
Hopefully, I will be reporting back to you shortly on that.
So the next topic that I have for you is our primary language assessment.
So this is the last year of our standards-based test in Spanish, our STS test.
That is our current primary language assessment in California last year.
We're happy to announce that the last administration of that assessment is via computer, and that's thanks to support from the Smarter Balanced Consortium.
It's a nice transition to prepare our students, because our next test that's under development will be on a computer.
So this is a nice transition.
Our new primary language test is called the California Spanish Assessment, or the CSA.
That replaces the STS.
In order to accomplish that transition, we'll be conducting a field test in fall of 2018 to ensure that the test is ready in spring of 2019.
We recognize that might not be the normal time of our field test, but we have quite a few tests happening at the same time, and we thought it was more appropriate to not have that occur so we could get a large enough sample in our field test for this optional assessment.
Next, I have the California science test to give you an update on.
I have a feeling you'll have some questions on this.
We're on track with the development of our two science assessments, the California Science Test, or CAST, as well as the CAA for Science as our alternate science assessment.
You might recall that the CAST is scheduled to go operational in 2018-19, and the CAA for Science the following year.
I'm happy to announce, first of all, that the CAST Academies, which is our professional learning event, will occur in April.
Thus far, we have 400 educators already registered for that.
In fact, our Sacramento and Irvine locations, I believe, are full, so anyone who wants to travel to Fresno, you should go ahead and sign up quickly.
We're doing a unique approach with this training in order to try and get more of our educators trained.
So we're using a hybrid approach.
We have some in-person trainings in those three locations, and we're also allowing virtual hubs to occur.
So we'll have virtual hubs.
well as in person.
And so this is the first time that we've done it exactly like this.
We'll see how this works and if it does it'll be a great way for us to expand on the number of educators that we can train with the limited resources that we have.
This full-day academy covers four sessions.
The goal is to help educators understand these new assessments.
They include session one, which is the role of assessments and the various types of assessments.
We do a review of the California NGSS.
How you read that NGSS document will be in there.
It's a little complex.
It looks a lot different than you would our ELA and math content standards.
We talk about the role of phenomena and the concept of multidimensionality.
We talk about how you can experience the CAST training test items, where to go, how you might use them.
We talk about the implications of the CAST item types.
You may recall that we're doing both performance tests as well as standalone items, so we'll be talking about those.
And then we'll be talking about the test design and how that has an impact on teaching and learning.
So this gives us an opportunity to talk about how
While we may have three assessments, we actually assess more standards than just those three grade levels might indicate, so it's an opportunity to talk about ensuring that science instruction is happening in all grades.
We are happy to announce that it is West Ed under contract with ETS who is conducting these trainings for us.
We held a workshop with stakeholders to get their feedback on the training.
That was in early March, seems like so long ago.
But that was early March.
So I'd like to thank all of the organizations that were able to spend a full day with us to go over this training and provide us feedback so that we could make it better.
So that was the Association of California School Administrators, the California County Superintendents Educational Services Association, the California Teachers Association, the California Science Teachers Association, the California Science Project,
the K-12 Alliance, the Regional Assessment Network, the Small School District Association, the Making Sense of Science Project.
So thank all of them for agreeing to spend a whole day with us.
The content standards are new, the assessments are new.
This was a great opportunity for them to come spend a day and give us feedback.
And they did, they did not hold back.
So we're going through and making those edits now so that we can prepare for the April
launch of that event.
We also will be doing, thanks to our contract with Sacramento County Office of Education, we want to ensure that our county offices have what they need in order for them to go forth and conduct similar trainings in their counties so that it doesn't just stop here.
If there's a county or staff that couldn't get trained, we want the county offices to have what they need.
So, Sacramento County will be doing a training of trainers, if you will, meant for county offices of education.
That will be happening in the summer.
The next thing is, just as a reminder,
For our 17-18 administration, those are census administrations, which means all eligible students are expected to participate.
So for this year, that is a field test for CAST, and it is the second pilot year for the CAA for Science.
So let's talk a little bit about the CAA for Science for a moment.
You may recall that we had an innovative test design.
We are trying something for CAA for science that we've never tried before in California, and we're trying that on a very complicated set of standards.
So I came forth and said, I need two years of pilot.
And you all said, yes, you do.
So thank you very much, because we do.
So let me talk about the things that we learned from the first year's pilot that were changing in the second year's pilot.
It's quite a long list, and it goes, I think, to show that we had good reason for asking for two years.
So the reason why we changed, or the information that we got, was mostly via a survey.
So we did have a survey after the pilot, but we also conduct focus groups quite often.
If you see me having a training somewhere, I also usually have a small focus group during lunch.
I keep people back, or ETS keeps people back, and if they're there, it's a great way, no cost way, to have focus groups, right?
So we were able to do that also.
So we're making a number of changes that we believe will positively impact students and our teachers for year two pilot.
So the first thing we did was we decreased the item length and difficulty to reduce the complexity of the questions, but we did this while also maintaining alignment to the core content connectors.
We decreased the number of items associated with most tasks.
So remember, this is a task model approach.
So we reduced the number of items that would be associated with each task.
We simplified and streamlined the language that we used, made sure it was appropriate for the student population.
We reduced the overall difficulty of that language.
We added a student response check providing clear guidance in each task about the conditions under which testing should stop if a student doesn't respond.
That was added.
We eliminated the need for examiners to evaluate the student's lack of independence at multiple points throughout a task and instead have them only do that once per task.
We redesigned the graphic interface of the embedded performance test so that they have more clear directions to our examiners who are administering this test.
We were more thoughtful about the activities that we included in this year's performance task.
And what I mean by that is we selected, for example, items that require fewer materials and were mindful of materials that would be readily available at a school site.
So that was a lesson learned.
If you're going to do a hands-on activity, we want that to include materials that are easy to find for our educators.
We sought a balance between hands-on activities and graphic representations or short videos.
We wanted to ensure that there were also other ways of getting the content besides just hands-on activities.
We introduced a formal answer recording document that simplifies recording a student response.
Those are all of the things that we're undertaking for year two pilots.
We eventually will have this assessment more similar to CAA for ELA and math in terms of it being delivered on a computer and the answers actually being easily input on a computer, and we're transitioning to that over time when we get to the field test.
So there will be more enhancements when we get to the field test.
This is not the final list of enhancements that we'll need in order to get this right.
I want to say I am grateful for the hardworking educators and the valuable feedback they gave us.
Some of the administrations we heard were a bit of a challenge for the pilot year one, and they expressed that to us.
We hope that the changes that we made have improved that, but also still have fidelity to the design that we all agreed on and that we want to undertake for this.
We believe that we have a better balance in terms of that for this next pilot year.
The other thing is I want to just mention that we believe that the changes that we made highlight our commitment to getting it right and our commitment to being honest and transparent about the things that we believe we need to improve and making those statements in a public meeting and agreeing that it's going to take some time to get this right and we're on the right road, but it will probably take until we get to the field test in terms of the lessons learned.
I think we want to take questions here.
I heard you say that as part of the administration of the assessment there is some kind of monitoring that the educator in the classroom is doing of the student to make a decision
to stop the student from continuing on that item or that task.
Is there objective criteria or guidance to teachers on how to make those intervention decisions or does that still remain more subjective at this point?
There is always some degree of subjectivity in that kind of decision, but it is not about a student not getting the answers correct.
It is about a student not being responsive.
I believe that does provide a level of objectivity in terms of making that decision.
We do have more guidance than we did before.
Whether or not we need to increase that, we'll look again and have some more focus group and feedback on whether or not our educators felt like they had all the information they needed to make that decision.
It isn't new.
Our examiners make that same type of decision with CAA for ELA and math.
And then for the manipulatives or the tools that students would use or interact with as part of the task, is there a difference in cost from among the tasks or is the cost of the equipment relatively the same for each of the tasks that have been developed?
I have not looked at it from that perspective of cost.
I believe that now that we have made them readily available, pencils, that type of thing, that I am not sure how much cost will play into that.
But it is a question that we are happy to look at and see if there is.
There were some particular samples last year that were very difficult and, honestly, probably
probably had some expense to them because they weren't readily available, and I'm not sure that we're going to have that same type of issue in the coming year.
But we're happy to look at it from that perspective.
Can you talk a little bit about how we're going to satisfy the Federal?
That's coming next.
You read my mind.
Pardon?
Oh, Karen Valdez.
KAREN VALDEZ.
I just want to really thank you.
I really feel like you are not reacting.
You're responding and your inclusivity of all the stakeholders and simple things like the supply list for the administration.
I remember in the Kappa days going through my house and finding things.
And I think that that's really helping to make this test be the best it can be.
So I appreciate what you're doing and the iterations that you're going through.
So thank you.
So, next topic.
In order to meet federal law, we will be providing preliminary indicators using pre-operational science assessments.
So, preliminary indicators, they're not scale scores, and they're not achievement levels, so let's start there.
That is what they are not.
They are percent correct, and they're also a general indication of the California NGSS understanding for a student.
An LEA may use this information in conjunction with other information to get a broad and early understanding of where they are in terms of their NGSS implementation.
ESSA requires, as well as IDEA, just want to add that, that these results be communicated with three audiences.
And those three audiences are parents and students, LEAs, and the general public.
California will be complying with this requirement as a condition of not double testing.
Another way of saying that is California has not submitted a request for a waiver.
We see no need to ask for a waiver.
I believe that is exactly what I put in writing to them.
That being said, we want to ensure that the various audiences appropriately interpret
i.e.
don't over-interpret the meaning of the preliminary indicators.
We will not be placing that on a student score report.
We believe that would send the wrong message.
We will not be placing preliminary indicators in the California dashboard.
That would again be sending the wrong message about what these preliminary indicators are.
What we will be doing is assisting our schools and districts with communicating these preliminary indicators to that audience that they are responsible for communicating with, which are the parents and students.
We're going to do that by providing a preliminary indicator communications toolkit.
That toolkit is currently under development right now.
It will include such things as a timeline, key messages that might be helpful when communicating,
Frequently asked questions, we are collecting those now, and also an optional parent score report letter.
The toolkit will communicate to our LEAs the discretion that they have in how they communicate results to parents.
I will be utilizing two different groups to receive feedback on this communications toolkit before I send this out publicly to our districts in California.
Those two groups are the Statewide Assessment Stakeholder Group, which I talk about all the time and I am so lucky to have, and they agree to meet with me every single month to provide me assistance, as well as our Regional Assessment Network, which our County Office of Education
friends and colleagues.
Those are the two groups that I will be using to gather input on that and I have a sense that there might be questions on the preliminary indicators.
What discretion does the LEA have in terms of reporting to parents and students?
I assured the U.S.
Department of Education that I would notify our districts that they are to communicate with parents and students, and that I would provide them with information on how they might do that.
For example, we will only give examples, we will not give an exhaustive list, but one example that we have heard might be useful is providing this information in a one-on-one meeting.
So if you have scheduled parent-teacher conferences, that would allow you to have that conversation with a parent about where you are, where your school is, in terms of transitioning to the new standards at the same time that you are providing that assessment result.
That is one option.
We are providing a letter, so if districts feel like that is the best option for them to communicate with their parent community, they can do that.
But we are also gathering other options that we can put in a non-exhaustive list of options.
Other comments?
Board Member Williams.
What are the two groups that you're going to run the communications toolkit by?
So the first group is the statewide assessment stakeholder group.
So that includes many organizations, such as California PTA, CSTA, CTA, AXA, SELPA, AXI.
I know I missed some.
So the California Science Teachers Association.
They have a representative on that group.
All right, because I know they have a good feel for the pulse of what the science teachers and administrators are going to be concerned about.
Yes, and they are great partners in the development of this test.
What I didn't mention – I think I'm free to mention it.
It's not solidified, but CSTA is so gracious to allow us – because I told them we're doing this CAST Academy.
It's six hours of training.
It's full-day training.
They have a conference coming up later this year, so I believe that they are going to give us, CDE, six hours to hold another CASP Academy at their conference.
That is just an example of what great partners they have been in the rollout of this test, so I am very grateful.
Yes, they will be included as soon as we have a draft to send them, which hopefully is this week.
Well, I appreciate your calling them great partners.
They are, and of course they have a real vested interest in how all of this goes, and I'm sure they feel equally appreciative to you and the staff at CDE for doing a six-hour session at their conference.
It will be a big help for their teachers, so it's a win-win.
I just want to say that I really appreciate the way that you're handling this with regard to working on the negotiation with the federal ED.
Everyone appreciates the fact that there was no double testing, which it looked like there was going to have to be.
And I think, I feel really confident that when LEAs get their CAS scores, the way that you're handling them and what they are, that they will be able to communicate those effectively with parents and students in a way, I feel confident that they will choose to do it in a way that says, this indicates where we are in our implementation of NGSS.
and I'm hoping that they also do it in a way with their teachers that says, okay, let's work together to see what else we need to be doing over the next year or two to get fully implemented.
So I think it's going to be, while it might feel a little anxious for those first scores to come out, especially since we don't have instructional materials yet, so the schedule's kind of a little bit out of sync,
But I think it could be turned around into a very beneficial thing in terms of motivating and informing the next round of implementation.
And I appreciate your work on this.
Thank you.
Board Member Valdez.
Just a quick clarification question.
So I know that when it came out that there was going to be some kind of feedback to districts in terms of results, and so now it's percentages is what I heard you say.
I think that helped a lot at the high school level to give it a little bit more importance, because there was a lot of just trying to plan, right?
Who's taking it?
I know it's supposed to be 12th graders, but there was some creative thinking in how to go about it.
So as an LEA, I'm going to get results by individual students in some kind of a database, and then I'm going to merge them into some kind of a letter.
Is that the idea behind it?
The final details, we are still working out, but I believe it will be a data file.
Do you know that?
Whether or not it is a separate data file or combined with a data file that you already have, we are still in conversations about that specific detail, but yes, it will be a data file by student.
California is responsible for the general public.
So I do have to report to the general public by all the required federal subgroups that I normally have to report on.
That being said, I don't want to give the impression that you can do more with this than you should.
So we aren't going to do that via our splashy website with the bars and all of that, the colored website that you all know as our CAS reporting website.
But we will provide a research file that has all the groups on it, so the reporting to the public will also be done via a data file, just like that is being done for you.
I think that will also allow us to put the appropriate cautionary language right there where you would download that data file.
So let's change gears again.
So happy to announce that we have recently posted the assignment of accessibility resources for the 2017 Smarter Balanced Summative Test Administration.
So this is a data file that we produce and we post that provides information about counts of students who were assigned accessibility resources.
We saw growth in terms of the assignment of supports over the last three test administrations.
We're happy to see that trend, but we don't believe that tells the whole story.
Starting next year, we're going to start investigating reporting of student usage of the designated supports and accommodations.
This is a monumental task.
As you might imagine, or if you can imagine for a moment, a testing session and a student is sitting there with an item and one of these supports may be a pop-up glossary.
and there are multiple words on that one item, maybe they select one word to use a pop-up glossary.
Maybe they don't use any, and then they use a pop-up glossary for the next item.
So how we actually analyze this data and provide that information is going to take some time.
This is going to be a massive amount of information, almost data overload, if you will,
But we do believe that it will give us a better picture of what's going on in terms of the usage of accessibility supports.
We're never going to get the full picture.
Unless someone was sitting behind every student and monitored what they did, it's never going to be complete.
But this is going to be more of the pie, if you will.
So, we're happy to announce that, but I also want to give us a little bit of caution that it's probably going to take some time, and it's going to take us some time after we get the data to really think about how we report this and what makes the most sense.
Does a student clicking on a pop-up glossary once over an entire test administration mean they used a pop-up glossary?
I don't know at this time.
So that's the type of information that we're getting and the struggles that we will be having in interpreting it.
What are some of your goals for your analysis of that data?
Well, one of the things in terms of the assignment of resources,
We keep seeing more and more resources assigned to students.
I think it would be great to be able to provide LEAs some information on what students are actually using when they get on that test.
Sometimes I think it's really easy to just click more and more.
Yes, they need that.
That would be helpful.
In reality, it may not be helpful, it may be overloaded, and it also may not be used.
So I think that there's some learning that can come from this type of information that we're gathering.
We also are talking about the future
the next generation, if you will, of the professional development and the presentations that my division will be doing in collaboration with all my partners and all my contractors.
And one of them happens to be really talking about accessibility supports throughout the year.
identifying ways that they can not only use our products, but what other products are out there that we know they are using in the classroom.
We know that we have Google Classrooms and we know that they're using Google products, for example, some schools.
What are similarities between that and what they will see on the assessment?
And maybe thinking about that when you have that long list of supports for Smarter Balanced,
and you're making those choices for students.
So that's the future of what we plan on presenting on and hoping to get to in terms of our next professional development type of events in the future and I think that information will help.
So thank you.
I would agree.
I'm glad to hear that there's going to be some analysis of the accessibility tools and how they're being used, all that.
The core piece or the basic piece is the training of the
the administrators on what these tools mean, how they fit into the accommodations for the student, and I think that it provided great tools around that, but I think there's still a lot of professional development and communication and support.
finding and really learning what those tools are and how they might meet individual student needs.
So it's got to be that you're collecting the data on that end but there's still that training at the at the school level as well in the district level to make it all really work.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
I'm really excited to hear that because I had actually asked, I think, two years ago to show me how ELs were accessing some of the supports.
So that would be one group of students that we want to see.
Do they have access to the resources, supports available to them?
because these are manually assigned, correct, for the students before they take the assessment.
So you would also have to, the teacher would have to know who their students are and tailor the supports for them.
So we didn't know if teachers were actually doing that or if there was an understanding of who was before them.
So that would be a great way, but again, I do think that it also needs to be part of the training so that everybody is aware of what's available to them and what's being used or not used.
Thanks.
And we have information now on assignment.
So we do know whether or not they're assigning, for example, stacked translations, or whether or not they're assigning a pop-up glossary for students.
But I think the second question is important.
The other piece of that, in particular for our students who do not have an IEP, the process for selecting those supports
districts have discretion on what kind of process they use for that.
I think this also may provide some information at a district-by-district level that may be helpful for those as they're still, I think, struggling in some districts on what process to use and whether or not it is really just an individual teacher making that decision, whether or not they have formed committees that have conversations and make those choices.
We always encourage those decisions to be made on an individual student basis.
I do believe that that's not always the case for districts.
They use information such as their SALT score and sometimes only just their SALT score and use that to determine what resources to provide.
And so I think this is another piece of information that might show those that are using that
That tool may not be helpful.
So I know that there are some districts, so for example, these are all lessons learned, right?
So the first year they turned on stack translations for all of their ELs and then it just slowed them down.
So as you're looking at this analysis also, do the resources slow down the student or do they help the student?
Is it too much on the page as they're looking at the item as well as the glossary?
I mean, those are kinds of some considerations and I don't know how you'd measure that.
But I think, is there an opportunity or some kind of a forum for districts to share their thinking about why they do some things?
Because I know it's a local thing, but there are teacher by teacher decisions.
But a lot of times at the district level, this is managed.
And maybe it's with the regional assessment networks.
But just the thinking about why they do, over time, have made different decisions and what has benefited them.
and some of the efficiency for the students to be able to engage with the assessment.
I'm just wondering, is that metacognition thinking about your thinking, but at a large level across districts?
So, a couple things.
One, I can easily send a question out to my regional assessment network about, you know, how have your processes changed in terms of making these assignments and what lessons have you learned?
Since you brought up the other question, I believe I can announce this other project that we just agreed to do yesterday.
Yesterday, I had a meeting with Californians Together about one of the topics that came up, which were the stack translations.
and you asked, how do you gather that information?
Well, the information that you're talking about you gather via cognitive lab.
So you have someone sitting with a student who is asking them questions as they're interacting with the assessment.
And in terms of stack translations,
We have had some feedback that just the way it's displayed on the screen with the English and then the Spanish is just difficult, and they believe that students are having a hard time following which line to read.
We have had that conversation in the past, and in the past we did believe that.
In looking at the other options, the current option that we have is still the best option, but it is time to reevaluate that again.
What we have agreed to do is come up with some different mock-ups and have a cognitive lab, hopefully later this summer.
And so I know that California's Together is going to help me find some students to participate in that cognitive lab that Smarter Balanced is going to conduct for us.
Maybe we don't even have to go to them.
Tony, you have your students now.
And I think that's perfect.
And I also just really want to celebrate your intentional looking forward and trying to engage, because these things should be used all year long, right?
So I think I really want to applaud the idea that you're trying to go out there and make sure they're happening with all of the vendors.
So thank you.
Do you have any other items for us?
Yes.
I know you have.
I do.
I know, I know.
I was told I had all the time in the world.
Okay.
Not quite.
Let's move on to peer review and give you a little bit of update there.
In June 2016, you might recall that we submitted our peer review evidence for our Smarter Balanced assessment.
The purpose of that is to document the validity, reliability, and fairness of our assessment system with the U.S.
Department of Education.
The outcome of that submission, you might recall, was substantially meets the requirement,
stellar first peer review finding.
As part of that, though, the U.S.
Department of Education did request additional evidence, and so the Smarter Balance did submit that additional evidence in December of 2017.
Also in December, California submitted its peer review evidence for the California Alternate Assessments for English Language Arts and Mathematics.
I believe we submitted over 100 different pieces of evidence for that particular peer review.
And we should hear back on both of those, the additional evidence that Smarter sent, as well as our alternate assessments.
We hope to hear back in summer of this year on those results.
And finally, I'd like to report some preliminary information about the additional analysis that Smarter Balance was conducting in relationship to the 2016 versus the 2017 scores.
So in consultation with the consortium members as well as the Smarter Balanced Technical Advisory Committee, the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium went through a series of analyses to test some hypotheses related to assertions that were made about the release of last year's scores.
The analyses investigated seven research questions, and I'm going to go through the preliminary information.
The report is not yet final, and it will be delivered to us either later this month or early April, in time for us to provide you that report in an April information memorandum, but I did want to give you some preliminary information.
So I'm going to go through each of the questions and brief information.
The first was, did students perform better or worse compared to the previous year?
Essentially, the 2016 and 2017 average scale scores were the same.
Were there fewer test questions available?
No.
The 2017 bank included virtually all of the 2016 items, plus a large number of new items that were developed.
Were the new test questions more difficult?
No, the new test questions were not more difficult.
Did the newly added test questions negatively impact test results?
There were no substantial differences that were found.
Did students spend less time taking the test?
No, actually the students spent more time in 2017.
They spent about 11 minutes more in ELA, about 10 minutes more in math.
Did students take the test earlier in the school year?
No, the time was essentially the same.
Did student demographics change?
There were slight differences found, but they seem to be more related to how students were classified versus true demographic changes.
An example is less students classified as unknown race in 2016 versus 2017.
So the Smarter Balanced Technical Advisory Committee agreed that the analyses conducted to investigate the research questions were thorough and did not uncover any technical errors associated with the newly added items or with any component of the 2017 administration.
The analyses conducted by Smarter Balanced was also independently reviewed by the National Center for Improving Educational Assessment.
Smarter Balanced is finalizing that report, like I said, so these are preliminary, and I will be sending the report in the information memorandum.
But in summary, we anticipate that this report will confirm the appropriateness of comparing the 2016 and 2017 Smarter Balanced test results.
Any questions on that?
Board Member Strauss.
So, Michelle, I really appreciate your thorough presentation and your demeanor and presenting it and the continued work you do.
The question on the analysis that you just talked about, those were the initial and we'd had a meeting with you all about what further validation we were going to do to
to support or look at the issue of reliability.
Are there any more studies or analysis or I thought we were talking about maybe independent review that might extend the validation and deepen this discussion?
Hello, Tony Alpert, Executive Director of Smyrna Balance.
So we do conduct a whole series of additional analyses as part of our annual technical report.
And for those of you that have the pleasure to look at it, it's something on the order of 500, 600 pages or some such.
So that is part of our annual process.
On top of that, we added this special additional analysis
to address the specific concerns that you as the board have or part of the board have expressed.
And so this is on top of what is otherwise our best practice.
The additional analysis we contracted with the National Center for Improving Educational Assessment
They're looking at all of our analytical questions, our process for testing them, our results, and they're determining whether or not they can affirm both our analytical process as comprehensive and our conclusions based on the data that we're looking at.
What's the timing for that follow-up analysis?
So tomorrow, I think we should get that.
So they've been working in parallel.
When we presented, we started this discussion with our technical advisory committee and our members back in fall.
And I think as you're aware, we don't get the data from states until after they've certified it as part of their accountability systems.
And as you know, that takes a long time.
So by January, we had a full data set upon which we could start conducting our analyses.
So in October, we talked conceptually with our technical advisory committee about the analyses that we might engage in.
Then once we had the data, we started producing some initial results to discuss with our TAC.
And then they, of course, had suggestions for changes.
So in the meantime, we had a contract with the center, and then they had to adjust their strategy and their timeline based on the revised request from our technical advisory committee.
So it's all shifted a little bit later than we might have hoped, but we're working as quickly as we can.
Any further questions on that?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So, questions for Michelle.
And I know that you cover the digital library and I know that that's resources that could help us go from the flat and take up a little bit.
But what are you, the CD, doing to help and support LEAs and for the supports to trickle down so that we see a difference, hopefully an increase, next year?
Now I feel the weight of the world on me.
What we, the department, do to help improve academic performance is, of course, not solely related to assessment, nor solely related to the digital library.
I am sure that someone from Tom Adams' shop would be happy to come present on the various professional learning activities and resources that they provide to support
In terms of what I provide, really I've already presented on those and I'm happy to, I was talking to Patricia DeCoste this morning, I think it would be a perfect opportunity for us to come at the next board meeting and bring a district person who is using some of these resources and report out to you how they think they, whether or not they think they're being useful and will lead to improved academic success.
also bring a teacher, that would be great to hear directly from someone.
I sure can.
Please.
That request.
Yes, because I know I was talking to my husband about some of the resources he's using and one of his colleagues accidentally like set the actual, administered the assessment.
Oh, yeah.
And she was confused and it showed that the window opened before it had to open.
So there's still a lot of confusion, a lot of need for training at the school site level on how to use these resources.
So it would be great to hear from those that are actually using the resources.
Sure, I'm happy to do that.
We'll find someone to come present.
And we're always looking for
districts that are doing innovative things with our resources, and we highlight those.
We have a series called C.A.S.P.
in Action, and we highlight different districts that are trying out different things, and sometimes they're successful, and sometimes, frankly, they're not.
They report back on, we tried this, and this didn't work.
In fact, Member Sung had her
Her charter school was actually in one of the more recent CASP in action, and they reported back on how they used the practice and training tests with their students and with their parent population.
And there was feedback from the teachers on what worked about that and what might they do differently in the future when they took on that activity.
And so those are the type of things that we're always looking for.
But I think it's time to bring forth the district again and do a presentation.
Board Member Roker.
I've been trying to figure out when to ask this question.
So since we're on the topic of resources, another important resource that has been developed both by Smarter Balanced and that the department has been using and providing support on is on the accessibility tools and the guidance.
And in looking at the report, at least the information that's been provided to us so far about the access or use of accessibility tools, my concern remains that it seems very low, given the number of students who A, take the alternative assessment, or the number of districts that have a numerically significant subgroup of students with disabilities.
So I want to understand with all of the assessment practices and interim assessments that are being done, is there any guidance being given to districts to encourage them to use the accessibility tools even as they're using the practice test and the interim assessments because I don't see where that use has actually improved given the number of students that have been identified with disabilities or taking the alternative assessments.
So we are seeing increases in the assignment of resources.
So that is occurring.
Is it enough?
And is it the right resource, I think, is really an important question.
Probably not in all cases, right?
So we do provide information quite often, particularly related to the interims and the practice and training tests, and iterate many times about how one usage of that is actually trying out these supports.
That is a message that is constant from us.
We do a webinar annually about resources.
I feel like we do communicate quite often, but with the state our size, it obviously is not trickling down in all cases.
We recently started engaging in activity to locate all of the conferences that might be occurring in and around our state.
We are putting special emphasis on locating conferences where we can reach educators of students with disabilities.
That is something that we are particularly focusing on this year.
I believe we have one or two conferences that we think we're going to hit.
We also do present at the SELPA meeting, but maybe we need to do that again.
The reason why I wanted to ask the question is I still get emails from teachers across the state saying that their district is under the impression that using the accessibility tools means there's only one way
that the test will be identified and it's automatically that the student is not proficient.
It doesn't matter that the Smarter Balanced Guide says explicitly in several areas of the guidance, including right on the front page, that that is not the case, but many teachers are being told when they ask about accessibility tools for their students that their districts tell them no because students will be identified as not proficient if they use any of them.
We're happy to put that particular message out yet again in our weekly update.
Also, just to point out, our weekly update is not limited to just district staff.
Any educator in California can sign up and get the information directly from the department.
so that they are not relying on that type of information.
Also, we use our weekly upload date to highlight specific resources within our digital library.
We do that quite frequently, so it is a great resource for them to get directly.
Maybe we need to reach out to CTA and CFT and see if they can help us get the word out that that might be something that their members would be interested in joining.
So one additional resource that we offer is we call it a crosswalk with instructional practices.
So we try to describe the accessibility resources that are on the Smarter Balanced assessment and the equivalent resources that a teacher might use in the classroom.
So for instance, the text-to-speech, they might have support on the Smarter Balanced assessment, they might have an instructional assistant in the classroom who reads aloud to the student.
So trying to make that connection so they tie their practice that they use every day to the resources that are in the summative assessment to try and make that connection more clear for them.
And it sounds like perhaps we have to highlight that a little bit more as well.
Thank you.
So, I just wanted to say thank you as well, Michelle, for coming.
We always like to get updates and appreciate your presentation, and thanks to Tony for being here.
Thanks for trying to be all things to all people.
I'm actually struck by the conversations as we have these around CAS by the stark difference between this assessment system and the California standards test.
and just to have people roll back the tape a little bit to how we got here and how much we have invested in improving teaching and learning as an outgrowth of our assessment system.
I think we lose that a little bit.
The one thing I wanted to go back to, though, and I apologize for missing the boat on this, was when you talked about the reporting of the preliminary indicators for science,
Just to revisit the topic of not making a big hoop-dee-doo about test results separate from all the other indicators that are in the dashboard, and I know you're still trying to figure out how you're going to actually report them, but I would encourage, as we're sort of thinking about
when we roll out the various metrics in our accountability system, that we make sure that test results are appropriately part of that rollout as opposed to a separate be-all, end-all that we've made them in the past.
I think we have some things that we can address in there.
We do specifically talk about not looking at these preliminary indicators as a standalone piece of information.
So maybe we also focus and specifically direct them to places that do offer multiple measures like the dashboard.
So we could be a little more direct in that, in the FAQs that we provide.
Yeah, I think we heard yesterday from the CSTA, they wanted to have a placeholder and member Williams talked about this as well.
So I think just kind of laying the groundwork a little bit to this is what it's going to look like when it's fully fleshed out and validated and all of that.
But again, just reinforcing, because I feel like a lot of the anxiousness that people have about CASP
is still, it's the muscle memory of, it's everything that we've got is this test.
And it's not.
I mean, it's very important information.
As I said earlier, it's a really great tool for improving teaching and learning.
But I think it would be great to just continue down this path of there's lots of other things that are important.
None of this discussion has touched on my biggest concern, which is, and maybe we can do this next time.
I don't want to open it, you know, have a presentation this time.
And that is the appalling lack of knowledge by the general public.
not educators, of what Smarter Balanced is and how it differs from the old test, from college admissions tests, and even its basic properties.
I speak a lot with audiences, rotary clubs, that kind of thing, and they have no idea that this is a computer-adaptive test
that it has open response, that a performance exam is different from a writing exam.
Education advocacy groups continue to say we don't get results back to school districts to the fall, confusing the fact that the turnaround is two weeks and they talk to reporters about it and we get criticism for slow reporting to districts.
So we may be communicating better with educators, but the general awareness of the unique characteristics in what we're doing, I think, in the general public is very weak.
And I know Smarter Balanced is trying to do something about it, and next time I think we ought to talk.
I have some presentation on that when you come back.
I mean, you know,
When I tell people that the SAT is a paper and pencil test, ours is computer adapted for each individual, they don't have open response.
It's a closed system.
They use a traditional writing example.
We use a performance exam.
We give feedback on detailed things that are different from what they do.
We are extremely vulnerable in defending this assessment in the public policy area.
There needs to be more focus on the inside baseball within educators
But we are losing the battle in the external awareness of the assessment, and they still think it's CST.
The only test the general public has ever seen is a closed-end moldable choice bubble-in test.
and then they see our announcement on what the scores are in September or whenever it comes out and assume there's this huge delay.
So I think also the educational professional groups could do more about this in some ways in disseminating it.
So this is my biggest concern and it doesn't seem to be getting any better.
So we're very susceptible to disinformation and misinformation about this exam and assessment.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, thank you for those comments.
I think you're on point.
The people I talk to outside of the education community have very little knowledge about our assessment and where we're going in general beyond just assessment, to take Member Burr's comments and context.
as well.
I just wanted to say that I think this takes a communication plan that goes beyond our assessment division.
So this is something that I'll discuss with Chief Deputy Glenn Price as well as take it back to the Executive Committee of Smarter Balance because I'm sure that the same thing is true in other states as well.
Okay, I think we're ready for public comment on this item.
We have two public commenters, Doug McRae and Martha Zaragoza-Diaz.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, retired testing publisher for Monterey.
Since your January meeting, Smarter Balanced has acknowledged a large change in 2017 operational item bank compared to 2016.
They've not addressed whether or not the 2017 scores had adjustments to reflect changes in difficulty for 2017 operational bank by grade, by content area.
The little information I received says that there were changes by grade, by content area, in difficulty.
These things, no adjustments or incorrect adjustments, could be the cause for 2017 scores to drop like a stone.
Still need for more transparency.
This problem affects 14 states and 5 million students.
Finally, we need a credible independent evaluation.
I have great confidence in the Center for Assessment.
However, I understand the lead person on this was a former co-chair of the Smarter Balanced Committee, and that strains the independence of it.
Additional CASP issues are addressed in material in your electronic folder.
Thank you.
Good morning Dr. Kirsten, board members.
My name is Martha Zaragoza-Diaz and I'm representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
First, I'd like to say that we're very pleased with the projects that will be undertaken with regards to obtaining data specific to supports used by students taking the CSTs and also with regards to the stacked translations.
We think that this is very important for students.
We also would like to thank staff on the work done so far with regards to the California Spanish assessment.
However, we do believe that the CSA can be strengthened by including a writing component similar to what is provided by the English language arts assessment.
Currently the CSA only assesses writing mechanics.
We believe that in order to assess the writing abilities of students taking the CSA that they should have a writing component within the CSA.
Staff is aware of this.
We've had our discussions but we would encourage the board to include this in order to move this issue along.
Thank you.
Good morning President Kirst, Deputy Price, members of the board, Jessica Sacco representing California Science Teachers Association.
I haven't signed up because we don't have an ask but given that we were mentioned I thought it was appropriate for me to return the thanks and appreciation for the department for their very deliberate
and inclusive approach as they work to develop the CAST and the alternate assessment as well as the board for their comments today.
CSJ is proud to partner as well and we're very grateful for all of your support for science.
Thank you.
And yes, we did offer a CAST Academy at the conference.
So, yeah.
Okay, this is not an action item so there's no board resolution needed.
Yeah.
Michelle, can you respond to the consideration of the writing portion of the California Spanish assessment?
Sure.
So I have met with Martha and Californians together on several occasions on their requests.
It is correct that the Spanish assessment measures writing mechanics.
That is what the blueprint measures.
It does not have, if you will, an extended writing prompt.
We have agreed to come up with a cost estimate for what it would cost to add that and provide that to Californians together.
We don't have the resources to add that type of item to the test.
I'm a testing person.
I'm happy to add all kinds of things.
You know, from a policy perspective, we do need to look at testing time.
In this case, it's optional, so maybe that isn't as much of a concern.
But we are getting our cost estimate.
I got some information this week that I'm confirming and we'll be providing that to them by next week.
Okay, we're now ready for item nine, which is the English Language Proficiency Assessment for California.
And Michelle will present that as well.
Yes.
So unlike the last item, item 9 is an action item before you.
The CDE asked the board to approve revisions to the test blueprints for the initial English language proficiency assessments for California, or LPAC.
As a reminder, the LPAC has two separate tests.
It has an initial assessment for the identification of English learners that goes operational in July, and our summative becomes operational this year.
That testing is going on now through May.
The SB approved the original blueprints for the initial in November of 2015.
A test blueprint details the number of items and points by task, type, and content standard.
The CDE is now recommending revisions based on both stakeholder input as well as the field test results.
The proposed revisions to the test blueprint for the initial LPAC are similar to those that I brought for you in September of 2017 for the summative LPAC blueprint.
Revisions address administration considerations which resulted in the elimination of some task types.
Revisions also ensure appropriate rigor.
For example, changes to ensure that the appropriate number of items were included for various task types to address the full continuum of performance were made.
Lastly, revisions were done to address the performance of task types, for example, realignment of some task types and the elimination of other task types.
Lastly, we are proposing the use of a single initial assessment for grades 9 through 12.
The reason for this proposed change to the blueprint is because the 2012 English language development standards at grades 9 and 10 and at 11 and 12 are very similar.
Therefore, a single test administered once in a student's school career can satisfy the intended use of the initial assessment.
Remember, the initial is used to identify students as English learners.
The revisions offer the final benefit, reduction in test materials that LEAs need to order, handle, and store securely from year to year, reduction in training for test examiners, both in the state-sponsored training as well as local training events, and potential reduction in the number of testing sessions that staff need to complete for grade-level groupings.
The proposed changes have been vetted with our LPAC technical advisory group, the California Association for Bilingual Education, Californians Together, and California educators during the initial standard setting in February.
The responses to that change were positive.
The next step, the CDE will provide an information memorandum.
This changes completely.
What is the next step in terms of LPAC?
We are going to provide you an information memorandum that details the preliminary threshold scores for the initial LPAC.
Those threshold scores will be coming to you in May for approval.
So it's a great opportunity right now to thank member Ortez-Lacon, who was so nice to come and spend a full day at our initial standard setting event so that she could witness and observe the process that ETS, our contractor, was conducting to establish those threshold scores.
So I want to say thank you, and I need to make sure that I include those kind of invites to my liaisons whenever they arise.
So are there any questions on the action before you?
Board member Holiday.
Although the standards may be quite similar between 9, 10, 11, and 12 in grades, the need for a student to become much more sophisticated in her use of language in the 11th and 12th grade compared to 9th grade freshmen, there's a pretty wide gap there.
Did you take that sort of
Idea in in to your thinking about having only one initial assessment
That was considered while there is of course continued learning and sophistication that is occurring with a student's English language development and their English skills throughout high school.
It was the opinion of the experts that we consulted that in terms of whether or not you need to be classified as an English learner to provide appropriate supports that was consistent across the high school grades.
One more, sorry.
Did you also think about having a single test but that there would be an additional group of questions or additional tasks beyond what you might give to the 9th, 10th, or the 11th grader or the 9th or 10th grader?
I mean, not two tests as much as just an expanded.
An augmented test as well.
That was not considered.
Any other questions?
Board Member Sung.
Not so much, I think, but I think for the identification initially, it doesn't seem like there's much of a difference at all in that.
So I will move this item and approve the staff recommendation.
What's that?
Is it, there's a motion we can discuss it.
Oh I thought this was assessment.
Okay.
We have a motion right?
I have a motion for staff recommendation.
Is there a second?
Second.
Okay let's have public comment on the motion then.
on the whole item, I'm sorry, yeah.
Doug McRae and Martha Zaragoza-Diaz.
Good morning again, I'm Doug McRae, retired test publisher for Monterey.
Both the LPAC summative and the LPAC initial test development sequence have involved revised blueprints after completion of field test exercises.
This unusual occurrence typically calls for a new field test exercise based upon the revised blueprints and delay of operational testing for a year.
I'd ask why is the CDE staff ignoring this major flaw in test development sequence for the LPAC test?
has major impact on validity and reliability of LPAC summative scores now being produced, and will have major impact on validity and reliability of LPAC initial scores.
I'd note the standard setting threshold study was done without any data whatsoever.
It was a data-free exercise, which for a test to be used for accountability is not a good idea.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together and we've reviewed this item.
We've had people take a look at it and we recommend moving forward and we support the staff recommendation.
Thank you.
Okay there's no further discussion on this item.
All in favor raise your hands.
Okay that is carried.
The CDE recommendation is
So we're now on to item 10, the California Education for a Global Economy Initiative.
Good morning.
Would you like to take a stretch break?
Good morning, President Kurz, Chief Deputy Glenn Price, and esteemed members of the board.
I'm Veronica Aguilar, Director of the English Learner Support Division, and I'm here to provide an update on the rulemaking process for the California Education for a Global Economy, or California EDGE Initiative, also known as Proposition 58.
The proposed regulations are intended to provide clarity, interaction to local education agencies for the purpose of complying with the provisions of California EDGE initiative.
The regulations are designed to guide local education agencies and school sites towards a process that incorporates parents and stakeholders into the process of establishing language acquisition programs to the extent possible.
As you may recall, over 70% of California voters approved Proposition 58 on November 8th of 2016.
The amended statutes became effective July 1st of 2017.
During the July meeting, the State Board of Education approved the commencement of the rulemaking process and opened a 45-day comment period for members of the public to provide public comment.
After reviewing analysis of the public comment, the California Department of Education revised the proposed regulations and responded to the comments received.
The State Board of Education approved the proposed revisions to the regulations on November 8th of 2017.
The California Department of Education circulated the proposed regulations for 15 day public comment period.
And the department accepted two recommended proposed changes from the public and made two minor technical changes.
The changes are denoted in the proposed regulations as double underlined in attachment two.
The summary of the public comment received in the California Department of Education responses is provided in attachment four.
Based on the public comments received, the two key revisions are to Section 11301, Community Engagement, Section A. As you can see in this slide, the proposed text is added in double underline, while the deleted text is displayed in double strikethrough.
The words, if applicable, are stricken and replaced
by if such a body is required by law.
This modification is necessary to clarify that pursuant to California Education Code 52063, a district with less than 50 English learners is not required to have an English Parent Advisory Committee.
So, similarly, this modification applies to Section 11301C, as you can see on this slide.
The other two minor modifications not displayed on this slide was a change to the, to an A, and the, to an N, just for clarity.
In addition, the Economic and Fiscal Impact Statement was amended, as well as the Fiscal Statement of Reason, which is your attachment three.
These are the documents that delay hearing this item in January.
Both documents now include a statement that I'm going to read to you verbatim.
To the extent the commission on state mandates determines that any of the requirements in these regulations exceed the requirements of or are not necessary and constitute a reimbursable mandate, a state will be required to provide the general fund resources to fund the required activities.
Now, the California Department of Education continues to affirm that the regulations are submitted to the state board today, as submitted to the state board today.
As in previous presentations, do not impose any cost.
This provision is more of a safeguard for any potential unforeseen cost.
The next steps and timelines are presented on this slide.
Upon approval of the commencement of the 15-day public comment period, members of the public may submit their comments to the email listed on the slide.
This will allow the public to provide input on the amendments to the proposed regulations.
The public may comment on the amendments, and as I mentioned before, those are the ones with double underlying and double strikethrough.
These are the only sections open to public comment.
All public comments that are received will be reviewed and taken into consideration during the revision of the proposed regulations.
If substantive amendments are made, then the proposed regulations would come back to the State Board in May.
If there are no revisions to the proposed regulations after the 15-day comment period, the State Board of Education considers the proposed regulations adopted.
That is what we are recommending.
Upon adoption, the regulations would then be submitted to the Office of Administrative Law.
The regulations would become final after their review and approval.
Additional information regarding this initiative is available on the California Department of Education.
And as a courtesy to the public, and since 80% of all English learners in California are Spanish speakers, the regulations presented to you today are also posted in Spanish on the California EDGE Initiative webpage.
It is anticipated that the regulations will become effective July 1st of 2018.
Thank you.
Okay.
You have more?
I wanted to just give you the implementation plan.
Once the regulations are adopted, an implementation plan has been developed and delineated in this slide, beginning with including the information and proposed English learning roadmap trainings that are planned in the summer, north, central, and south, as well as webinars in both English and Spanish.
Of course, we're going to also try for the top five languages.
We'll contract that out.
bilingual coordinators network and other conferences.
We are very fortunate that we do have the support of various institutions and they're all listed here, which is really a tribute to why this proposition passed and also to the California English Learner Roadmap.
The CDE requests the following action of the State Board to approve the commencement of the 15-day comment period, designated a formal public comment period so members of the public may provide comments on the proposed amendments, and if there's no substantive amendments after the 15-day comment period, then the proposed regulations adopted by the State Board, and direct the California Department of Education to submit the regulations to the Office of Administrative Law.
Before opening it up for questions, I would like to thank individuals in various offices that were instrumental in keeping the regulations moving, but particularly the joint collaboration between Judy Saez, Amy Holloway, and our Chief Deputy, Michelle Summa, because they really were instrumental in getting the item here.
Okay, thank you for that board member discussion.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you, Veronica, for the presentation.
And I just want to point out that this really could have been in consent because there's only two minor changes to the wording.
But we pulled it.
It was pulled from January.
So in full transparency, we wanted to give it an opportunity for the public to be aware of where we're at and also to notify the public that there is a 15 day common period.
But thank you for the presentation.
Thank you.
Any other board discussion?
If not, we're ready for public comment.
We have two public commenters, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz and Michael Flores-Castaneda.
Good morning.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We support the recommendation to go ahead and approve the regulations.
We are very pleased that a lot of work has gone into
Developing these regulations.
We've provided quite a few comments.
We've we see that they've been incorporated at least the majority of them and The field is waiting for these regulations.
And so We recommend support.
Thank you
Good morning, Michael Flores Castaneda on behalf of the California Teachers Association.
When this came up in January, we presented a letter to the board requesting that the time to respond to parents be changed from 90 to 45 days.
It had been changed to 60 days and we're requesting once again on behalf of our Language Acquisition Committee from CTA that it be changed to 45 days.
We still feel that 60 days is too long.
It's the third of the school year to respond to parents on what type of programs could be offered.
Thank you.
Okay do I have a motion on this?
Motion to move the department's recommendation.
Okay been moved and seconded.
All in favor raise your hands.
Okay that passes and we're going to take then a break before we take up the waivers and let's come back at 10 15.
Waiver 4 through 8 and waivers 10 through 15.
I would move approval of the recommendations for the actions on the waivers enumerated.
Second.
Are there any comment public comments on those waivers?
Hearing none, all in favor.
Sheila Whitley and
Is there anybody in the audience that wants to speak on these waivers?
Okay, if not, let's raise our hands.
Okay, that's done.
We have now three that we want to hear and we'll take those in order of numerics and so let's have a presentation on waiver one.
This is the Hanford Joint Union High School District Community Day Schools.
Good morning, President Kirsten, Chief Deputy Price, members.
I'm Gordon Jackson, Director of the Coordinated Student Support Division.
I'm here today to seek approval for a waiver request from Hanford Joint Union High School District.
And now then, I've got some information associated to share with you and then the recommended approval with four conditions.
Hanford Joint Union High School District, now that King's County Office of Education, as of May of 2017, is no longer providing an educational setting for expelled students, is currently providing educational placements for all expelled students who live in the district's boundaries at Hanford Community Day School.
The district is concerned about the safety of students and staff, considering the status of some of these expelled students.
and is requesting to waive portions of California Education Code Section 48663A relating to community day school minimum instructional minutes.
The district is requesting to have the option of offering an independent study placement for those students for whom the district has safety concerns.
Under normal circumstances, independent study pursuant to California Education Code 48663A may not be utilized to provide any part of minimum instructional day.
By virtue of this waiver, it is to be understood that the minimum school day pursuant to this California Education Code is to be met for all students, regardless of the instructional setting.
Thus, the 360-minute day still applies.
This waiver, for which we are only recommending approval for the period of July 1, 2017 to June 30, 2018, is also necessary to allow sufficient time for the Hanford Joint Union High School District to develop a comprehensive educational program for expelled students, including both classroom-based and independent study programs as appropriate for their students.
So, the CDE recommends approval of this waiver, but with these four conditions.
One, all of the provisions included in California Education and Code Sections 51-745 through 51-749.6 regarding independent studies shall be in place for Hanford CDS students who choose an independent study option.
Secondly, the Hanford Union High School District will develop and provide a comprehensive classroom-based educational program for Hanford CDS students who do not choose an independent study program.
It is their option.
Three, the Hanford Union High School District will develop and submit a transition plan to the CDE, which includes the aforementioned comprehensive educational program for expelled students for the 2018-2019 school year.
And lastly, this waiver shall be approved for the period of July 1, 2017 through June 30, 2018.
I submit this as a recommendation for approval of this waiver.
OK, is the board member comments on this item?
If not, is there any public comment?
So this is, Gordon, is not a typical waiver that we see in front of us and obviously independent study for kids that are already having serious concerns keeps them out.
Do they have any required, don't they have a minimum required at least contact time with the school?
And is there, this is a very short waiver, my understanding it's only till June.
So just would you clarify the specifics.
So this is an odd where you would normally not want them out of school when
They're the most struggling students.
Precisely.
I mean, one would readily say that this is not the ideal situation for a student who's been expelled.
And I know that Hanford is reacting to this new expectation on their part since the county stepped away.
and is looking for a way to pull together a program.
So it is exceptional.
We're pleased that it's for a short duration.
And I would concur, I think anyone, that this is perhaps not the ideal placement for an expelled student.
So we're gonna be very much looking forward to this comprehensive report where they explain in detail what they'll do differently for expelled students.
Board Member Valdez.
Would this include any special ed students?
As far as I know it doesn't this time around and it wouldn't be appropriate for a student with an IEP.
It would have to be, this is Judy Sias, it would have to be consistent with their IEP.
Any other questions?
Is there any public comment on this item?
All those in favor, we have a motion.
I'll move a motion to approve this waiver with the conditions.
I'll second.
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, that approves and now we're on to W3, Waiver 3, Lincoln Unified School District Non-Instructional Certificated Employees.
Morning, President Kirst, Chief Deputy Superintendent Price, board members, I'm Barbara Murchison, Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division, presenting Waiver 3.
In this waiver, Lincoln Unified School District is seeking to waive Education Code Section 44663B.
This section of code requires that the written evaluation for certificated non-instructional employees employed on a 12-month basis be provided to the employee no later than June 30th,
Then a meeting between the certificated employee and the evaluator to discuss the evaluation be held before July 30th Lincoln unified would like to move these evaluation dates from June 30th and July 30th as defined in Education Code to an unspecified date after the California assessment of student performance and progress CASP test results are made public but before September 30th The district would like to use this information in the evaluations of non-instructional certificated employees
The department is recommending a denial of this waiver under California Education Code Section 33051A4.
Pupil or school personnel protections are jeopardized.
The CASP assessment system is not designed for use in personnel evaluations.
California standardized tests do not include the required sample amount of questions to be sensitive to classroom instruction or to evaluate non-instructional employees.
The use of CASP data in an employee evaluation could jeopardize school personnel protections, those of the certificated non-instructional employee, if that evaluation contributed to the employee's dismissal.
In 2011, the board approved a similar waiver for Lincoln Unified with the condition that the standardized testing and reporting star test data not be used by the district as a basis for any adverse personnel actions.
The term of that waiver was from May 1st, 2011 through September 30th, 2011.
When the previous waiver was approved in 2011, California was using a completely different assessment system.
STAR ended in 2013 and was replaced by CASP.
With CASP, the district does not have to wait for the public report to have access to its test scores and summary reports.
Final CASP aggregate results are not reported to the public until August, but computer-based assessment results are available to LEAs two to three weeks after the student has completed all components of the assessment for the content area.
Individual student scores and preliminary summary reports are available in the CASP online reporting system.
Coordinators have access to preliminary test results and summary reports in the online reporting system for the district and all the schools within the district.
In short, if a district feels very strongly about using student summative assessment data in their evaluations, much of that data is available to them much sooner under CASP than with STAR.
Lincoln Unified typically opens their testing window in late February and closes it on June 1st, and if their testing goes well and according to plan, their reporting should be completed by mid-June, which would allow them to use
this information as part of the evaluation system consistent with the timelines laid out in Ed Code.
The waiver request is supported by the local board, the California School Employees Association, and the district's community council.
The local teacher bargaining group, which does not represent the certificated non-instructional employees, has adopted a neutral position in this matter.
So that's the information I have for you.
Again, the department is recommending denial of this waiver request.
If you have questions or I'm not certain that Lincoln is here today.
Board member discussion on this side.
All right.
Is there any public comment?
Sheila Whitley.
Good morning.
Sheila Whitley representing California Teachers Association.
We assume this request is referring to the evaluation of administrators or possibly teachers on special assignment that are serving in management positions.
The California Teachers Association is strongly opposed to any attempt
to tie test results to the evaluation of teachers.
So we certainly don't condone this attempt to tie non-instructional certificated evaluations to test scores either.
CASP was not designed for this kind of usage and we ask for the board to deny the request.
Thank you.
Board Member Strauss.
Barbara, thank you for presenting this.
I have a quick question.
You made it clear that the rationale for the waiver request is that they need the test results, but the test results do come back, so in a timely manner.
Not that we're supporting the use of that for evaluation, but I'm just wondering why they submitted it knowing that the results come in in a timely manner.
Did you follow up with them, or is this a procedural?
Yeah, we spoke with representatives of the district and they felt like they wanted to move forward with this waiver.
I can't really explain why.
Board member Rocker.
Well, I originally wasn't going to comment on the waiver, but this, because it's hard to have a conversation about this waiver and the use of the assessments without going back to the comment that President Kirst made earlier about the lack of understanding about the assessment system and about the way the assessments operate.
This waiver suggests, again, portends about the idea of a delay in receiving test scores in a timely way or in an efficient way that just is not supported by the way the assessment system works on not only processing student scores, but also on giving districts back the information in a very quick, very early and timely way.
If this waiver was approved, it would actually support the idea of delaying this reporting until these other scores come out much later in the year than what's actually available currently under the current reporting system.
So denying the waiver is not a statement by the board about whether or not the board thinks the district is using the score reports and the CASP system in an appropriate way, but more importantly,
denying the waiver holds the district accountable for using their own score reporting and the information that they get back far sooner than the timeline that they're purporting that they want approved in this waiver.
Okay, ready for a motion?
I would move the recommendation to deny this waiver.
Second.
Second by Member Burr.
All those in favor?
Okay, now we're on to Waiver 9.
This is a request by Pasadena Unified District concerning sale or lease of surplus property.
Morning President Kirst, Chief Deputy Price, Board Members, my name is Juan Mireles.
I'm the Director of the School Facilities and Transportation Services Division here at CDE.
Also with me here today is Mr. Andrew Nave who supervises the review of waivers.
Waiver 9 is a request by the Pasadena Unified School District.
The district would like to lease approximately 20,000 square feet out of a total of 40,000 square feet from the school site formerly known as Burbank Elementary School.
The school was closed in 2011 and part of the campus is currently being used for special education classrooms and offices.
The district would like to waive several sections of the education code that would require them to go through a sealed bid process.
It would also require them to select the highest bidder.
Instead, the district would like to go and use a request for proposals process that would give them greater flexibility in securing the most favorable lease for the district and the community.
This will allow the district to use other factors aside from cost as in the highest bidder in selecting a tenant that's also compatible with the current operations at the site.
Both the United Teachers of Pasadena and the California Teachers Association have submitted written opposition to this waiver.
They would prefer that the district sell or lease the site to the highest bidder.
The board has previously approved all requests to waive the same sections of the Education Code.
Therefore, staff is once again recommending that the board approve this waiver with conditions.
And those conditions are that the acceptance of the proposal be made within 60 days of accepting them.
and that the reasons for the acceptance be discussed in a public session and that they be included in the minutes for that meeting.
With that, we'd be happy to answer any questions.
Board member comments?
Yeah, I have one.
I think us getting into the details of how local districts handle these kinds of decisions is really micromanagement.
I don't feel confident at all that I know what they ought to do, so I support the waiver.
Are there any public comment on this?
Sheila Whitley and Fermin Villegas.
Speaking for California Teachers Association, there were several things that were kind of mentioned here, but what we are really objecting to is that is the portion where they want to waive accepting the bid from the highest bidder.
We feel like that we should be protecting the taxpayer here.
and that other policies and procedures that are in place in the regulations for disposing of surplus property protects the district if someone inappropriate were to be the ones applying.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kirst and members of the board.
Fermin Villegas here from Atkinson-Andelson, Lawyer Ruden-Romo, speaking on behalf of the Pasadena Unified School District.
We would simply address CTA's comment there that the RFP process that is being requested would not necessarily lead to the highest bidder not being accepted.
That process would allow the district to negotiate with the bidders that proposed so that it can get the best benefit for all students involved.
And in fact, it may even end up that the best proposal may be the one that's actually accepted.
It is important in this case because unlike in other cases, the property actually houses part of the district's special education program.
And so it is important that the district is allowed to negotiate with whoever would come in so that whatever activity is allowed there is compatible with the existing use.
We wouldn't want something that is not compatible with having students on site.
So we respectfully request that you grant the waiver.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Looks like I'm ready for a motion on this.
I will make a motion to move the staff recommendation.
Second by Member Burr.
All those in favor?
Okay, that carries unanimously.
And so now we're on to the proposed consent calendar and we have some recusals here.
So we have
recusals on waiver 11.
And we have a two-part motion.
First of all, Sue Burr and Karen Valdez must be excused for recusal.
So we will consider the first motion on proposed consent item 11.
Is there any public comment on this item?
No?
The motion is to approve just Hemet and OMI.
Yes.
OK, so is there any public comment on that part?
Yeah, just Hemet and OMI.
So I'll move approval.
OK, it's been moved and seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hand.
OK, now we have a second motion on proposed consent 11.
And we have two more recusals, board member Strauss, board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
And these are the rest of the remaining career technical education incentive grant renewal proposals from local districts.
Is there any public comment on this item?
No.
OK, I'm ready for a motion.
I'll move the item.
Seconded by Board Member Rucker.
All those in favor?
Okay.
Let's wait for our colleagues to come back and we can then move proposed consent items 12 through 18.
Proposed consent items 12 through 19.
Okay.
Are there any speakers on these motions and on these consent items, I should say?
All right.
I'm ready for a motion.
I would move.
I'll second.
Okay, Burr moved and Rucker seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, carried.
So now we're on to the first of our charter items and that is item 20 concerning the Vista Springs Charter School.
CDE will present.
Good morning board members.
My name is Lisa Constancia with the Charter Schools Division again here today.
Item 20 is an appeal by Vista Springs Charter School to establish a new charter school.
Pursuant to Ed Code section J1, petitioners for a charter school that have been denied at the local level may petition the State Board of Education for approval of a charter subject to certain conditions.
To provide you some background on Vista Springs Charter School, on August 30th, 2017, the Vista Unified School District voted to deny the petition by a vote of four to zero.
On November 8th, the San Diego County Office of Education took no action on the item.
On November 16th, 2017, the Vista Springs Charter School submitted an appeal to the State Board of Education.
Vista Springs Charter School is proposing a TK-12 program, and it is actually four educational programs.
The La Fuente Academy is a TK-8 classroom-based dual immersion program.
Their enrollment is expected at 131 for the opening year and to increase to 192 in the fifth year, 2022-23.
They are also proposing a homeschool independent study TK-12 program that is a resource center supported program, starting with an enrollment of 18 in the opening school year, increasing to 22 in the 2022-23 school year.
The third program is to be called Keys College and Career Prep High School.
It is a nine through 12 independent study program with a resource center to support it.
Enrollment starting at 15 for the first year and increasing to 25 by year five.
And the fourth program, Mosaic Academy, a TK-8, three-day classroom-based and independent study model.
This one would not be opening until the second year of operation in 2019-20, and then beginning with 32 students and increasing to 48 by that fifth year of the charter.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on February 7th and the ACCS moved California Department of Education staff's recommendation to approve the petition and the motion passed with a seven to zero vote.
In this case, the staff did not look at any additional information after the ACCS meeting because we did go with an approval recommendation to the ACCS.
So we did already feel confident we had enough information to review at that time.
And this was the one item out of the six that we did initially recommend approval on.
So that's why we didn't look at any additional information, just to let you know.
CDE recommends that the state board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish Vista Springs for a five-year term.
The recommendation is based on demonstrably likely to implement the attendant program due to a realistic financial and operational plan.
and a sound educational practice and comprehensive description of most of the charter elements in the petition.
CDE staff is here for any questions you may have.
Thank you.
OK, technical questions.
Yes.
Just on the chronology, you said San Diego County did not act.
Did they consider the petition, or did they just punt?
They did have staff recommendations.
Their recommendations were to deny, but they, within their 30 day, did not take action.
So did they hold a hearing, do you know?
Yes, they did hold a hearing.
Thank you.
And I think the county office is here also if you have any questions.
Okay, so I'm going to open the public hearing now and first we will hear from the supporters of the CDE staff recommendation to approve the charter school petition.
The petitioners have a total of 10 minutes.
Then the district and county will have a chance to speak against the CDE recommendation and to oppose the charter school.
They will also have ten minutes.
So now I have the public hearing open so we will now move to the ten minute presentation by the supporters of the petition.
Good morning.
My name is Dr. Kathleen Hermsmeyer.
I am the superintendent of the Springs Charter School Network of Schools.
It's my pleasure to be here today to present our Vista Springs Charter petition to you.
It's especially gratifying to stand here with CDE's recommendation for approval and the ACCS unanimous recommendation for approval, so that's delightful.
I wanted to tell you that I brought my leadership team with me, my senior leadership team available to answer your questions if you have any related to education or special ed or EL or business.
And so they're back there.
And Harbor Springs Charter Schools is in its fifth year of operations.
And our program at La Fuente and Vista is in the fourth year of operation.
Our Springs Resource Centers provide a continuum of service
to families who want a more parent-involved program.
They want some independent study, some home study, and some classroom support.
So it's a more supported version of a homeschool charter.
It may, we also provide special ed and English language development services at the center.
And so we are providing, like as she said, four different programs and personalized learning in every one of them.
So it's one mission, but it's a continuum according to the needs of the parent.
So, whoops, that was what I was supposed to be on, that slide.
All right, so I'll move to the next slide.
We always consider the needs of our students in each local area and we build a continuum of programs, as I've said.
In Vista, parents really wanted a dual immersion program.
Vista Unified School District does not have a bilingual dual immersion program on offer.
We built one with the help of our really qualified, fantastic team.
In looking at the needs of our community of learners, we decided when the ODIC situation, the Shasta decision came up, we decided when we were taking the opportunity to petition to change the program from a four-day model to a five-day seat-based model for the dual immersion program, because that better met the needs of our families.
This is a graphic of our transition plan that was attached to our state waiver.
Once the Anderson decision was made, we immediately began work on a local petition to come into alignment with the decision.
We began drafting the charter petition in December of 2016 to submit to the local district, Vista Unified.
We first submitted our petition in February and we were denied in April.
We took all the reasons for denial and added 220 pages of detail to the charter petition and went back to Vista Unified because we had felt that they were open to that.
But then when we went back, we were denied again in August.
So then we appealed to the county, our appeal to the San Diego County was split with no action taken.
And so that's how we came to be here today.
So we appreciate the thorough review by your staff and we are happy to modify our charter petition to satisfy the three concerns that they had within the petition and they were mostly technical or smaller.
So and we're happy to make those changes.
Our building is fantastic.
It was remodeled seven years ago and it's approved for use as a school with a gym, a full kitchen for a national school lunch program, and it's, as you know, for charter schools, a good facility is very hard to come by.
We're delighted to have found such a great school location and we're in a lease for three more years with our own option for five more after that.
And so, in closing, we do have a few parents, students, and staff here to speak to you today, but I'd like to show you a two-minute video of our students and staff at their school site in Vista.
Bienvenidos!
Hi, my name's Sophia.
Welcome to my school.
Let's go take a look at La Fuente Academy.
I'm Amy Heald, and I'm the principal of La Fuente.
The spring's vision is about empowering parents and about empowering students to set their own goals in life and learning, and also about making the community the classroom.
So it's really one thing.
La Fuente to me means a place where everyone can learn.
Learning a language opens not only that language up to them, but it opens the world to them.
It helps them connect in all areas, mathematics, music, and even in English, they learn how to speak better because of learning the second language.
Some of the research that we have shows that the curve of learning of a student who is learning in two languages
takes off around third or fourth grade, and they surpass in their academic achievement.
So when I came here, I felt very welcomed.
I didn't speak any Spanish before.
It was a little challenging at first, but my teachers made it really easy for me.
Sometimes people think that children have to be under the age of seven.
Some of the research says that that is the best time to learn a language.
But it isn't too late.
And that's why here at La Fuente, we not only try to encourage the children to learn to speak the second language, we encourage their parents to participate in that as well.
Because it really, really does open the world to you.
This is Alistair.
He's in...
Great.
What inspired you to speak Spanish or is it like from your culture?
I like to make secret messages so I think doing this and then having like one of my friends knowing Spanish would be like a really good way like if we were in a club
to know what we're saying when we're talking to each other.
Like a secret code.
Yeah, pretty much.
I want them to love learning, and I want them to be empowered to learn.
That they don't need to know the language of the people fully to be able to interact with them in a positive way.
It's that joy.
And when you feel excited about every day of your job or your experience at school, how can that not be a wonderful learning experience?
Okay, that concludes my presentation.
Okay, now we have 10 minutes for the opponents to the CDE recommendation and to the charter petition.
Okay, I see nobody signed up then.
Okay, so now we'll move to public comment.
Public hearing is still on.
With the following people, please line up.
Michael Castaneda, Amy Heald, Molly Elkins, Audrey Elkins, Candace Lynch, Havana Lynch Castillo, Tom VanHoekelum, Jeff Rice, and Romel Antoine.
Thank you.
Please come forward.
And identify yourself, and if you're with an organization, identify that.
One minute, yeah.
Absolutely.
Good morning.
Buenos dias.
I'm Amy Hilt.
You just saw me on the video with some of my students.
I'm the principal of La Fuente.
And like so many of us in California, and maybe some of you, I am the grandchild of pioneers.
My family came to the Imperial Valley in 1908, and they braved the terrible summer heat as they worked with other families to create an enduring agricultural community.
Being a pioneer is all about making sacrifices to make your dreams and the dreams of others come true.
All of us at Springs Charter Schools act as pioneers every day as we work to innovate learning experiences specifically tailored to our students.
At La Fuente we are a community who want our children to be bilingual and biliterate.
Some students have grandparents who only speak Spanish.
Some dream of having their children better equipped for this multilingual world.
Some just think it's fun.
No matter the reason, families are choosing our program and students are thriving with us.
Please allow us to continue to ignite the excitement of discovery in our students by voting for our charter.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Hello, my name is Molly Elkins and I'm the director of instruction for a small educational company.
Quality of education is very important to me.
When my daughter entered TK, we were very happy to find La Fuente.
It's not like any of the other schools in our area.
It is community focused and offers bilingual immersion.
I was homeschooled and a French major in college, so student-centered learning and languages are very important to me.
I was immediately impressed with the mixed-grade classrooms and activities.
Audrey has opportunities to learn with kids of varied age levels, and she's also had an opportunity to learn a language in an immersive classroom.
I wanted my daughter to learn a language from a young age in order to develop fluency.
At La Fuente, there's a culture of learning and sharing among students, parents, and teachers.
What this looks like is a friendly, nurturing environment and comfortable, easy relationships between our family and all of the La Fuente staff.
A benefit that I didn't expect is that my daughter isn't intimidated when she meets someone who doesn't look like her or speak her first language.
Please authorize Vista Springs so that we can continue building this diverse community.
Hi my name is Audrey Elkins and I'm here because it's worth the trip to tell you about my school.
There are three things I especially love about my school.
I love the fact that my school is small and there are lots of people who care about me.
Not just my teacher, but all of the teachers and people in the office too.
I like that I'm someone who helps create my school.
If I think way back to the beginning, I remember when I was in TK that I got to help unpack the desks and chairs and practice using the screwdriver to put the desks together.
I like that I get to learn Spanish so that when I am a grown up,
I can make friends in lots of other countries where they speak Spanish.
When I grow up, I want to be a singer and sing all around the world.
Hola, buenos dias.
Hello everyone, my name is Havana Dorsady and I'm really excited to be here.
I've never been on a plane before and it was very exciting to fly here.
And some of my family even came to hear me speak.
I want to tell you about my school La Fuente Academy because I get to learn Spanish there and since Spanish was my first language, it is one of my dreams to continue learning and practicing my Spanish.
Does anyone know what La Fuente means?
It means a fountain, but to me it means a fountain of knowledge.
My school is about learning adventures and ever since kindergarten, our teachers and visitors have inspired us to learn and make our life an adventure.
I hope you'll approve to La Fuente Academy so we can all get back to our learning and our adventures.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Candace Lynch.
Thank you for the opportunity to share our stories on why La Fuente Academy is dear to our hearts.
Spanish was my first language.
However, I quickly picked up English before kindergarten.
I didn't have the opportunity to attend a bilingual school like La Fuente, so I only spoke it when needed, which was in conversing with my grandmother.
When I was nine years old, she passed away, and I no longer found a need to continue my Spanish.
I began to forget the language and quickly became very self-conscious.
In high school, I took Spanish classes, but to be honest, I had a very difficult time relearning my first language.
It was a lot harder than I expected.
However, with constant exposure and practice, learning Spanish has added great value to my life skills as well as to my resume and my career.
My hope is to provide my daughter with the opportunities that I didn't have, and La Fuente Academy offers those successful opportunities.
I hope you will consider the value and potential of our school as we look forward to taking our education to the next level.
Thank you for your time.
Hola y buenos dias.
My name is Tom Van Heukelen and I have the joy of teaching 5th through 8th grades at La Fuente under the oversight of the Springs Charter Schools.
La Fuente offers the only dual language immersion program in Vista and the surrounding communities.
This program helps our kids develop critical thinking skills, creativity, and communication skills.
A dual language immersion program takes what's traditionally considered a challenge
and makes it an asset as native Spanish speakers and native English speakers model language both in the classroom and on the playground.
Students use both languages to study, communicate, and to get their desires and needs met.
They learn to value both languages, both cultures, and the racial divide disappears.
The dual language model is a proven model and has above average test scores in schools where the English learner population and poverty rate are often higher than in the surrounding schools.
This school is the only opportunity for students in our area to participate in a dual language immersion program, and we all hope you will see the appropriateness of granting our charter.
Please.
Thank you.
Good morning, Michael Flores Castaneda, California Teachers Association.
And we're here to speak in opposition of the staff recommendation based not only on the findings of the district and the county school board for the unsound educational program and the unlikelihood of a successful implementation, but also because of the lack of the declaration to consider itself the exclusive employer of those, exclusive public employer of those employees.
So on behalf of those would-be employees and their rights, those educators' rights, we ask you to deny the staff recommendation.
Thank you.
California Charter Schools Association here to speak in support of Vista Springs.
They are an existing program and this is the first of many items that we'll see over the next few months out of the Shasta V. Anderson decision.
that schools are coming out of waivers and asking this board to consider their approval for a new program, which is similar to what they were running before.
What's really strong about Vista Springs is that they have taken the opportunity in this waiver time to improve their program and to listen to their community to improve their offerings.
And so we asked this board to move ACCS's recommendation and CDE's recommendation of support.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
Jeff Rice with the A Plus Personalized Learning Network Association.
I'm also here in support of the Vista Springs Charter Petition Appeal and would like to ask for your support as well.
I have worked very closely with Dr. Hernsmeyer and her leadership team now for more than 15 years and can attest to the fact that they run an excellent program that is very successful.
with a strong commitment to a personalized learning model of education and to high standards of academic excellence and accountability.
It bears emphasis in repeating that in good faith, Vista Springs submitted its petition twice to the local district
and was denied the first time, and then they corrected all of the errors that were cited, went back a second time with all of those corrections, and were denied for a completely different set of reasons, which makes one wonder whether they would have been approved under any circumstances.
So therefore, I urge you to step in and do what is right for the parents and students in the San Diego community and approve this charter.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
Again, in support.
I'll associate myself with the prior two speakers in the interest of time.
Innovative program, one that continues to evolve even after umpteen years to meet the evolving needs of the community.
Thank you.
OK, that concludes the public hearing.
And we've heard all the public comments.
So now we're ready for conversation among the board, comments from the liaisons.
Do you want to start with comments from the liaisons?
Well, how about from the board, if there's any board comments?
OK, liaisons first.
This is, from my viewpoint, probably one of the easier appeals for today, for this afternoon, with the ACCS recommendation, with the CDE recommendation, with no opposition showing up, with the county not taking action, and with the presentation.
I am very comfortable recommending this school for approval.
Other board comments on that?
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
Yes, bienvenidos.
I also agree, I think this is probably the easiest of the proposals coming before us, but one of the things that I appreciate is that it is a unique model.
It's a language model that is not offered, a DI model not offered by the district.
The districts didn't show up to express how this would be a burden in their own communities.
And we don't see a community divided.
And I have to say that yesterday I left here with a very, very heavy heart.
And so this is a type of charter proposals that I like to see.
And I feel like this is something I could fully support legally and also it's right with my heart and my mind.
Thanks.
OK, seeing no other comment, I'm ready for a motion.
Liaison might make a motion.
I move approval of CDE's recommendation to authorize this school.
Second by Holiday.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, that carries unanimously.
OK, we're now on to item
21, this is the Bay Point Preparatory Academy in the San Marcos Unified School District.
Okay, item 21 is an appeal by Bay Point Preparatory Academy in San Diego to establish a new charter school.
August 15, 2017, the San Marcos Unified School District voted to deny the petition by a vote of 5-0.
November 8, 2017, the San Diego County Board of Education voted to deny the petition by a vote of 3-2.
November 29, 2017, Baypoint submitted a petition on appeal to the State Board of Education.
Bay Point San Diego is proposing a TK-12 site-based program.
Their targeting enrollment is 200 in the first year of operation, increasing to 600 by year 2022-23.
Also, to let the board members know, there is an existing school, existing Bay Point school, Bay Point Preparatory Academy that is currently authorized by the state board.
It is a K-12 classroom-based program, similar to the one that is being proposed today, and it is in Hemet, California.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on February 7, 2018, and the ACCS moved to recommend approval of the petition on the condition that CDE would verify the revised budget and ensure that the revised budget was sound.
This motion was passed by a vote of six to one.
CDE staff did review the revised budget as requested by the ACCS.
The CDE recommendation is that the state board hold a public hearing to deny the request to establish Bay Point Academy San Diego.
And the recommendation is based on the demonstratively unlikely to implement the program, mainly based on their fiscal reserves, that they have very minimal fiscal reserves.
I'm here and available for any questions that you might have.
Okay, Board Member Williams.
Could you repeat what their fiscal reserves are currently projected to be for year one?
Yes, for year one they're at 3.4% and we are comfortable at about a 5% reserve.
And I can't remember who said this or where I heard it yesterday that
either statute or regulations or policy, something like that, expects schools to be at 5%, charter schools to be at 5% by the end of year two.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
What the, no, that's not true?
Someone in the audience is shaking their head that that's not true.
Okay.
That has been, from my understanding, the 5% reserve has been our policy.
It is in our MOUs also.
Did they make some changes or take a look at their budget?
Did you take a look at their budget?
We did.
How much is it?
It is 3.4%.
Other than that, the rest of the budget looked okay?
Yes.
And this school is, as I understand it, is a second school.
We already authorized one of the, a school, Hemet.
Correct.
That we authorize.
And this is a second school in that charter management organization.
That's correct.
And Hemet, for Hemet, when did we authorize that?
That one was authorized in 2015 and 2016.
It expires in 2020 with the board.
Has CDE had a reason to issue any kind of letters of concern about either their operations or their finances?
No, I actually just confirmed this morning, we have issued a letter of academic support, and that is really to have a discussion with them on where their dashboard, there's some oranges on their dashboard, but that is more of just of a conversation between staff and the charter school.
But in terms of fiscal, their first interim report has come back fine, and we just received their second interim report.
We haven't had a chance to analyze that yet, but they seem to be in good fiscal standing.
Okay.
Other board member questions before we open up the public hearing?
Okay, I now declare the public hearing open.
Each side will have 10 minutes so we'll start with the people who support the petition in this case and oppose the CDE recommendation.
Yeah.
Might need some tech support from our control room, because the screen's gone blank.
I believe.
Okay, go ahead.
Good morning, State Board and CD staff.
My name is Nancy Spencer and I'm the lead petitioner for Bay Point Repertory Academy in San Diego.
First of all, before we get going, I'd like to thank the staff, CD staff for all of the time and energy and effort that they have put into reviewing our petition and supporting documents.
As I said, my name is Nancy Spencer, and I want to introduce our team to you that put this petition together.
I have been in education for 46 years.
I hold elementary, secondary, and administrative credentials.
I have been in the charter world for 13 years.
I have opened three successful charter schools.
Two of those schools were from the beginning, and one of them was a school, Bayshore, in San Marcos that was going to be closed.
We initially, on all three of the schools, received full WASC accreditation at the first visit.
In the first school that I was in, in Ventura, Oxnard area, it was an ASAM 9-12 high school with 80% Hispanic, and we had one of the fourth highest API scores in the state with that school.
Frank Aguaro is our board chair.
He's been in business for over 20 some years.
He has been in Charterworld for 12 years with a parent and as well as nine years on the charter board.
He was the founder of Baypoint and Hemet as well, and he was an immigrant from Uganda during his teen years.
Heather Herrera is our Director of Education.
She has been in education 11 years.
She's been in the charter world for about the last five years.
She holds her multiple subject credential, and her emphasis is in reading instruction.
She's worked as a special education behavioral interventionist, and she is also instrumental in developing our K-5 blended learning program that we use out in Bay Point and Hemet.
Thomas Dell and Bill Jaeger are two other board members who are also founders of Bay Point and this school.
They collectively have over 40 years experience in business as well as nine and four years respectfully as charter board members.
Our proven track record, our first school, Bayshore, that is located in San Marcos, opened in 2005.
It's a K-12, non-classroom-based instruction program.
It received WASC initial accreditation on its first term out, and in 2014, received the highest WASC accreditation, the sixth year with a mid-term report due.
It has 41 ACG courses.
It also has its NCAA-approved courses, which is very difficult for an independent study school to acquire that.
It took us two years to do that.
We had two unanimous approvals, renewals with that school.
I came to Bayshore in 2010, the spring.
2009-10, they were in a year where the district was going to close them down.
hired me with the intent of getting the school turned around and as we did we were able to get a unanimous approval at the end of that year renewal as well as another five year.
Bayshore's academics are track record.
With the API, you can see from the graph that every year they've continued to improve and exceed what the amount was suggested by the growth that should be each year in API.
And when CASP was initiated and implemented, we also have continued to improve that.
We had one slight drop, as you see in the math, but we implemented some changes in our program, and as a result, our scores continue to increase.
The subgroups, we also looked at our subgroups with the API, as well as our CASP results.
And as you can see, those two have continued to increase with those groups.
We looked at Hispanic and socioeconomics in the API, and then our economically disadvantaged in English and math.
We wanted to get a comparison for this year to see how we've done compared to our local district as well as our county and the state.
And in ELA, we were pretty close to what San Marcos had as far as both with all students as well as the economically disadvantaged students.
In our math, we actually exceeded the outperformed the district, the county, and the state as well, both in all students and in the economically disadvantaged.
Our subgroup population at Bayshore has continued to be above 50%.
We were at 61, as you can see on the graph, and this year it's at 52.6 with the unduplicated.
That is a lot higher than what the district is.
The district has been slowly decreasing.
They're at 40 this year, but without recruiting that population, we have continued to be high.
And our special education population, you can also see, has remained consistent.
Our budget, well our priority location is to locate in the geographic area of one of these three elementary schools and to correct it we're a TK8 program not a TK12.
So we're TK6 the first year and then adding 7th and 8th the following consecutive years.
Our budget, we've allocated $10,000 to market towards these populations and those are the statistics for the unduplicated count in
those elementary boundaries, and we have conservatively estimated 75% that we've put forecasts into our budget.
Our second school, as you know, is a state board approved charter that was approved in 2015, Bay Point Preparatory.
It's a K-12.
It received WASC on its initial accreditation.
It also has its A through G40 courses approved.
And we do have the NCAA courses that have been approved, as well as we are in our first year of CIF competition.
And we offer music, art, and PE.
I want to take a look at our first year in operation, what our CASP results were compared to the local school, elementary and middle, as well as the district.
And as you can see, Bay Point, in the blue, outperformed almost consistently across the all-student grade levels, as well as with our economically disadvantaged students in ELA.
Also in math, we looked at that, and as you can see, the same thing.
Bay Point, again, outperformed consistently pretty much all the local school as well as the district in both the all-student and the economically disadvantaged.
In the science, which was the last year that the CST was administered in our first year of operation, we also took a look at how our students performed, both the all students and economically disadvantaged by the three grade levels that are tested.
As you can see that Bay Point did perform all except for maybe one where they outperformed the local school or the district.
In year two of the CASP, we also did a comparison just to see how do we measure up, because we're serving the same populations in our school as in the surrounding areas.
And this is for the ELA and the all students as well as economically disadvantaged.
Again, math for the CASP last year, the same thing.
We did a comparison so we could see how we're measuring up with populations that are in our geographic region.
We wanted to look at last year, since our population increased and our school grew, how our EL students as well as our SPED students did compared to the local district.
And the scores from my perspective aren't high, what they should be, but in comparison with what's going on around us, we still did exceptional with the ELA and the math.
Our subgroup population has continued to grow in the three years that we have been in existence, and it's now up to 76% for the free and reduced lunch population.
Our EL population dropped this year at the beginning when we took the CBEDS numbers, and I'll explain in the next slide.
And our SPED population continues to increase.
The reason that our EL population dropped, as you can see on this slide, is at Bay Point, we reclassified 50% of our students.
At Bayshore, we reclassified 70%, and it's broken down by the various grade levels.
And I'm excited about one student that was a 11th grader at our school who was EL, and he reclassified, and he was also a SPED student, so that's encouraging to see we were able to get him over that hump.
finances that's an issue of concern and i wanted to bring up this in our my side presentation about our track record with our finances as i mentioned to you that i began in the school in the spring of two thousand and ten so that's the last year at the bottom that i've done any numbers for you
I walked in the door of that school and was told the day I started I had to cut $100,000 from the budget.
Well, as you can see, we were able to do that, and with the data about our academics, our scores, our academics were not impacted by that.
And so every year I put on here this table, the projected and the actuals, because we're showing you
We do know how to adjust a budget and how to work a budget.
A budget is a proposal, and then what happens is you adjust it and modify it as you go on.
Bay Point, as you can see, ended the first year with 13.26 percent, higher than what we had initially projected, and we're set to end the year with 18 percent.
This is just a graph of where we were and how it looks from the previous table.
And contingency budget, the numbers that you were asking about earlier, you can see the 2018-19, it's $113,000, and we came up with $5.69.
The CD staff was saying $3.4 based on a $67.
Those numbers are because the lottery funds
and the $5,000 in fundraising we'd included in the budget were removed, hence the discrepancy between our budget and the budget that they have.
We have also applied.
We're in the process of starting the PCSGP grant application, which we received for Bay Point, and we attended the workshop on Monday and will be submitting that application.
Just a reminder in August that you were in the report that CDE presented to the SBE.
It shows how the schools that they oversee did academically and financially.
And as you can see, Bay Point met both the academic and was considered good financial standing.
And that was only eight of the 22 schools that had both of those criterias met.
Again, Bay Point Preparatory will be a replication of what we've been doing up in Hammett.
We're doing it in San Marcos.
It'll be a TK-8 program, college prep.
It's going to be data-driven.
We're going for the WASC accreditation in the first year and the low student-teacher ratio.
So I ask for your support in approving Bay Point Preparatory Academy San Diego.
Thank you.
Okay, 10 minutes for the opponents.
District and county people.
Going once, twice.
Okay.
No, no appearance by opponents.
So we will then begin the public comment.
Will the following individuals please line up at the podium?
Angela Ramos, Brian Adams, Heather Herrera, Frank Aguaro, Richard Homsberger, Steve Nelson, Rommel Antone, Eric Premack, and that's it.
Good morning.
My name is Brian Adams with Abacus Education Partners.
I helped prepare the budget for the CHAR petition.
The budget we submitted actually has reserves of 5.7% in year one, but the CDA staff adjusted our budget by taking away two of our revenue streams, which is how they arrived at reserves of less than 5%.
These two revenue streams are fundraising and year one lottery.
The fundraising revenue of 5,000 is less than one-fifth of what we normally raise in each of the other two schools that we operate.
But even if we don't include any of that fundraising revenue, we still exceed the more than 5% reserve threshold because the $35,000 in lottery revenue for year one should be included.
We have demonstrated this in our recent correspondence, which you have a copy of, which states that in accordance with accrual basis accounting, the lottery revenue is properly included in year one revenue because that is the year in which this revenue is earned.
That's all.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Heather Herrera, and I will be the Director of Education at Baypoint San Diego.
I want to thank you for your time this morning.
As a member of the petitioning team, I've been deeply involved in the development of our educational program, and as a former classroom teacher, I've used both the model and the materials that we've outlined for you in the petition.
As you can see, based on Nancy's slides, what we put together in the educational program is a replication of what we're currently successfully implementing at Hemet.
And as you can also see in Nancy's slides, we have been able to meet the diverse needs of our different diverse student populations.
I also wanted to bring your attention to the number of signatures and our parent letters that we've submitted to you.
There's truly a need in the San Marcos community for a alternative to what's currently being offered for our site-based schools.
So again, I wanted to thank you again for your time and your review.
And if you have any questions about the educational program, I'd be happy to answer those.
Thank you.
Good morning, SBE Board members.
My name is Frank Aguaro, President of Baypoint Hemet and Bayshore San Marcos.
With Baypoint San Diego, we included the $35,000 in lottery revenue in the budget because it's earned in year one consistent with the accrual method of accounting.
Although we also have the option to withdraw down on an available $2 million in working capital, cover this, our contingency pro forma, before he requires no need to borrow.
Short the lottery in fundraising revenue, the changes in year one reserves from 5.6 to 3.4, which can certainly be addressed in a technical clarification.
CDE staff did find that all other concerns were addressed and the school has a multi-year positive fund balance.
As with our current schools, this third school will maintain adequate reserves and remain cash flow positive.
For reconsideration, I hope our track record and response to staff findings gives you the confidence that we have the ability to successfully implement the intended program.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Richard Hansberg.
I represent Bay Point.
I think it's important to note two things.
First, you see no opposition here today.
I think that's testimony to the strength of this school and its organizational capability.
And second, I'd note that at the district level, there were no findings and zero findings made regarding the educational program at this school.
And the only two findings were made regarding
The UPP are the unduplicated pupil percentages in the facilities.
At the county level on Peel, just the opposite occurred.
No findings regarding finances or facilities and findings only regarding the educational program.
So now here we are at the state level dealing with a very narrow issue.
Do lottery funds accrue in year one?
I think we've submitted credible evidence that the answer is absolutely yes.
I urge your support for Baypoint Preparatory Academy.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, board members and staff.
Thank you for your service to our state.
I'm Steve Nelson.
This application is for a school in my community where my family and I have lived for 25 years and where I have my business.
Our district has doubled in size over that time and is building new schools and yet has declining LCFF revenue.
They're strapped for cash and now discussing things like eliminating PE teachers and class size ratios.
We have hundreds of new homes in neighborhoods with new schools, three schools torn down and replaced with all new buildings, a high school for $150 million that holds 3,500 students and is now over capacity two years later, and an elementary school that will be converted for $63 million that holds over 1,100 students.
The district staff claimed that Bay Point's budget overstated its future enrollment of underserved children.
However, who better to provide the smaller scale focused attention and high expectations for underserved students than these leaders who have a stellar record over three years under the watchful eye of CDE staff.
For our community, please approve the school.
Thank you.
I just want to speak on a couple of issues.
First, I want to talk about the leadership of this school.
Nancy is the superintendent.
Frank is the president of the board.
It is clear through their presentation that they know how to manage a school in multiple programs, especially one that is authorized under the state.
They have shown through their academic success and their fiscal success that they know how to do this well.
We're happy that they were able to show that they have different ways of meeting the state's requirements around their reserves and how they can do that through no cut to the actual services that are provided to students.
So we know that they are able to do this program very well, and we look forward to the state supporting their school.
Thank you so much.
Hi, Angela de Ramos representing California Teachers Association.
We urge the board to deny the petition based on the CDE's findings regarding the minimal fiscal reserves.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
This one should be a slam dunk.
Another organization with a successful track record operationally, academically, financially.
With respect to the reserves issue, I'm going to quote directly from the regulations that govern how you guys are supposed to review appeals.
And it says, quote unquote, present a budget that in its totality appears viable over a period of no less than two years of operations provides for the amassing
of a reserve equivalent to that required by law for a district of similar size.
So what that essentially says is that over a two-year period that you get to the
reserve level that districts are expected, even by CDE's numbers, which underestimate the revenues, they meet that requirement.
And they exceeded and hit 9% reserve by year three, even using CDE's numbers, which we have heard are factually in error because they do not include the lottery, et cetera, funding that should be there.
So here, I think you have a slam dunk.
I urge you to approve.
Thank you.
Okay, I now declare the public hearing closed and I think we should have CDE come up and discuss this reserve issue.
In terms of the lottery and the fundraising, those are typical, we typically do take that out when we're reviewing a fiscal analysis.
So that, those are amounts that we do take out and then take a look at the budget and see if there are at least a 5% reserve.
So that has been what we have continually done.
And why would the lottery not come through?
I don't, what is the grounds for that being uncertain?
My understanding is that that comes through in year two.
It actually just dawned on me what is going on here.
This is a bit of a technical issue.
You've heard the accountants and fiscal managers for the charter say they're using accrual basis.
Governmental entities don't use accrual basis.
They use modified accrual basis.
That's what we use to look at this.
We score the revenues when they are available, not when they're earned.
They're doing accounting for the nonprofit.
The laws for the nonprofit say you score the revenues when they are earned as opposed to when they are available.
It is a bit of a technical issue.
When we look at these projections, we care about
They care about the economic condition.
We care about the fiscal condition.
So and particularly for the projection.
So we want to see when the revenues are available to be spent versus what their expenditures are as opposed to, you know, generally the, you know, I'd say the economic value of the entity.
And what do you make of Mr. Premack's assertion about two years in whatever he read from, I'm not sure what the source of that was.
Yeah, I think it's just a matter of, for me, confidence.
The first budget that was submitted contained a lot of errors in the way they were calculating revenues and other things like that.
They came back.
They made some adjustments.
Looked like, you know, I saw a very close look at the adjustments they were making.
They seemed reasonable, but still, given that the tightness of the budget, it didn't give me a strong sense of confidence that
they would, that I could rely on the new set of books that they'd given us, given the closeness of the budget versus the errors that had been made in the first set of books they gave us.
So that's kind of where.
was a little bit maybe the tipping point for us on this.
But it's just a level of confidence in what they're presenting.
But you said they met the 5% in the second year.
And what was the document he was quoting from?
So I'm not sure you agree they met the 5% in the second year.
And I'd like to know, was that law or I'm not familiar?
It's law.
OK.
He was quoting from a law.
Regulations?
I think it's the regulations.
What?
Regulations are law.
OK.
They were official regulation.
I believe so, but I'll check.
OK.
All right, I'm sorry, Board Member Holliday wants to get in on this, yeah.
And then we'll go around, yeah.
That's our liaison.
Ask something from the petitioner.
Oh, the petitioner?
OK.
Yes, please.
We didn't run into this problem with the prior school in terms of the fiscal projection.
But the fiscal projection that you had with the existing school in the end was the actual significantly above the original prediction?
I believe so, yes.
And secondly,
A lot of this is based on enrollment, right?
Enrollment is- Yeah, enrollment drives your revenue.
Doesn't it?
And so if this is a thin budget, it makes enrollment really important, right?
Tell me about your enrollment.
The projected enrollment
Well, we're projecting 225 in each grade level, starting with TK through 6th grade.
And as I said, we'll roll up to 7th and 8th in the following years.
But that's why we put $10,000 in the budget to actively go out and recruit students in the area.
Our signatures that we have, and that was the last slide, had 198 signatures.
student represented signatures so that's close to the 200 we're looking without doing marketing and we targeted that community we went door to door knocking doors and talking about the options and what was there as well so we didn't go looking we haven't really done any
promotion out in the community because we don't exist yet so that's what we're waiting for is to go out and have that opportunity and I realize what that revenues having been in it that the enrollment drives your revenue so and we've had to as you see as you might have noted on that previous slide that I had about our projected versus what the actuals were but yeah we were able to go back we do with the first interim and the second interim and final budget year and
we go back and we re-evaluate where we are.
And we have done that consistently over the last 13 years.
I have with the schools and with Bay Point and Bayshore for the last eight, almost nine, or nine years now.
And we run a lean, mean fighting machine if we have to.
But our top priority is making sure
that our academics are not impacted.
And that's why in those slides I put so much of that data, not just so the whole school, but our economically disadvantaged, our ELs and our BED students.
So we are really conscious of what that looks like and making sure that we can support our students and support our staff with the program that we implement.
So in Hemet, the initial year of enrollment was successful.
Yes, we projected 325.
I think our P2 was a 260, I believe.
So it was, you know, yeah.
And our enrollment fluctuated around what it was.
But it's the same thing.
We had three months with our last school to go out and promote the school and to advertise that it was there.
So it was really a struggle, because we lost people who initially had joined us, because it's a year process.
I've been through that.
I know how tricky that can be.
But at the same time, even though you didn't quite make the projected enrollment attempt at the beginning, financially you were able to adjust to the point where you were successful and did not receive any sort of concern or warning from the CDE.
Is that correct?
No, correct.
And you're prepared to make that kind of adjustment, of course, if necessary.
Absolutely.
And the communities are obviously different to a certain extent, but at the same time, you do have a little bit longer, if this were to be approved, you would have a little bit longer to do the marketing.
Correct.
Two extra months.
that can be significant.
Yes, definitely.
And also it's all a time when when we were approved before in May, it's towards the end of the school year, and so we were really trying to recruit and promote our school during the summer.
With this school, at least we have the, when people are at the end of the school year looking at options and changes and things, we have an opportunity not only to recruit students, but to recruit staff, qualified staff, because most people have already been hired, a lot of your good quality teachers have, so that's
One of the concerns, obviously the department is not entirely comfortable with the financial situation.
Would you be willing for the department to be closely monitoring that?
Absolutely, I have no problem with that.
We've always tried to be, ever since my coming in with Bayshore, when there was issues and there was contention with the district with San Marcos ready to shut the school down and very distrusting of what was going on, I've always felt that that's important, is to be open and honest and forthright about what's there.
If there's a problem, I have no problem explaining that and seeking help, but so yeah, I'm absolutely.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Williams.
Will this school be eligible to apply for public charter school grant funds and would you intend to do so?
Yes, the PCSGP, they just opened that up on the 5th of March and the deadline is April 3rd, so Monday we sat in the training all day with the staff, CD staff about getting that and we've already had conversations with budget and how we're going to put that in our budget.
Gentleman went to the meeting yes, Tuesday in Sacramento here in this room, so.
And do you have any idea, did you apply for a certain amount or do you know what the amounts are?
The amounts are different this year.
It's a whole new structure.
It's $475,000 for the initial grant and an additional $100,000 on the unduplicated numbers, but that's not based on where you reside.
It's based on your population once you have your enrollment in C-BEDS day.
If you were awarded that, when would that come in?
When would you get it?
It comes fairly quickly we have to we can start the way it's done.
It's reverse reverse It's reimbursements.
It's not initial up front So you have to you can start submitting any expenditures that you have starting April 5th So anything that we incur starting that date that is allowable under the grant we will start Expending those and then getting reimbursements submitting for those we have it's a very short window.
We have to spend
Spent all the money by July of 2019, July 31st.
So it's not the normal three years.
It's a very like a one and a 15 month, one year and a half process for spending it.
Okay, thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
This is, I guess, for the department.
I'm actually looking at the dashboard, which is the new accountability system that we have, versus API.
And one of the things that I'm looking at, just one indicator, ELA, and I see that maybe the schools, I'm looking at Bay Point, maybe it's doing better for some of the student subgroups relative to some of the neighboring schools.
But internally, you have a lot of work to do.
I see a pretty significant achievement gap between your Latino students and your white students, where your white students made a 14-point gain and your Latino students declined by 10.8 points.
And for your English learners, I see that although a small number of students, they're also very low in terms of status.
So that is concerning to me because once you start peeling back the data dashboard, the orange is really triggered by your Latino students and their numbers are pretty comparable to the numbers of white students, 79 and 70.
So I would like us, as we're looking at providing support to our charter schools, that we're looking not only how they compare to the schools in the surrounding community, but how they're doing to serve the students that they have and prevent internal achievement gaps that are happening in both indicators.
You see it in math and you see it in ELA.
And I don't even have an ELP indicator that could just be the newness of the school.
Thank you.
That's a concern for me.
Thanks.
I just have a quick question for the petitioner and then I think for Nick.
I'm confused because the names are similar.
Bayshore Preparatory Academy or school, is that authorized by San Marcos?
Yes, it is.
Okay, but they denied your petition for this school.
They authorized it and renewed it in
the year that I came in, 2010, and then they again unanimously renewed it in 2014.
And when we presented before them, their concern was not about our academic or educational program at all.
They basically, the one issue besides the location, you don't have a place, you have a name to where you're going to locate, which isn't required.
was that they didn't think we could hit our 75% unduplicated numbers that we put in our budget.
So they wanted us to reduce it down to what the district is, which is 40, and then they said, over the next few years, drop it by a point, 39, 38.
And we said, well, at Bayshore, without recruiting, we've always been up between 50 to 60%, and that is our target audience who we're going for.
So that's why we were denied at San Marcos.
So that's actually my question then to Nick or to Lisa.
When the budget came in, I don't know what their unduplicated count percentage was, but was that an initial concern of yours or do you think that their projections of unduplicated funding are realistic?
I don't know that the issue was relative to their projected enrollment or their unduplicated count.
I think it was just in the calculation of their LCFF funding was an issue for us.
They seemed to be way off of what we had calculated.
And it's a bit of a concern because we've got the FCMAT calculator out there that's easily accessible to all to use.
Why they had gotten a very different calculation of that that we had gotten in using this calculator was a big concern.
There are some other calculations that seem to have been in error as well in their original budget submittal.
Including the grant.
Including the grant funds that we didn't know if that was going to be accounted for.
Mr. President.
I'm sorry, were you finished?
I said including the federal grant funds because those weren't aren't guaranteed as well initially they had included those in the budget also.
the federal grant, the Pacific, I'm sorry, the public charter school grant funds.
Yeah.
Did you have a chance to look at the, I want to go back to this question on whether they satisfied the regulation.
Did you have a chance to look, can you give me an answer yes or no as to whether they did, there is a regulation.
Did you agree that they satisfied the regulation by saying they'd be at 5% in the second year?
I'd say there is a regulation.
They satisfied on paper.
I'm not sure how confident I am that that that that can be relied upon.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's the bottom line there.
Board Member Holliday.
Thank you.
So I So I do think that
This school is capable of meeting their fiscal responsibility.
And I do think the educational program is a value to the community.
And I do think that we have a track record of reasonable, if not good, success.
I do appreciate the department's fiscal concerns.
And I certainly would like to try to help alleviate
those concerns by offering a motion to approve this charter school but with a condition I have a written motion if it would be proper at this point to pass it out to the member to the board members
While he's passing that out, can I make a comment?
Yes.
I think the fact also that we've already authorized one charter in this CMO and that they have been functioning well operationally and fiscally and academically.
And I'm impressed with the leadership of the group, the CMO, in terms of how data-driven she is and how much data she has and how they analyze it, both budget and otherwise.
And so I'm going to be supporting the motion that Member Holliday is proposing.
If you have a copy it says to approve the Bay Point petition with the technical amendments identified by the CDE in the petition review form and with the condition that Bay Point agrees to provide quarterly operational data to the CDE demonstrating the actions Bay Point is taking to achieve at least a 5% reserve by the beginning of the 19-20 school year.
And I would second that motion.
It's been moved and seconded.
Any further board discussion?
Yes.
Pardon?
Mr. Price.
Yeah, I'd just like to ask Deputy Schweitzer to comment on this as far as the timing of the quarterly reports and indicate whether you believe this would provide greater levels of confidence.
Sure.
Certainly, we do, you know, of course, over the schools that we oversee, we do regularly check in with them on their fiscal condition, but yeah, this is probably, we do, what, three times a year this, so this would be an additional
I mean and you know certainly if the board were to approve this school we would probably be looking at it more closely anyway just as that's that's our responsibility for for overseeing these schools so.
Okay.
Board Member Valdez.
Thank you.
I have a question for staff.
So it sounds like when the school in San Mar- well, let's go back to Hemet.
When the school in Hemet was opened, you under projected the unduplicated count because that district has about 83% unduplicated count.
You came in about 70.
And I'm just concerned that San Marcos was saying, based on their numbers and knowing that they asked that you be at about 45% unduplicated count, was that correct?
Or 40%?
And you're coming in at 75.
And so I want to ask staff, are we comfortable with this based on what number of unduplicated count to get to be solvent in 20, if that makes sense?
because you underestimated in Hemet and you're overestimating in San Marcos.
So that's just my question.
What's the margin of error?
We, I'm sorry, we don't really have an answer to that right now, but it is something is if if the board were to approve this, we'd have to carefully monitor that.
Board Member Rucker.
Board Member Holiday, I just wanted to make sure I understood the motion.
So if the board approves this petition, the school would open in the beginning of the 18-19 school year.
Correct?
And so the regulations say that they have to, that they should, the goal is that they get to the 5% reserve by the end of the second year of operation.
If I'm reading this motion correctly, it says that they would need to achieve at least a 5% reserve by the beginning of their second year of operation, 19-20.
Is that what you meant to do?
I believe this is what the MOU states, doesn't it?
I thought it said it'd be by the end of the second year of operation.
No, I'm sorry, you're talking about the regulation?
Yeah.
I'm talking about the MOU that the department has used with state board authorized charter schools in the past.
Okay.
And that is what it says, correct?
By the beginning of the second year of operation.
So the MOU states that it's- Please identify yourself.
I'm sorry, Judy Hall, Administrator, Charter Schools Division.
Apologize.
So the MOU states that we're expecting 5% based on the LCFF entitlement, the full entitlement, and that it's not stipulated by year.
So it's beginning with the entitlement when that entitlement's actually received.
When the, so, right, so when you get your LCFF, based on prior year, this is a new school year, so that won't come until mid-year after PENCECT and 20-day are fully established.
Then we bill based on P1, whatever that count is, that's the entitlement, and then we go back at P2 and adjust the billing, either up or down.
Right.
So if we were to approve this motion, they would need to end their first fiscal year with a 5% reserve, which means it's hitting all of the targets that they're saying they're going to hit.
My question is, what if they don't?
What if they don't?
That is where I was going because what this doesn't say and what this doesn't contemplate based on the fact that they may be overestimating what their LCFF unduplicated count may be,
based on the advice from the district, they may be overestimating what their actual revenues should be by the end of the first year of operation, given the fact they didn't meet their target in their other school at their first year of operation.
But what they did meet is their fiscal responsibility and a clean budget in the first, second, third, fourth, fifth years.
And they did not have any fiscal insolvency or problem.
And the question of what would happen if they don't meet it, it's the same question that we face every time you start up a charter school.
It's a question we face always and every authorizer faces, every charter school leader faces.
You either make the budget or you're in trouble.
And what we're trying to do here with this motion is to adhere to the department's MOU process and not change that, but at the same time encourage or ask that the CDE monitor this very closely with the intent that should things start to look
different than what was projected that the CDE could provide technical support, advice, counsel in ways that would help the charter school sort it out and be successful.
In addition, on the PowerPoint, it was made very, by the petitioner, it was made very clear that they do pretty, pay a lot of attention to budget analysis with projections and actuals, projections and actuals.
And one of the things that I heard the petitioner say was when they see, you know, a budget is a plan, and the plans don't always exactly work out, and so you have to right-size your organization to what is actually happening.
And what I heard is that they are very good at right sizing.
In particular, she said that they always make sure when they need to make any adjustments that they do them with a priority of protecting the student and the instructional program first and find other ways to make those adjustments.
So I think they're actually very savvy at what they do fiscally.
Okay, Board Member Holliday.
Do we have a motion second?
Okay, all right.
Call the question or those in favor of approving the charter petition, raise your hands.
Those opposed, raise your hands.
Okay, it carries.
I'm one abstention, two no votes, one abstention.
It carries with six votes.
Abstain.
OK.
All right.
Lunch?
OK.
We will resume.
We're going to get our lunch.
And we're going to bring it back.
No, 1250.
What?
So we need to be back here at 1230.
Well, we underestimated the time.
There was no opposition.
The Board will reconvene at 1230.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene and we will now hear on item 22, the Middle School Mesa Spring Valley Appeals from San Diego County.
Okay, item number 22 is the appeal by College Prep Middle School to establish a new charter school.
Pursuant to Ed Code Section J1, petitioners for a charter school that had been denied at the local level may petition the school board for the State Board of Education for approval of the charter subject to certain conditions.
June 30th, 2017, La Mesa Spring Valley School District voted to deny the petition by a vote of four to zero.
October 11th, 2017, San Diego County Board of Education voted to deny the petition with a vote of three to two.
November 22nd, College Prep submitted a petition on appeal to the State Board of Education.
College Prep was previously authorized by Mountain Empire Unified School District.
They voluntarily closed under Mountain Empire on June 30th, 2017, which is the same date in which they were denied their petition with La Mesa Spring Valley.
The petition currently before you is for College Prep Middle School.
It's for that same school.
They are located in La Mesa and will be for the first part of 2018-19 if they're authorized to open in 18-19.
And they'll move to a newly constructed site in Spring Valley for the second half of the year.
But both of those locations are within the La Mesa-Spring Valley school district boundaries.
The petitioner was also approved for a second school under Mountain Empire.
That one is College Prep East County.
It is currently open and is at the former College Prep site, but they will be moving to the location in Acampo in 18-19 school year.
I tried to explain that, but if there's any other questions as we go through, if that didn't make sense to everyone.
The proposed grade levels are 5.8, and it is a site-based program.
The targeted enrollment is 240 for the 18-19 school year, increasing to 500 by the 2022-23 school year.
They're planning to serve pupils from the La Mesa Spring Valley School District and surrounding communities in East San Diego County.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on February 7, 2018, and moved to recommend approval of the petition.
Four commissioners voted in favor, three voted against.
There was not five votes to move the recommendation forward to the State Board of Education, so no recommendation has been moved.
The petitioner did submit additional information that after the ACCS meeting that the staff did review.
And after the review, the CDE recommends that the state board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish College Prep Middle School on a five-year term.
The recommendation is based on demonstratively likely to implement the program due to realistic financial and operational plan and a sound educational practice and comprehensive description of most of the required charter elements in the petition.
And I'm here and available for any questions that you may have.
Okay, are there any technical questions on this proposal at this point?
Board Member Strauss.
Could you clarify, so this closed and now they want to reopen under a different?
Correct.
Could you just clarify that?
Sure, they were authorized under Mountain Empire and then sought to, because they are physically located in La Mesa in their school boundaries, they sought to get a petition approved through La Mesa Spring Valley.
So they were denied by La Mesa Spring Valley and they closed under Mountain Empire on the same day, on June 30th, 2017.
So right now they are not authorized by La Mesa or by Mountain Empire, which is why they did also then go to the County Office of Education seeking petition there and were denied there, which is why they're now before the State Board of Education.
The only thing, we've had other situations like this where they
Why did they close?
Do you know?
Why didn't they just stay open and continue the appeal process?
From what I understand, and they are here to speak to this, but they did want to seek authorization under La Mesa because they are physically located within the boundaries of the La Mesa School District.
This is related to the Shasta decision?
No, not.
No, it's not a resource center.
It is a site-based program.
But they did want, yes, they did want to seek authorization where they are.
Correct.
Any other technical questions?
If not, I'm going to declare the public hearing open.
Each side will have 10 minutes.
And so I want to start then with the groups that are in support of the petition and the CDE recommendation to approve.
Thank you.
All set, all set.
I need these now.
Good afternoon, board members.
I'm petitioner Christina Calloway, and on behalf of all of us here representing College Prep Middle School, La Mesa Spring Valley, we thank you for hearing our appeal.
Also, we'd like to thank the CDE staff for the time and attention that they gave in their careful and thorough review of our charter petition.
We've always been so fortunate to have surrounded ourselves with a talented and supportive group of people, some of which are here today to speak about our program and help to answer any questions that you might have.
The educational program outlined in the charter before you does not merely propose a hypothetical program that would be implemented in a not yet existing school.
Rather, if granted, the charter will allow the continuation of an educational program that has been in practice for eight years with a proven track record in a community that we already serve.
The goal of our educational program is to promote students to high school who are on the path to college and career, students who are prepared for the rigors of high school and beyond, who don't require remediation and are able to choose from the highest level of core course offerings and college preparatory electives available to them.
Our academic program is centered on mastery of foundational skills in literacy and mathematics and in the core content areas of social studies and science.
Frequent assessment is used to inform our curricular decisions, monitor student progress, and identify students that might need additional supports.
There's tremendous demand and need in the La Mesa Spring Valley community for a high-performing charter school.
We wish to continue to provide that educational choice to a community that overwhelmingly wants choice, as indicated by the almost 300 letters of support that we provided to you from our community members, elected officials, families and friends, including many of our alumni, who we're really proud to say are now attending our local community colleges, universities all over the country, and even a student at Stanford, to name a few.
We wish to carry on the tradition of success we started in La Mesa with our first charter in 2010.
I love putting up this picture.
This is a picture of Mr. Miller and me in 2013 on the day that we learned that our API at CPMS was an amazing 941.
I always look and say, we were so young.
Making us the third highest ranking middle school in San Diego County.
In addition to the successful academic program that is consistent with sound educational practice, we offer a strong team of experienced personnel.
Mr. Miller, who you see there, is our director of school operations.
He has almost 20 years of experience working in the fields of education and family and child mental health services.
He's worked for Child Protective Services, County Mental Health, Autism Support Services, and as a school psychologist and administrator at the middle school level.
Mr. Miller holds an administrative services credential, a pupil personnel services credential, a master's in educational psychology, and is a certified school psychologist.
I'm the director of school business.
I'm responsible for the majority of our back office for the school.
I do all of our required state and county reporting, including the maintenance of our CalPETS data, et cetera.
I supervise staff and provide instructional support.
I have a single subject teaching credential in biology, an administrative services credential, a pupil personnel services credential, and a master's degree in educational counseling.
Forever a student and wanting to grow, I recently completed the school business manager certificate program at the University of Southern California.
I, along with Mr. Miller, run our school every day.
We fill in where needed and you'll always see us in the parking lot directing traffic mornings and afternoons.
Historically, our scores on the CASP assessments have consistently outranked state, county, and local averages.
We've been informed that we are ranked 67th out of 2,508 middle schools in the state.
Pretty proud of that.
In other measures, we've also shown that we can achieve success in all the state priority areas, including parent involvement, student engagement, and school climate, to name a few.
In the new accountability system, we are proud to have achieved the highest rating of performance across all the state indicators.
Our educational program is designed to help and serve all students, low-achieving, high-achieving, English learners, students with disabilities, students from all racial and ethnic backgrounds, and all others.
Our recruitment plan outlined in our charter is specifically tailored to attract students from all walks of life, and we are confident that it, along with the opportunity to grow our enrollment, will lead to a diverse pool of interested students.
On the business side of things, we've always run a fiscally sound operation.
We have seven years of successful independent audits and have maintained a positive fund balance for all the years of our operation.
Each year our board has been committed to building a healthy reserve with an eye towards growing our program.
Our charter budget also reflects our strategic goals for the future when it comes to our school site.
We've done extensive due diligence for the school's new facility.
We engaged a turnkey school facilities developer with years of experience acquiring and constructing charter school campuses in California and across the nation to help ensure that our plans for our new facility are solid and that our goals are attainable.
The costs for the new facility are well within commercial market ranges for financing and construction of this type and are reflected in our charter school's projected budget.
Our project comes in at a fraction of the per-pupil cost for other new schools in our county.
This is an architect's rendering of our proposed new state-of-the-art ADA-compliant facility located at Madrid Way in Spring Valley.
The project was unanimously approved by the San Diego County Planning Commission.
The two-story building will have e-occupancy and will be approximately 27,000 square feet and equipped with modern amenities for a state-of-the-art 21st century middle school.
We intend to exercise our right to purchase the project in a few years and have been exploring the eventual financing of the purchase with tax-exempt bonds.
We are already talking with a major underwriter in that regard.
Our largest barrier to serving more students has been the capacity at our current temporary facility, which only will allow 240 students.
The new construction will address our facility issues and allow us to serve more students, including those on our wait list.
Again, we appreciate the opportunity to present ourselves and our program to you today.
We believe we're a great example of the Charter School Act.
Our family supports us, our family support us, my mom supports me, right?
Our family supports us.
Our staff supports us and the community supports us.
We have a wait list of over 130 students currently and it grows every year.
And in these past eight years, we think we've done exactly the kind of work that you would be so very proud of.
Please look at our track record and our likelihood of continued success.
Your support will help us to continue our tradition of excellence and expand our ability to serve even more students of our community.
I want to take the opportunity again to thank you on behalf of all of our families and supporters, those here with us today and those working hard back in San Diego.
And speaking of working hard back in San Diego, I have to share with you that today, one of our sixth graders was representing us at the San Diego County Spelling Bee, and all of our seventh graders are out on San Diego Bay experiencing hands-on science with the Floating Sea Lab.
So speaking of back home, we're a really busy place, here's a brief video from our campus.
And again, thank you.
I am college prep.
I need college prep.
I'm not college prep.
I am college prep.
Okay, that concludes the presentation on this side and so we will now turn to the opponents of the petition.
District and County officials.
Good afternoon.
I'm Dr. Emma Turner.
I'm immediate past president of the LaMesa Spring Valley School Board and also I'm the current clerk.
I'm here today to support our decision and the decision of San Diego County Office of Education to deny the petition from College Prep.
The charter has been denied four times
by two local educational agencies in San Diego.
And any approval by the State Board of Education now would be detrimental to local control.
We were thoughtful and very inclusive in making our decision about College Prep.
We gave them every opportunity to correct glaring deficiencies around their proposed finances.
double student count, and other serious matters you have before you.
College prep does not serve all students.
And comparing it to the La Mesa Spring Valley School is not accurate.
It's like comparing apples and oranges.
Here are some examples.
College prep requires families to purchase uniforms.
This is a requirement in order to attend the school.
And the proposal allows two of the highest paid administrators to remove students at will.
It does not serve the same demographics of the community in which it's located now.
And contrary to some statements that's been said, we at La Mesa Spring Valley, we welcome and we embrace charter schools that operate lawfully and that are in compliance with the authorizer's oversight.
For example, we just recently approved the petition of a charter school.
They were very transparent, they were cooperative, and they worked with us.
They had some discrepancies that they had to correct also, but they did so.
So as a local public official elected to ensure public schools within La Mesa Spring Valley's boundaries are operating lawfully and serving all kids, I respectfully request that you deny the college prep petition based on the deficiencies noted in our denial.
If college prep submitted additional documents for your consideration on this appeal, we have not been given access to them, even though we've requested.
And therefore, I also respectfully request that those documents not be considered in your deliberations.
Thank you for letting me speak.
Good afternoon.
I'm Kristen Armitas.
I am from the San Diego County Office of Education.
I serve as the consultant in business advisory services.
So we had very similar findings as the district.
We also showed the uniforms and that there were disciplinary actions that could be taken against students for not wearing uniforms or for lost materials.
suspension and expulsion procedures.
That was also an issue for us, so they did not provide manifestation determinations for special education students and also failed to explain the process for a student to appeal that decision.
Racial and ethnic balance, so again, they are not serving the same student population as the school district currently is.
So low socioeconomic and English learners.
Low socioeconomic, La Mesa Spring Valley District is a 60% percentage.
And English learners is 20% for that district.
And college prep on the other side is 37% low socioeconomic and only 2% English learners.
But where the county office really has found some very significant concern is on the financial projections.
So the majority of their budget was based off of a $1.5 million beginning fund balance, which was to come from the college prep middle school that closed.
In between this time, they've also opened and established College Prep Middle School East County.
And in that petition, that $1.5 million was also named as a beginning balance for that charter school, which is operational this fiscal year.
So it's still unclear to us whether or not that $1.5 million is even available for the La Mesa Spring Valley Charter to access.
And in addition to that, the land agreement or the lease agreement that they have entered into is highly reliant on student ADA counts in those first few years, which currently they've been at about 230, 240 students.
They have a target of 500.
Doesn't seem like that is a reasonable expectation at this point.
And they are also highly reliant on the charter schools facility grant funds to move forward with those payments.
The lease payment that they're currently making is $180,000, and that soars in year three to $941,000 under this new proposed agreement.
So those are the findings that the county office had.
And with that, I will turn it back over to LaMesa Spring Valley.
Well, good afternoon.
My name is Brian Marshall.
I'm superintendent of La Mesa Spring Valley Schools.
I've been superintendent in the district for 15 years, been in public education now 29 years.
Why would La Mesa not approve such a high-performing school?
Because you can't deny the achievement of the students there, although you can question the demographics, which we'll get into, but certainly the students do have high achievement.
Why would La Mesa Spring Valley not want to embrace that school and bring it into
district.
They were operating in the district since 2010 under a charter in Mountain Empire that was, after the Shasta decision, illegal.
That's why they had to get a subsequent petition.
That's why they closed the first school, opened the second school, College Prep East County.
They're now operating in the exact same location as was mentioned under an exemption because they're building facility up in the Campo area in Mountain Empire.
So why would La Mesa Spring Valley not go for this twice?
Several reasons.
The first of them has to be the demographic group that they serve.
When I asked College Prep in 2015 about their demographics, I got a very flippant response, which I included in my documents to you, I hope you received the three letters that we sent, our documents to you where Petitioner Calloway stated, well, there is no College Prep La Mesa Spring Valley yet, so there can be no demographic differences.
But that petition was written to transform the existing College Prep Middle School to the College Prep Middle School in the Mesa Spring Valley.
So there were demographic differences.
It was just going to be a transition.
The second thing that came up that was a concern for us was this land deal and certainly the purchase and all of that that went around this purchase of the Madrid Way property.
It is important to note that the purchase of the property was done without College Prep Board approval in November.
It wasn't until January
that that was approved by the college prep board in a retroactive move.
Since that time, then, they've entered into agreements with Highmark and with all of these other firms outside of California to develop the property.
But as was mentioned by the county office, the costs are just so outrageous, going from $180,000 a year lease payment to over $900,000.
Those were a big concern for us, and the budget just didn't pan out.
And finally, as was mentioned by the county, discipline procedures.
When I did my first capacity interview with College Prep and their staff, and I have two minutes and four seconds, so I've got more than enough time.
When I did my first capacity interview, I noticed in their SARC that there was an expulsion
Now, I have been a middle school principal, I've been a middle school vice principal, I was a middle school math teacher, I've been assistant superintendent, superintendent.
You and I know that expulsion is the most serious consequence a school district can levy on a student.
Expulsion means you do not attend public school for one year, the semester in which the event happened and the subsequent semester.
So I asked myself, at a charter school of 240 students with this demographic body, how can there be an expulsion?
It had to be serious.
You and I both know that in California, there are three things that are mandatory expulsions, brandishing a knife, selling a controlled substance, so selling drugs, or bringing a black powder firearm to a campus.
You bring those three things, we have no hope, you gotta get expelled.
So I asked petitioners, can you tell me about this expulsion?
And the response was, well, the youngster brought a knife.
Now, you and I both know middle schoolers are going to bring knives to school.
They forget they're in the backpack.
They think it's cool.
Whatever.
Generally, you kind of take that.
Maybe there's a suspension.
Maybe there's some of that stuff.
So I said, oh, my gosh, a knife.
The student must have brandished it.
He said, oh, no, he was just showing it to some friends.
Well, you and I both know kids like knives.
They're going to show them to friends.
So I said, so what did he do that got him expelled?
Well, he just didn't fit in was the answer.
That is an absolute quote.
It just wasn't fitting in with our school.
We hear that sometimes from kids that come back from college prep.
They're mean to me.
Finally, I have to say, you have documents that were not provided to La Mesa Spring Valley.
When your staff reviewed the exact documents we had, they recommended denial.
It was only after the subsequent documents were received that I asked for and was told you'd be given you everything in that letter, and you have all of this, that we had to deny.
In your case, with the documents that we had, there was a denial.
Why would CollegePrep not share the documents with La Mesa Spring Valley?
Four seconds left.
I thank you for your time.
Okay.
Board member, before we have board member comments, I'll call for public comment because we're under the public hearing.
With the following speakers, please line up at the podium.
Sheila Whitley, David Feliciano, Mitchell Miller, Joe Gilman, Dylan Petrovich, Tracy Dahlkamp, Sung Trainer, Christine Lamarca, Lana Penaberry, Father Simon Ishaki, Corey Malchik, Mark Skosin, Gary Hobelman, Andy Stern, Ramal Anfion, and Eric Premack.
Please come forward.
I'm Mitchell Miller.
I was named third, so I'm not sure where the first two.
Were you on the list?
Yes, sir.
OK, go ahead.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Mitchell Miller, as we mentioned.
I'm one of the petitioners for College Prep.
I'd like to thank you for this opportunity to present our petition and to be able to tell you a little bit about the good stuff that we're doing for kids.
We believe that we've developed a very successful educational program over the past eight years, culminating to the petition that is before you.
It is one that truly focuses on people and programs.
However, it's been quite a journey that's brought us here today.
And despite the district putting up roadblocks at every step of the way, including unsuccessfully litigating against us, not once but twice, at a reported cost of over $250,000 at taxpayers expense, we continue to provide a high quality education to our community for eight years.
We feel that this should be an exciting time for us as we look to expand our program whose success we hope will be celebrated.
We love what we do and we want to be able to continue to educate students and prepare them for high school and beyond.
We take that responsibility very seriously and know how significant the middle school years are in making sure that students are on the right path to success.
We hope that you see how much this means to us in our community and we wish that
to not only make our students and families proud, but to make the State Board to be proud as well.
Something that we like to call Tiger Pride.
Thank you again for your consideration.
I appreciate it.
OK, I brought a picture because my kids wanted to come again, but we came last month.
So my name is Jo Gilman, and I'm the proud parent of two college prep students spanning the last seven years.
We're a multicultural blended family.
And this makes me, sorry, a stepmom and a grandma of three.
I can't wait for my grandkids to go to college prep.
The last seven years have been awesome.
My daughter, Kamilani, has a 4.6, and she's in her top 3% of her graduating class this year.
She has a love for math and physics, and she learned excellent organizational skills from her years at college prep.
Our eighth grade daughter, Mia-Clea.
who came with me last month is also a straight-A student and has acquired her excellent study habits from college prep.
Both also have been prepared for a strong social life as navigating a middle school can be difficult.
I love the fact that our classroom size provides an intimate learning environment.
Both my girls attended our local elementary school and while I was very happy with the environment,
It quickly became obvious that our girls were given the task to tutor their peers.
While this honor was esteem building, it kept them at status quo and did not give them the challenge they needed to push forward.
College Prep has done that.
Please approve our charter so that my grandkids can attend there.
I'm really counting on you guys to do the right thing.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, distinguished members of the board.
My name is Dejan Petakovic.
That's a Serbian surname if you're interested in diversity, but in the spirit of St.
Patrick's Day, we can be Irish.
My wife, Natasha, and I are the proud parents of two sons who are both honor roll students at College Prep Middle Schools.
Analogous to the credo, location, location in the real estate world, the credo that best describes CPMS is dedication, dedication, dedication.
Our students are dedicated to higher learning.
Our educators are dedicated to our students.
We as parents, the true representatives here today of the Lomasa Spring Valley School District,
Come here today from San Diego at our own personal expense, not a taxpayer expense, in support of our petition under your oversight.
We ask you to join our three pillars of dedication.
Together, we may build together a stronger foundation.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Tracy and I have two children in eighth and sixth grade who currently attend CPMS.
I do not have a background in education.
I'm not involved in local politics.
I am a mom who two years ago...
was in a dire situation with my children's education due to physical, emotional, and psychological challenges at their large public schools with large class sizes.
After one year, it was clear that CPMAs made the difference.
My kids felt seen, heard, understood, and cared for.
The students are noticed.
They're encouraged to share their opinions and ideas.
The teachers have an opportunity to observe the pace of the class and adjust learning accordingly.
The benefits of my children have experienced being in a smaller class size has been a real eye-opener for our family.
Another reason this school is so well-loved is because of the nurturing staff.
They know every child, all families are invited and encouraged to be active.
Personally, I believe the increased violence we see at schools today is largely due to children that are in environments where they are not seen, they are not heard or understood.
This school sees our kids and they care, and more kids deserve a school like this.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I want to thank you in advance for taking into consideration what I'm going to say before making your final decision.
My name is Lena Pena-Berry, and my son is in seventh grade at College Prep.
Almost four years ago, my husband and I made a very hard choice to leave our faith-based school.
After touring multiple schools in and out of our district, we made the decision to move our son to College Prep, as it was the only school in our community that met our son's educational needs.
It was one of the best decisions we ever made.
Aside from a stellar education, our son has learned accountability, responsibility, time management, and most of all, how to be a respectful young man.
The driving factor behind his enormous success is due to the entire staff at CPMS, who make it a priority to know every student and their families on a very personal level.
And they work closely with them in shaping the success of every student.
I stand before you to ask you to please let our program continue to grow and thrive so more kids can have the same opportunity we have had.
I know with your support, CPMS will continue to affect our kids and community in a positive way for years to come.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Sung Trainer.
Thank you for giving me this opportunity to express my strong support for College Prep Middle School.
Currently, I have a daughter in seventh grade and a son in sixth grade at College Prep.
Both of their experiences have been positive and encouraging.
They are very different in personality and in learning styles, but they are both thriving.
My daughter is involved in the school's ASB program, and my son plays volleyball on the boys' team.
In addition, I have been able to volunteer at the school, giving regular art lessons to fifth graders.
This opportunity has allowed me to observe the administrative staff and teachers closely.
The administrative staff are dedicated.
and are excellent at running the school.
They are kind and genuinely care about the students.
The teachers are well prepared and provide an engaging and positive learning environment for the students, and they also take an interest in the individual students.
Please let our College Prep Middle School continue its tradition of preparing our future leaders for success.
Good afternoon, hello.
My name is Christine Lamarca and I have twin 8th grade daughters at CPMS.
By the end of the 4th grade we recognized that the 5th grade teachers' quality was not up to the same standard as the teachers we had had prior and we decided to go and look for options for our children.
The other thing was that as they were heading into middle school there was a 1,500 student plus school developing a very poor reputation in our neighborhood.
And that option didn't seem like a good fit for our physically small and often very quirky daughters.
And school, obviously, is not a one-size-fits-all option.
We started looking for our alternatives.
And after touring CPMS in our tiny little space and meeting the directors and seeing the quality of the student work, lining the walls in the classrooms, it was clear that this is where our girls would be best suited to be.
We started it in 2014 and here we are in 2018 and the transformation of our daughters is crazy.
They've been accepted with honors to a local high school achieving over 90th percentile nationwide in testing.
The CPMS students like mine demonstrate proficiency and we would perhaps like to see this be a model for all of our students and future leaders in the East County area of El Cajon.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Corey metric.
I'm the board president of college prep.
I want to thank the administration, faculty, and staff of College Prep Middle School for creating, cultivating, and operating a premier learning environment and a fiscally responsible organization.
I would also like to thank all the students and families, those many of who are here today and those who couldn't make it, for all of their support.
And finally, I would like to thank the CDE staff for their thorough and unbiased review of our charter.
Their detailed analysis of the facts resulted in the CDE staff recommendation of approval for our school.
And what I would hope that this board would do is to follow both the majority of the ACCS that voted to approve us, as well as your staff to approve us, and approve our high-performing charter school.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Gary Hobelman.
I'm the assistant superintendent of business for Mountain Empire Unified School District and I've been with the district since January of 2015.
We just wanted to say that we were the original authorizing agency for Charter Prep back in 2010-2011.
We've been providing the back office and the payroll support for the Charter since that time.
We have a wonderful working relationship with them and College Prep has been a viable charter and it's reflected in their fiscal responsibility in previous years and their educational program.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Mark Skousen.
I'm the president of Highmark School Development, the company that's actually developing this facility for college prep middle school.
The thing that I just wanted to mention today is we've developed over 70 schools around the country, including several other high-performing charter schools here in California.
And we do a very, very vigorous vetting, underwriting process for each of the schools we choose to develop and invest in.
This has been about a two and a half year process with College Prep Middle School.
We vetted board governance, we vetted their program, we vetted the real estate solution.
In my mind, having looked at a lot of schools, College Prep Middle School represents the best of the best in the terms of the schools that we choose to underwrite.
We are pretty selective in the schools that we
choose to partner with and this is the exact type school that we choose to partner with and are very supportive.
The other quick thing that I'll mention is as it talks as it relates to the facility payment, we back into the facility payment based on the school's budget and we will not put a school in a situation where they cannot afford their facility payment.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Andy Stern.
I'm the Managing Director with Charter Impact.
We provide accounting and financial services for charter schools.
I was previously for six years the Chief Business Officer for Rocketship Education.
Charter Impact asked us to do an independent financial analysis.
Our conclusion is that the financials are reasonable and the fund balance resulting in a fund balance that's in excess of 37% in all the years of the charter.
The projections of rent are as stated, however, the charter school qualifies for SB 740 allocations, which would result in the annual cost of less than $500,000 even when the school is full, and would likely be less if and when the school exercises its likely option to acquire the building and refinance.
Hello I'm Sheila Whitley and I'm here representing California Teachers Association.
First I want to commend CPMS because it sounds like they have an exemplary program and it's a program I'd love to have my children have attended and my grandchildren to attend.
However, I am here objecting to this being approved, and I am objecting because of the message that keeps being sent to charter schools.
All of us believe in local control.
That is why we have the LCAPs.
You guys developed this to give back monies to local school districts.
Most of the teachers in California truly believe that it is very important
to have local control of our schools because not all communities are the same, not all schools are the same, and not all children are the same.
So I feel like the
that you are sending back to schools is that they cannot provide the information that is requested and that they can just come here and get their programs approved by the State Board and I don't think that is the message that you guys should be sending or that you want to be sent.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Sarah Sutherland.
I'm an attorney and I represented La Mesa Spring Valley School District.
Petitioners have an active charter with Mountain Empire School District.
Currently, there's four more years on that charter.
That charter was pending at the time the La Mesa Spring Valley Charter was pending.
They were essentially the same charter.
They were based on the same teacher signatures.
They were based on the same students.
They were based on the same money.
And so at the time this petition was considered by La Mesa Spring Valley, it was a very different proposal than it is
before you today, which is now a second school, with another charter for Mountain Empire that is apparently gonna move these same 240 students to Campo, which is 50 miles from La Mesa.
I wanna remind this board that Mountain Empire Unified School District was, at the time this charter was approved, run by a superintendent that has been convicted of a felony for approving charters to just locate outside of his boundaries.
This is a classroom-based charter that located wherever they wanted to locate as long as it wasn't in Mountain Empire.
That's how this started and that's why it is continuing to this day with this sort of local issue, which is truly a local issue and we would respectfully request that you allow it to remain a local issue and we are handling it.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is David Feliciano.
I'm the assistant superintendent for business services at La Mesa Spring Valley School District.
And you forgive me, I'm going to read from my phone here.
I'm a resident of San Diego and I'm also an advocate for charter schools.
In fact, I have two children that attend a charter school where they receive a high quality education and it's the right fit for my family.
I should add that this charter school was authorized by the district in which the school is located.
It is this commitment to school choice that motivates me to speak to you today.
As a CBO, if I were to engage my district in a binding multimillion dollar land deal,
With multiple out-of-state for-profit corporations prior to board approval and with no opportunity for public input or scrutiny, as CPMS has done, I would rightly be accused of misappropriating millions of dollars in public funds.
violating the education code, conflict of interest laws, the Brown Act, and numerous other state and federal laws.
I would lose my job and possibly face criminal charges.
I fear for the charter school movement because of these actions by CPMS.
Thank you.
Board, Ramel Antoine with Cal Charters.
I want to state our strong support for College Prep Middle School based on their track record, based on the services they're already offering and their expansion.
At ACCS, this issue of diversity came up and I wanted to read a letter from Father Simon, or sorry, Father Simon Shockey, speaking to a specific group that they're serving that doesn't show up on the indicators.
So, dear board members, here's a brief explanation about who the Chaldeans are.
I hope everything – rather, the Chaldeans are part of an ancient group of many people who are the original inhabitants of modern-day Iraq.
They also have their own traditions and language which they use, which is Aramaic.
Over the past century, Chaldeans have been spreading all throughout the world, mainly because of religious persecution in Iraq.
We have big communities in Europe, Australia, and Canada, but the major areas are Detroit and San Diego.
In San Diego alone, they have about 60,000 Chaldeans, many of whom experienced religious persecution in Iraq and had to flee the country with nothing.
For Chaldean community here in San Diego, he does a lot of work and really thinks that the college prep provides an option for those students needing support.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
Again, another one that I think should be an easy, simple, straightforward approval.
They meet all of the criteria.
I think there's obviously a lot of philosophical opposition to the charter school concept in some circles.
Again, not a reason for denial.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Claire Crawford within the public interest.
I would just like to suggest that if you do vote to approve this charter that you request that the CD staff that are charged with oversight provide careful attention to the demographics of the student body and ensure that their demographics reach much closer to reflect what the district currently has attending.
I think the numbers that the county raised
serious concerns about whether they're actually serving the students in that community and so the CDA would have the ability to really be monitoring that closely.
Thanks.
Okay that concludes the public comments so I declare the public hearing closed and now we're ready for board member questions comments.
Board member Strauss.
Well, I wanna thank everyone for coming to testify and share their perceptions.
It sounds from what I hear and from the data that the instructional program of this school is solid, but I have a lot of clarifying questions based on the other testimony.
So maybe I'll start with our CDE team and then you can decide who best and I'll just kind of share.
I wanna talk about the demographics, about the disciplinary action,
about the financial issues and things that the county felt.
So could we start with the, did you investigate the contrast in the demographics from the local population to what appears, is it the, well maybe I'll ask you that and then we've heard some other explanations.
I'm just trying to be clear about whether it's a self-selected group and doesn't represent the actual population of the community.
We didn't look at the demographics specifically.
We did look at the race and ethnicity balance and how that's identified in the petition.
So that's as far as we got in terms of the race and ethnicity.
But as was proposed, that is something we can continue to look at as we monitor, especially with the dashboard now.
So that is something we can continue to monitor and bring forward if we do have any concerns about that.
But we didn't get into the detailed demographics.
So I just would put on the table, and maybe my other colleagues have other clarifying, but the contrast of 2% English learners versus 20% of local population is a concern of mine, but maybe there'll be some other ones as well.
Also, this doesn't really sound like a school that closed, but when I asked you, you said it closed, but it sort of reopened, but it sounds like it's an existing school.
I'm actually somewhat confused, and also that one was gonna be located 50 miles away, so could you follow me
give me from one mountain empire authorized it and where it is today has it moved has it just closed and reopened is it just a technical i'm i'm just confused by all the testimony that i will do my best and and if if i am incorrect i'll have the the petitioner come up but my understanding is there's two schools so they were both authorized under mountain empire
one in La Mesa, which is the one before you today, and then the Acampo site.
The La Mesa school closed June 30, 2017, and then the Acampo site has been using that facility.
They are currently in operation.
There are
technically two schools, one that's currently open and then one that's before you to be authorized under the state board.
But the one that's before us to be authorized, are there students currently in that program waiting authorization because of the technical issue of relocating in the local, like it really didn't close.
Well, my understanding is that one did close, and there are kids that are at the Campos site now.
They also do have a waiting list.
So if both schools are open, then there will be kids going to the La Mesa site and kids staying at the Campos.
But the parents who testified are talking about their students in a program that they don't want us to close.
Because the other campus is currently operating.
The kids that were in the school back closed, but a new school came in and took over the school that was existing under the other name, so it's just got a different name now, but it's the same site and the same students, so that's why I'm confused.
maybe my okay my it's been a long day and i may have if i have it wrong please let me know but my understanding is that the the the mace the the la mesa site the closed the college prep middle school closed and then in august the acampo site opened uh both college prep but there that students went to are at that facility the facility is still in la mesa so the students went to that school which is that school again
The same facility.
It's the same.
In La Mesa, not in Campo.
La Mesa, yes.
But they were in La Mesa.
I'm totally lost, yeah.
Can you tell me where Campo is and where is Campo?
That means nothing to me, Campo.
I believe they're operating under a petition authorized by, currently, authorized by Mountain Empire.
But they have a site in La Mesa and a site in El Campo.
The site in La Mesa is outside of Mountain Empire.
They're operating there under exemption.
that is legal, they allege, based on the temporary allowance to operate outside of the district because they're constructing a facility.
Where is El Campo?
Is that near, how close is that to the local school district?
It's like 50 miles away.
But the kids are going to school in La Mesa.
How could they have the same population as Springfield, as La Mesa then?
So there's, so we had our La Mesa, we had our La Mesa site.
It was in a church basement, I believe.
That site was authorized
by Mountain Empire closed, then they did a new petition in Mountain Empire with two sites, Acampo and the closed site.
And now they're going to get a new petition proposed to you with just the La Mesa site, but keep open the Acampo site under the Mountain Empire petition.
Judy, let me clarify.
The students that were in the college prep middle school have not lost the continuity of their instructional program.
That's correct.
They've changed authorizers.
Are they still in the same site they were in in 2017?
So it's really a technical process.
Am I right?
Yes.
Yes, but there will be two schools.
Yes, at the end of this it will look a little different because if you approve it there would be two schools, two petitions.
The petition you possibly approve with the La Mesa site and then the petition that's currently authorized by Mountain Empire will lose the La Mesa site and just keep the compost site.
Okay.
Well, right.
Yes.
Where did the statistics come from that they produced and was it a site 50 miles from the proposed one or is it the La Mesa?
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
I missed the question.
Okay.
We got various statistics about racial and ethnic differences between the charter school proposal and the district.
If they're going to school 50 miles away, what is the comparison?
I'm trying to, you know, I'm lost.
Right now, those are the same kids in La Mesa.
They're not going 50 miles away.
This is really just a technicality to get it within its own location.
So just a couple more things and then I believe I'm expecting my colleagues may have other questions but the issue of disciplinary actions and suspending or expelling kids that seem to be against what the philosophy of normal progressive discipline at middle school.
Did you review that or was that done only at the county level and was there any
recommendations or conditions regarding the disciplinary exclusion issues?
We did review the suspension and expulsion that was in the petition and we did note that they would need to be updated based on the new laws, the AB 1360 that came into effect.
But that is the case in most of the petitions that we see because they're older and they're trying to catch up to the new laws.
So that is pretty standard in each of the petitions that we see.
And my last area, again we may come back, but
The financial issues that we heard testimony on, is the CDE comfortable with the current financial information that you have?
We are.
Board Member Burr.
I just want to follow up on the issue about the racial and ethnic diversity and make sure I understand what we're doing at the state level because the charter law requires a charter to include the means by which the school will achieve a racial and ethnic balance among its pupils that are reflective of the district in which it will be located.
So, I'm not sure if you checked that or if there is a definitive, I didn't look at the charter petition on this area, definitive plan to achieve that balance.
One second here and just and while you're looking for at least that what what's a little confusing I'll just say for the La Mesa Spring Valley people folks the tables that you included seem to be heavily weighted toward the elementary or middle schools that were in the neighborhood but the law talks about the whole district and
I just want to be clear that that's the standard in the statute, that it's the district population, but I also want to know what we're doing to make sure that happens.
Part of our review of the petition is racial and ethnic balance.
In this case, we didn't see anything in the petition that would state otherwise, so we do take a general look at the petition in that sense.
That may be something we can look at further, but we didn't see anything to the contrary, so we assume that as they continue to grow under us, we will continue to look at that as part of the MOU.
I remember how to say.
This is a site-based school, correct?
Correct.
There was some talk about this being part of the Shasta ruling.
No, it's not.
It's a site-based school.
I believe the superintendent thought it was, but at the same time it's not.
It's not associated with that decision.
Correct.
Our understanding is it is a site-based school.
There is, of course, this other issue about a charter being authorized in a particular district, but the site being located outside that district.
That's a whole other topic, but it doesn't have to do with the Shastra rule.
No.
Correct.
We heard that a lot about this new facility.
And in fact, at the beginning of the title page of their petition, they have that same drawing of the building.
Is there a spot, though, in the petition that requires that the school continue down that path to that construction project?
If we were to approve this petition, are we obligating them to continue down this path toward that facility?
With the new facility?
Yeah.
We will look at that and the costs of that facility as part of the financials that we look at in ensuring that we feel the charter school will be financially viable.
So we do include what they're estimating to be their lease payments, but there isn't anything that holds them to that facility.
We heard from the facility provider.
I don't know exactly what term the gentleman goes by, but that with all their experience of 70 other, you know, school buildings they built or whatever, you know, they work on a sliding scale based upon, you know, the needs of the school and all that.
But it is possible for the school to pull out of that construction project if financially they can't meet it.
Is that your understanding?
I'm not sure where they are in that contract.
So that might be a question for them.
I just have a couple more quickies here if you don't mind.
This $1.5 million that was the starting balance
There was some confusion here about whether or not that's already been used for a particular school or whether it is still possible for this school to have in their budget.
Can you explain that?
We did initially, it was one of our questions about where this $1.2 million was.
As part of our additional review, we did get a board resolution.
We did get a home office bank account that showed us where the funds were.
So we did feel comfortable that the transfer of those funds would be coming to basically both schools, but we did feel comfortable
The majority of that is coming to the La Mesa school.
And when you talk about this additional information, is this information you asked for?
it is we did if if you recall at the ACCS meeting one of our biggest concerns was this 1.2 million we couldn't tell if that was included in their account but we didn't tell it we couldn't tell if that was actually going to the school or where that those funds were so we did ask for some clarifying information to find out where that money was and where it was coming from to make us more comfortable with the financials this is the type of
Question that comes up is that you know, we didn't get that information.
I didn't get that You didn't get that, you know, but this is information you asked for and they provided it to you.
Is that correct?
Okay, and I just sorry And one more checking on that and did you give it to the back?
The district says you could they couldn't get that information from you That part I'm I'm not sure we they they did ask us for it and we did provide that to the district
Okay, go ahead.
Sorry.
And the last on my list right now, at least, is do you do you know for a fact that they are requiring fees for uniforms?
I remember that question coming up before the ACCS meeting.
We did ask the petitioners if they were requiring uniforms, but our conversations with them were that they were going to assume the cost of those uniforms.
That is my memory recollection.
I will double check.
I don't recall if it was in their budget.
I'll have to take a look.
It's not a line item, but for you.
It doesn't necessarily have to be a line item.
Correct.
But it needs to be in the budget, obviously, if they're going to assume the cost of uniforms.
All right.
Thank you.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe, I think, was next.
Oh, Karen was next.
OK.
So I have a few concerns, and one is, of course, the suspension and expulsion data procedures, not having a manifestation determination if it involves a special education student, but I'm hearing that we're going to maybe clean that up in the MOU.
I do have real concerns about the demographics and not matching, and the huge discrepancy, it's like half of the poverty level, and 1% or so of the, or 2% of the,
SED, the low income level.
But my other concern is if the property that they're putting the school on belongs to whom?
The new property, my understanding is it belongs to College Prep Middle School.
College Prep owns that.
They don't own, okay.
Who owns that property?
The developer.
So with that, if an agreement is entered in, and I have been working with a school that has private underwriting bonds for their school, and the contention is if that school ever goes upside down, that the authorizer is the one that then holds the liability on the loan.
Is that correct?
Are you doing a leaseback type of agreement?
Do you mind coming up and talking about that?
Yeah, so Highmark School Development partners with a large real estate investment trust that provides the majority of the capital for the financing of this project, roughly $9.3 million.
So we do a triple net lease with a three-year buyout provision.
So we basically have ramped the payments based on the student enrollment of the school and then the school have the option to buy that facility back from us after three years.
So we're the property owner for those first three years and then the school
could access the tax-exempt capital markets to own the facility and be title owners of that facility after three years.
So it's kind of like a balloon payment on the fourth year something has to happen?
Well, no, I mean, as soon as they as soon as they become an attractive target to the tax exempt market through the underwriting process, then then they would have the ability to exit.
They would they go through an underwriting process.
That's a private bonds, right?
That's what we're going for.
So that's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
Private public bonds.
Right.
Oxymoron there.
So with that, though, the liability of that loan ultimately lies with the authorizer if something happens to that charter.
No, it actually, because it's privately financed, Highmark actually acts as the guarantor on that.
So if for some reason the school could not make that lease payment, Highmark is first obligated to that, to the Real Estate Investment Trust, EPR, and then they would, we would either try and find another school to come in there if they couldn't make the payment.
It's our real estate essentially, it's not your responsibility.
Okay, thank you.
A fellow, Ortiz Lacombe.
Thank you.
I think anyone that says this is a simple one is not sitting on this side.
Because there's a couple of things, and we've heard it's a recurring theme, because now like 50% of our items are charter related.
And before the liaisons would take the lead, but I think now all of us should be very well acquainted with the review process on the CDE end.
We hear that the petition has evolved and that there's new material and new information.
I can't, from where I'm sitting, I don't know how that has evolved, and I'm assuming that's something the CDE will look at.
You look at
and correct me if I'm wrong, what petition was initially filed, what petition was filed with the county, and what's coming before us?
And any clarification is based on the original petition.
I also want to know, are we looking at data of the demographics?
I mean, that's something that we should be looking at.
Does it mirror the demographics?
I have to say that you are doing well by your students, and that's undeniable.
You know, you're doing well by your Latino students, you're doing well by your three English learners.
Three, when it's 18%, it would be great for us to see what is a comparison, what is the demographic information.
Not for us to pull it up on site with the data dashboard, but that should be something coming before us, as well as information that comes before us using our current accountability system.
I've seen too many APIs, but I think that should stop when it reaches you, and then what comes to us is more up to date.
In terms of the uniforms,
Listen, that's kind of a common practice.
Long Beach Unified has uniforms.
My kids wear uniforms in public school.
And there's also always a thing called a waiver where parents could opt to waive out of the uniform.
And guess what?
Most of us parents love the uniform.
So for me, that's not the concern.
And I think that we've shown in Long Beach Unified that the lowest income family could receive assistance from the schools, but they also like the uniform option.
That is something that brings parity in terms of socioeconomic to our students.
so that not one student has to feel like they're not well-dressed for school.
So, you know, I like that concept.
But I think that really the issue here is that we hear the district, we hear the county, and they each have a different story, and then we hear the petitioners, and we're now left to make a decision based on a story that has evolved so much.
And it would be great to know how you review, maybe a memo, how you review the petitions, what goes into your considerations, so that we are all on the same page.
Thank you.
Could I ask the petitioner a couple of questions, please?
This is kind of a general question.
You've heard from the department responses to some of the questions that other board members have made and that I've made.
Do you disagree with any of their responses?
Respectfully, yes.
Which one and how?
With regard to our demographics, I believe that we very much look like the community that we're located in.
When we move to our new facility, if we're so fortunate to get your support, we would like to move to our new facility.
That facility actually qualifies for SB 740 funds because of the surrounding area, which means that they have over 55% of their students that receive free and reduced price meals.
Currently at our campus, we are at 41% free and reduced price meals.
If I could just list our demographics currently, 53% are white, 3.8% are Asian, 8.8% are African American, 3.3% Filipino, 8.8% Hispanic, 13% Middle Eastern, 1.3% Korean, 2.9% Mexican American, and 1% Pacific Islander, and those are just to name a few.
We have currently, yes, we have a few ELs, but we also have about 57 RFEP students that we monitor and we work with as well.
So just to let you know that.
There are 13 primary languages that are spoken at our school, Arabic, Assyrian, Chaldean, French, Japanese, Khymer,
Korean, Lao, Lithuanian, Russian, Spanish, and Vietnamese.
I would like you to recall or remember that we are a campus that's located in the lower level of a church building currently.
We have served 240 students.
That is all the fire marshal will allow us to have in our current facility.
Each year, we have a 98% retention rate, which means that our students that start with us at fifth grade, they tend to come back to us at sixth grade, and they continue on seventh grade and eighth grade, and that's a wonderful thing, and one of our, I think, our best statistics.
This past year, we had 20 younger siblings come to our school, which I also think is one of the more wonderful statistics that we have.
If you think about that in terms of each year, we basically have a new fifth grade cohort that comes to us each year.
That's 60 spots that are available.
Now, if I have 20 siblings that are coming, that means that I really only have 40 spots available.
As you can see, while we have an open enrollment process, there's not very many spots to fill in our school.
So we're looking forward to our growth and our move to the other part of town, if you will, to increase our diversity.
And I believe that we will attract a diverse and interested group of students.
I hope that answers some of the demographic questions that you had.
As far as the facility, we, I'm sorry.
That's all right.
So, you know, thank you for that explanation, but as I think Member Burr pointed out, it's important to have a plan.
for achieving the racial and economic demographics of the district.
Absolutely.
And again, I think 12,600 students are in the district and we are serving 240 of them.
And once again, I think if you looked at the area that we're in and those schools that are surrounding us, you'll see that we very much mirror those demographics.
I believe CDE was okay.
They looked at our plan for our recruitment and found it to be satisfactory.
I really believe that with that recruitment plan and our move, we are going to attract a diverse population of students.
Yes, board member Rucker, but I'm going to put into say that I will ask the district and county to come back just the way you did, but we'll continue.
Since I have you up here, I do have a couple of questions.
Could you summarize what your recruitment plan is that you believe you wrote in your petition?
Right now, because our facility is very small, there tends to be more of a word of mouth.
It seems like it is a more active way of getting our students.
We intend to go out and do community meetings in various kind of community gathering places.
We also are going to do a wide-reaching advertisement campaign.
We haven't done that as much in the past just because we just, again, our limited resources or room at our current site just won't allow it.
outreach to the community.
What do you mean when you say that?
Well we we put out information about our school and then we get you know we have our enrollment but again we've only got certain amount of spots available and then the rest of our students those students are on wait lists.
So I think once we are able to move to a bigger facility again in the charter you'll see that we plan many many more outreach
efforts to different places in the community, places where people gather.
Also, again, another wide-reaching advertising campaign over in that neck of the woods.
And I heard you say you have a wait list, is that correct?
Yes, currently we have 130 students on our current wait list.
And what's the ethnicity of the students on your wait list?
I couldn't tell you off the top of my head but they're from all over the county and we are open to all students of all over the county and we don't just have students in our school from La Mesa Spring Valley, we have students from the surrounding areas as well.
Okay and concerning this because I am confused about the two sites I'll be honest with you it would have been better if I had never heard about the site that was authorized by a district that's not related to the petition we're asking today it would have eliminated some of my confusion.
So I want to focus just on the site that's inside La Mesa Spring Valley.
The petition before you I appreciate that.
So for the site that's inside La Mesa Spring Valley that this petition is related to
are those the students that are going to be going to your new site?
I think most likely.
I think that we have students that have begun our program and are definitely probably going to be interested in enrolling.
I didn't ask the question correctly.
I'm sorry.
Okay, no, that's not your fault.
That means I didn't ask the question correctly.
As it relates to the students at the La Mesa site, are those, is that the,
students that you are building this new building for?
I think we're, I'm trying to understand what you're saying.
The students that are currently in our program, I'm going to make a strong shake my head assumption that they are going to want to enroll at our new, in our new
Okay, how many students is that?
That's 240.
And this new building will house how many more students?
250, 260.
It's at capacity it can be 500.
So at capacity it'd be 500.
So you'd be
recruiting half again as many students as you have right now.
And yet the development plan that you described to me, the fairs and all those other recruitment strategies are what you're going to use to recruit those additional students.
And you have students on your waiting list of over 130 students, but you can't tell me about the ethnicity of those students.
I don't have that information right in front of me, but I can tell you that they come from all over San Diego County.
And so they would have a place or in line for that new school when you move, is that correct?
Well, we are about to start our open enrollment season.
And so those students that are on wait lists are asked to re-enroll.
They do not stay on a wait list.
I understand that.
So those 130 that you're speaking of, they wouldn't necessarily be the same 130 that are automatically called, hey, we have a spot for you.
It would be a new fresh cohort, if you will,
in the fall with our enrollment.
We're starting our own enrollment season now.
Okay, thank you.
But wasn't one of the sites 50 miles away?
So are you expecting students to go 50 miles?
We have.
I'm not expecting that.
However, we have that option open for our families.
We actually do have a few families that live kind of out towards that neck of the woods.
But we would expect that the students that live in La Mesa or the surrounding environs of La Mesa, the communities around this, Lemon Grove, Spring Valley, El Cajon, what have you, would probably want to enroll in the La Mesa Spring Valley campus.
Okay, Member Burr is next.
So I think I'm more confused than I ever was.
I'm trying to understand what the consequence would be of us not approving this petition.
Because if I hear what you're saying, just let me make sure I understand this.
It's a little bit about the current school, because we hear lots of wonderful things about the current school.
So there is a school operating.
My understanding is that that school is operating under Mountain Empire petition.
So if we were not able to come to an agreement today about this petition, what happens to those kids?
The students that are currently in our La Mesa facility, they would have the option to enroll in the school at East County, which is 50 miles away.
I just heard you say that you were expecting them to move there anyway.
No, I'm sorry if that's what you thought.
No, like I had said, I would expect that students that live in La Mesa and the surrounding environments would want to stay with the La Mesa location and would move to the new facility or stay in La Mesa.
They would not go 50 miles out to Campo.
So they would stay in La Mesa in the church?
We would no longer exist as College Prep Middle School.
The facility or the school that we operate now, the one school that we operate, outside of this is the charter that we have, if I can back up the track, in 2010 we were authorized by Mountain Empire Unified School District.
We operated happily in La Mesa Spring Valley, the one location rule applied at that time.
We're kind of bebopping along in our location, and as we grew, we made a decision that we needed to start planning for a new facility.
Again, we have the capacity for 240 students, and that's it.
That's all the fire marshal will allow us.
When we started to pursue the new facility, litigation was brought against us by the Little Mesa Spring Valley School District.
Granted, we were five years operating in La Mesa.
La Mesa Spring Valley actually provided our lunch services for three years.
They provided transportation for our students.
We bought back these services from them.
They sued us alleging that they were never properly notified that we were located in La Mesa.
In order to, I know, in order to avoid an expensive litigation, and I have to tell you this has been four years now of this, it's an expensive fight and we're a small school.
Over such a technical concern, we decided that the best thing to do would be to look to be locally authorized.
And I'm here to tell you that we tried.
We've tried three times to be locally authorized by the La Mesa Spring Valley School District.
And each time we have attempted, I mean, we've worked with them.
We've, you know, I think things were very harmonious until the property, the project.
That is what's going on.
So you would be essentially closing our La Mesa facility without your support.
And I hate to be able to just say that and be blunt, but that's what we're facing.
We are looking forward to our plans of opening a school in Mountain Empire.
We're looking forward to that, moving our school over there.
Currently the Mountain Empire School District was deeded some property and we've been with Mountain Empire for eight years and enjoyed a wonderful, wonderful relationship with our authorizers.
So we know these things are possible.
They really are, I would need you to know that.
It's possible for a charter school to work collaboratively, cooperatively with their sponsoring district.
And in good faith, we tried to make that happen with La Mesa Spring Valley to no avail.
When the first lawsuit was found to be, well, we ended up closing that charter, again, because we wanted to get locally authorized.
La Mesa Spring Valley has brought litigation against us twice.
Once, a week before school started this past year, they tried to get a restraining order to keep our students from coming to our school.
Thankfully, the judge didn't see the beauty in that.
And I must tell you that both those litigations, we prevailed in both of those.
So it's been a very long journey to get to here with you.
As you can imagine, when you're a business that's five years into operation and you're doing all the right things.
You're growing, you're fiscally responsible, your kids are doing well, your families are supported.
Every indicator that you throw at us, every measure that you give us, we've excelled.
And at five years, we believe that we needed to grow in order to serve more students in our community.
And then to be faced with this type of opposition, even though we've tried to become locally approved.
That's the long story, and I apologize for the length, but it has.
It's been four years of litigation, and that's what brings us here today.
It's not the EC charter, because we enjoy a wonderful collaborative relationship with Mountain Empire, and we have a wonderful school planned for the fall.
Board Member Sung.
Petition in front of you, this is the one that will continue to serve the community we've been serving for eight years.
The program that we've been showing you the history of, all of that wonderful thing, the parents that have been in our program, that is what you are.
Member Sung.
Thank you, that really was very helpful to get a little bit more of that context in the history.
So the school that was closed down, that was located in La Mesa.
Will essentially be replaced.
It will be this, it will be this one.
And the students who were in that school are temporarily under this other charter until such time you can get there.
So that's where, those are the students who are actually going to be going to the school.
Right.
Okay, I think we have that.
And I'm sorry for the confusion.
That is enough.
I'm ready for the district and the county to come up and make their rebuttals to what they've heard or add anything they want to add.
I think that this illustrates the issue that La Mesa Spring Valley had in considering this petition.
We have now heard it's going to be one school, two schools, we're moving, we're surrendering.
They did not prevail in the litigation, they mooted the litigation by surrendering their charter, and so the judge actually said, you threw in the towel, they are the prevailing party.
They did not prevail in the first litigation.
The idea that they didn't engage in it, they appealed a demur to the Court of Appeals and had it tied up for three years.
And so the litigation was certainly engaged in and avoided and it was ultimately successful and that is why we are here.
And so the idea that they prevailed in both cases is completely inaccurate.
The issue is that the same teachers that currently work at the facility in La Mesa are the same teachers that signed the Campo petition
are the same teachers that were going to move there and teach.
And at the time La Mesa Spring Valley was considering this petition, two school districts had the same petition with the same teachers and the same kids and the same funding to support it.
This is all about that facility.
And a public school district learning at a planning commission, the new public school facility was going to be built in their boundaries.
That facility was not approved by Mountain Empire.
Mountain Empire was not aware of that facility.
Mountain Empire is 50 miles away and does not oversee this charter.
They do not.
They are serving La Mesa Spring Valley residents.
And the district that is left to deal with all of the behavior that is not overseen is La Mesa Spring Valley.
The students that are not served there, the homeless students, the special ed students, the English learners, the socioeconomically depressed students, those are all in La Mesa schools.
We are looking at a district.
We're not looking at that little neighborhood.
The budget that you're looking at is totally different than the budget we considered.
The budget Mesa Spring Valley considered was based on the exact same open funding balance as the one Mountain Empire granted.
Mountain Empire had granted that when the Mesa Spring Valley considered it.
So we would be granting a charter, a second charter with the same $1.5 million, the same eight teacher signatures, and the same 240 students.
And how could we approve that?
They were moving to Campo.
That's what they said to us.
That's what they represented in the litigation.
That charter is closing.
We're moving to Campo.
Judge, don't order anything against us.
We are already moving.
That's why a second case was necessary, because on the eve of trial, they surrendered their charter and got a new one in one month with a few days' notice to La Mesa Spring Valley.
And so this concept of we've been constantly trying to work together is really not accurate.
Mr. Marshall actually went to their board meeting and encouraged them to work with him to submit a petition.
And all we were requesting is to work with us on the facility, that we did not need a new public school facility built kitty corner to an existing school.
They wouldn't work with us on the facility.
They wouldn't tell us anything about it.
There was a question asked about the documentation.
That documentation was requested by La Mesa-Spring Valley several times, and they refused to provide it.
We now know, in receiving it from you all, that it existed at that time.
When we requested it, it existed.
And it was provided to you, but not us.
Not the county.
That's a problem.
That's a huge problem.
How can a lease, we were entering a lease, backing a lease that we couldn't look at.
That is a huge problem.
And so the idea that it was all cooperative, they've been very cooperative with CDE.
They've provided CDE any information CDE wants to know.
With us, they wouldn't come to a meeting.
They wouldn't even tell us about the deal, who owned the property.
We learned through these documents it is owned by an out of state corporation.
That was purchased by a public charter school in California with public
Tax dollars that is now owned by a developer and so these are real issues that we were grappling with at the time and we didn't Have the clarity that you all are now being provided at all.
We didn't have a developer come to the meetings We didn't have a single parent come to the meeting None of these folks that have spoke before you came to any of the Mesa Spring Valley board meetings.
I
To provide comment.
They did not comment.
They did not comment at the board meetings.
I was there So anyway that I think that is there are obviously many perspectives on this and I I guess that is the reason why I think it is very difficult for this board in Sacramento to understand the difference between Mountain Empire, which is a very rural huge area with 3,000 students and La Mesa Spring Valley, which is an urban area with over 12,000
And so it is it is very difficult I think for this board to actually have an understanding of what you're approving you're approving These petitioners to operate a second charter to have two charters 50 miles apart with two different authorizers with the same seven teacher signatures
Superintendent, would you like to comment?
Certainly.
As was asked and stated, the information provided to the Department of Education is different than the information that was provided to La Mesa Spring Valley or the San Diego County Office of Education.
We did request for any and all documents related to the land lease and all of that, and we're told that we've given you everything.
I know, in seeing the documents that you guys have, that the second lease is dated May 5th, 2017.
In a letter to us that you have dated June, he stated, we've given you everything.
That is not the case.
There was a second lease that actually would have clarified.
If you look through the emails I sent, I said, hey, the budget doesn't really look like the budget should.
Your numbers are different.
As I use this letter of intent that we have, that doesn't calculate.
There has to be something else going on.
No, no, no.
You have everything.
i even so okay if you're not going to come to the meeting here's an email here's my questions just give me an answer and you guys have that i spelled it all out and we received zero information back it's almost as if they didn't want local approval i'm not going to say they didn't because i don't know but it's almost as if what i would tell you is that i offered and i think you have this as well i offered to meet with them to help review the petition the very first one as to expedite approval was the words that i put in the email
They wrote back and said, no, no, no, we've got some legal stuff we're working on.
We're good.
Okay.
So, anyway.
Board member Rucker was next.
Yeah, board member Rucker was next.
You want to talk to the UNF?
Okay.
Yeah.
So, when I studied all six of the charter hearings that we were looking at this for these two days, I actually thought this was going to be the easy one.
I sought two petitions, two authorizers, two sites, and that became my simple way of understanding what this charter was about and attempting to unravel a morass of timelines and all of these things.
I did go back and read through all the material, the petition, and I did craft and construct a timeline, and I do agree with you that there are some issues in the timeline about the communication, about what you requested, and whether or not you received it, so I do agree with you on that.
But now, before I say this next sentence, Mr. President, I truly object to the behavior of people in the room
in shouting out and shouting at people at the dais.
It's not just the parents and other folks from the community, but we've had people who go to these board meetings regularly who are also behaving in inappropriate ways, and that needs to stop and be put in check.
So the reason I said this, because now I'm going to say the next thing,
While it may seem on the surface that there is some intentionality to be deceitful or to defraud in some way, I don't actually believe that was the issue.
I think that probably there is some mismanagement, probably there's some misunderstanding, and probably there, I don't believe there was a purpose of, there was purposeful evasion.
What I believe was,
There was a desire to try to resolve what they felt was an untenable legal circumstance that they found themselves in, and they looked for the path of least resistance to try to resolve it.
But the problem is they created more problems than they actually resolved.
So my question to you is, because I want to be real clear,
You have students who are otherwise students in your district who are currently at a charter school site in your district that's authorized by another school district.
Going back to board member Burr's question, if this charter is not approved today, I have two questions.
The first is if this charter is not approved today, where will those students be?
So there is two options for those students.
There is an existing charter with Mountain Empire.
It's called College Prep Middle School East County, which will operate next year, I believe.
The students could choose to attend College Prep Middle School East County.
That would have to be located in the Mountain Empire School District, which is some 50 miles away.
So some students may choose to do that.
I don't know.
The students who are not choosing to follow to the College Prep Peace County, they would then need to enroll in another school in the La Mesa community.
That could be one of our schools, Parkway Middle School, one of the elementary schools, since it's a five through eight program, they would be served both in elementary and middle schools.
If they don't reside within the La Mesa boundaries, and as you heard, some of these students reside in other neighboring districts, whether that is El Cajon or in San Diego Unified, those students would then need to find a school in their community.
There's also other charter schools that operate within the community.
I would tell you that La Mesa Spring Valley, we operate three 4th through 8th grade academy schools.
The La Mesa Arts Academy focused on the performing arts, and so kids would have to find a place or go to these schools.
So then that takes me to my second question, and this goes back to this building.
So I do agree with you that they knew they had this building.
I am confused about whether they bought it, if they gave money to an out-of-state entity, if they have a lease.
All of that's very confusing to me.
I do know that there was an exchange of state funds with somebody.
I don't know if it means they own it or they lease it, but I am very clear as of the spring last year, they have a building.
Where do you think this building is in your district?
So this building is now a old church lot that is in Spring Valley on Madrid Way.
It is across the street, Caddy Corner, from an existing elementary school, Casadero Elementary.
Okay, so relative to the building these students are currently going to school in, how far away will this new building be?
Not very, very far, maybe five to eight miles.
Okay, so if this charter is approved and they're allowed to go forward with developing this building, I'm assuming they're saying or asserting that the building can be ready for them.
About nine months.
In about nine months.
So in the meanwhile, where do you believe these students, if the charter is approved, where do you believe these students will be?
I believe the plan that has been presented would be that for the first start of the 2018-19 school year, students would remain in the existing facility.
As the new facility became online, then they would be migrated to the new facility sometime mid-year.
Okay, so that's where I started getting confused when the original presentation was made.
So your La Mesa students who are currently housed in a building that is being authorized as a charter in another district would actually leave this building, go to the new building site in nine months once it's completed.
They would still be La Mesa students, Spring Valley students in a building in La Mesa Spring Valley in a charter authorized by this board, by this board if the petition is approved.
Does that,
So while the board is not a party to any of your litigations and any of your conflicts and issues that you have with these authorizers, as it directly relates to this building and those students, what issues get resolved by that for the students and your district?
So if the state, the board, were to authorize the College Prep Middle School in Mesa Spring Valley, which is the one that is there, then the issue that would be resolved for our students would be they would have their charter school within their community for next year.
Okay.
And I hope you know I'm being very honest.
I'm not couching my words at all.
I'm telling you the truth.
Okay, so the issue that remains for me and the issue I'm still I'm confused by and it is an issue that you did raise is about the funds and the funding and how the building was procured.
Does that none of this approval process here unravels those fiscal issues or does it clarify any of those fiscal issues that are still very murky even for me today?
And I would add that one of the questions that was asked is that if the school goes out into the market to get bonds to purchase the building, who is liable for those bonds if they are defaulted upon?
But they've already given somebody some money.
They have entered into a 20-year lease.
I mean, this is my understanding.
I haven't seen the new documents.
But I can tell you from the old documents, because I'm very familiar with those, if you want.
Yes.
Okay.
So they've entered into a 20-year lease to rent facility.
They're not buying that facility.
There's buyout options in the lease, but the lease isn't a lease purchase.
It's a lease.
And then at the year three, you can purchase it for 125% of the construction cost or whatever.
That kind of thing.
Right.
I understood.
So yeah, that's where I started getting confused again.
Did they buy it?
Are they leasing it?
It's a lease with an option to buy, but the buyout isn't part of the lease payments.
The lease payments are separate from the buyout.
Thank you.
I appreciate, I thank you.
I appreciate.
You're very welcome.
You have unwrapped some other, you have unwrapped some other concerns that I had.
Thank you.
Yeah, Bruce is next.
Well, I just want to pursue this one if I could in that regard.
Can CDE come up and talk about what you saw?
I mean, we have allegations about the facility and how it's financed and people are operating off of different documents.
I'd like to hear what you saw
I don't think, in my own personal view is there's nothing inherently evil about going out and getting a private developer and getting them to build a school.
It always to me, you know, the idea that all of these things have to be financed by the public and that anything else is evil, I never agreed with.
So if it is, but what they explain never made sense to me either.
If it is a lease payment,
And the developer then has a guaranteed enrollment of these students if developer can make money on this.
So, but they were talking about buying it.
So, can you tell us what then this they're saying about this?
Okay, what we did see is that the petitioner will finance the project costs through the lease payments.
So we took into account the $42,000 that they stated would be the lease payment for the facility.
So we took that into account into their financials, not the option to then purchase that if it goes down that path.
Yeah, because we are looking at it within that makes sense to me where they were going to get this money to buy the building was in that that was the way they lease payments or lease payments and using a developer to get it is not to me a problem.
But yeah, I couldn't believe how they were going to buy this thing.
So just for the board's understanding, the state does have programs.
They're housed over at the School Finance Authority.
And there are other agencies throughout the state that enable charter schools to issue
tax exempt bonds to finance the purchase of facilities.
I presume that's what they were referring to.
And those bonds are typically secured by a sort of a lease arrangement, a lease payment arrangement.
become the, or the lease payments for the charter school, for the facilities, go to pay the interest and principal on the bonds until the bonds are retired.
So I presume that's what, you probably talked to the charter folks themselves, but I presume that's what they're planning.
Go ahead with the leases.
Board Member Holliday.
Well, I don't want to rush things, but... Yeah, we're getting along.
I would be prepared to make a motion, and the reason I feel comfortable with this motion is because I do believe that we have a group of educators that are providing a quality program for their students.
I don't understand what all the lawsuits are about.
I don't understand the intent of the lawsuits.
I don't understand the outcome of the lawsuits.
But I do understand that this is a group who unfortunately originally was authorized outside this district, and that has created a great deal of difficulty on all sides.
This school approved today.
It will mean that there will be a continuation of this school's program and the teachers and parents and the family at this at this location for
a period of time until this other facility comes online.
I have over the years dealt with these sorts of development companies in my own experience.
I have been in and out of lease arrangements.
They do come from out of state often.
It doesn't mean there's anything wrong with that.
They come from in state other times.
They all have to have above-board practices, and I don't think that puts us at a liability.
I am concerned about the demographics as always.
There's never a reason why a charter school can't adequately mirror the demographics of the district.
I do believe that there has been a challenge with only bringing in a handful of kids each year and not really an outreach program.
They haven't really focused on that.
But I do think that when the new facility comes online that it will provide them an opportunity to do some different and orchestrated outreach.
And I certainly hope that that is the case.
We don't want to let that drop at all.
Anyway, I will recommend approval of the CDE's recommendation.
And I'll second.
Any further board discussion?
Okay.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, those opposed.
Okay, the board will take a recess.
We'll come back at 2.20.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're on item 23, the petition for Phoenix Charter Academy in Shasta County, California.
Item 23 is an appeal by Phoenix Charter Academy to establish a charter school.
Pursuant to Ed Code section J1, petitioners for a charter school that have been denied at the local level may petition the state board for approval of the charter subject to certain conditions.
On May 9th, 2017, Shasta Union High School District voted to deny the petition on a vote of five to zero.
June 13th, 2017, Whitmore Union Elementary School District voted to approve the petition on a vote of three to two.
So Phoenix is currently open and operating under the Whitmore Union Elementary School District.
Staff, our understanding is the school will continue to operate under Whitmore.
So after they are currently operating under Whitmore, they then went to the Shasta County Office of Education to get their petition approved there.
The Shasta County Office of Ed voted to deny the petition on a vote of seven to zero.
And so now the petition for Phoenix Charter is before the State Board of Education on appeal.
This is a non-classroom based program.
To give you a little history, Phoenix was previously operated as the Academy of Personalized Learning.
They were authorized from August 18th, 2009 through June 30th, 2017, and they were authorized by Gateway Unified School District.
APL offered to voluntarily close as of June 30th, 2017 prior to revocation from Gateway.
PCA, again, is currently operating at the same location as when they were Apple, when they were Academy of Personalized Learning, so they are at that same location.
I know, I'm sorry.
I'm going to try and make this less confusing.
I know it can be confusing.
Okay.
Again, the proposed grade level is K-12, independent study, non-classroom based program.
Current enrollment is 331.
And based on the information received, they plan to stay at that enrollment through the 2022-23 school year.
It is a resource center located in Redding, California, which is within the Shasta County, but outside the geographic boundaries of Whitmore Union.
So that's why they're here.
The Resource Center includes administrative offices, meeting spaces, a school library, computer labs, and classrooms.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on February 7th, 2018, and they moved staff recommendation to deny the petition.
Four commissioners voted in favor, three voted against, and as you know, five votes are needed to move the recommendation to the State Board, so no recommendation moved forward.
The petitioner did submit additional information after the ACCS meeting that was reviewed by CDE staff.
The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to establish Phoenix Charter Academy.
Our denial is based on demonstratively unlikely to implement the program and being unfamiliar with some of the requirements of law.
They have a marginal fiscal viability, unsuccessful history, previously operated as the Academy of Personalized Learning, and they do have some deficiencies still, even after we reviewed their additional information that we found in their charter elements.
PCA previously operated as Apple, as I mentioned earlier, charter school during this time period.
So they were authorized by Gateway Unified School District, same resource center location in Redding.
On October 15, 2015, APL filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy protection.
On November 9, 2016, the Gateway Board approved issuance of a notice of violation to be issued to the charter school as APL.
Their reasons for the notice of violation was that they were violating the law, that they were not within the geographic boundaries of the district at the time, and they were failing to demonstrate increases in pupil achievement.
Those were the grounds the district had at the time.
February 22nd, 2017, the Gateway Board provided APL a notice of intent to revoke and a notice of facts in support of revocation.
The Gateway Board took no action because APL offered to voluntarily close as of June 30th, 2017.
March 10, 2017, APL stakeholders then drafted and submitted the Phoenix petition to the Shasta Union High School District.
Then it was subsequently denied by the Shasta Union High School District, approved by the Whitmore Union Elementary School District, and then denied by the Shasta County Office of Education.
And then these are the elements in the charter petition that even with additional information, we do feel that there are some deficiencies in the charter.
I'm here to answer any questions that you may have.
Okay, thank you.
Technical questions for CDE.
Did they they submitted a petition to Shasta County just as a countywide petition or that was an appeal petition?
That was well it was an appeal petition from the appeal that when they submitted to Shasta the high school district because they are located within their bounds.
Okay then we're ready for the public hearing.
And so I'm going to open the public hearing.
Each side has 10 minutes.
So I'll start with the petitioners who want to have the state board approve the charter and they'll have 10 minutes and then the opponents 10 minutes.
Here we go.
I'm Dr. Patricia Doherty, and I would like to start this afternoon with thanking all of you for sharing your time with us and giving us time to appear in front of you today.
I would like to introduce Carl Yoder.
He is here to discuss our fiscal viability with you.
He is a principal of DMS, and they do our back office.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Patricia had asked me, due to the importance of the fiscal viability of the Charter, that I speak for a few minutes at the start of the presentation.
Patricia will then go through the PowerPoint and provide additional information.
I am speaking solely on the fiscal viability.
I really wanted to talk about four major points in the next few minutes.
The first one has to do with the individual findings of fact presented in the CDE analysis.
We commend CDE staff for their work.
We continue to have some minor differences of opinion on a number of items.
Lottery funding, we did not include in the first year.
LCFF funding is updated, provides additional revenue.
Mandate block grant has been increased and provides actually additional revenue over what was in our original petition.
We can go through the individual items and I am happy to answer questions, but I would really like to move to my second point, which is for the sake of argument, let's take at face value the conclusions that CDE arrived at.
That is a very small surplus, $655 in the first year.
In year two, $177,000 surplus, and that brings the school to a 5.5% reserve, and then up to 7.3% in the third year.
Under SBE's own guidelines in the California Code of Regulations,
It states that charter schools approved by SBE shall be given two years to reach the minimum reserve threshold.
And in this case, CDE's own findings show that the charter meets that reserve level after the second year, and the reserve grows after that.
The third point was for clarity, we had not included any beginning balances that were transferred over from APL, but the reality is APL continued to be financially viable.
The closure was not due to a lack of financial resources.
The school met all of its operational commitments and closed with net asset balance of about $505,000.
As the school is currently operating, Phoenix has received those net assets.
Phoenix under Whitmore now has a net asset balance and will end at about 526,000.
when that $526,000 is taken into account.
In other words, if SBE approves this charter, the SBE-approved charter opens next year, that new charter will begin with a net asset balance of over $500,000, effectively negating the claim that the school would have insufficient resources.
And my fourth point, before I turn it over to Patricia, as the board is well aware, charter schools are encouraged to be approved, and they should only be denied if they are demonstrably unlikely to succeed.
In this situation, Phoenix is operating successfully.
It's operating under Whitmore, is operating successfully this year, showing a surplus, and the only reason that the school is before SPE, as Patricia will outline,
is due to legal issues having to do with Shasta Union High School District.
With that, I'm available for any questions after the presentation, but I'm turning it over to Patricia to continue the PowerPoint for the remaining of the 10 minutes.
Thank you.
As Carl had stated, Phoenix Charter Academy is successfully operating with the sponsorship of Whitmore.
We are also being relentlessly attacked by the traditional districts.
We are operating with Whitmore on an exception.
There is not the real estate in Whitmore to house our program in its totality.
Imagine what it must be like to run a charter school that you are continually under attack for.
And we do have to defend when we are attacked legally by the traditional districts in our area.
I'm forced to spend public funds to do that.
I would rather buy Chromebooks for our students.
And I don't have that option because I have to be able to defend.
And if in the event SBE does decide to vote for us today to sponsor us, we will be closing our Whitmore charter and transferring our assets.
One of the claims from CDE was that we had not provided training for our ESL parents.
We are developing an ESL program within our LCAP and within our first and second charter years.
Along with that, it is also in our LCAP, which we have sent you a copy of, that we are developing parent training for not just our ESL independent study students,
which we will, I'm sure, have moving forward.
We don't have now.
We're also developing those programs for our population of independent study students.
We do have measurable pupil outcomes, and they are listed in our LCAP.
We have many things that we benchmark with.
One of them is ed performance.
And being our first year, we did set a goal of
our students being able to make across the board a minimum of a 5% growth in their academic progress.
The next claim was that we lacked a description of our employee qualifications.
We did send you all of our credentials.
All of our staff are fully credentialed and qualified.
There was also a remark made about our SPED team not being qualified.
We have a speech and language pathologist who works with us.
It is a full-time position and she is fully qualified with all certifications.
We have an RSP teacher who is with us.
She has her
her foreign language credential, her EL certification.
She has her RSP credential, her learning handicap credential as our RSP person.
The administration holds a doctorate degree.
I am fully qualified.
I have also had two years of leadership training with the SELPA as well as CBO training with CSDC.
You do have access to all of our credentials.
We did send them with a matrix.
I am here to say that we are fully qualified and we are fully committed to our students.
There was also a claim regarding our admission requirements.
PCA's admission and enrollment requirements are aligned in strict accordance with the law and we do not prevent barriers for any of our students.
As was stated earlier, we did surrender our charter back to Gateway Unified School District.
That was a strategic move.
It was also noted for the record that we had filed Chapter 11.
I think it was called Chapter 11 bankruptcy.
It was called Chapter 11 reorganization.
Those are two different things.
When we had stood before the judge requesting Chapter 11, that was also strategic.
We were being attacked viciously.
Our resources were being eaten up rapidly, and we could not gain any control of the chaos that was happening to us.
When we stood before that judge, if we had been insolvent,
He would have immediately changed us from a Chapter 11 to a Chapter 7 or Chapter 13.
We were never insolvent.
It was a strategic move.
I am more than willing to answer any questions that you have for us on that period in our life.
We did approach, after the Shasta Anderson decision, we did approach Gateway Unified School District and ask for a waiver and they denied it outright.
So we were moving forward to operate with the letter of the law.
Shasta Union High School District is in our geographic boundaries, they denied.
Whitmore was willing to take us on to preserve not only our charter school for our families and our students, but to, they really do believe in our program and we have a wonderful working relationship with them.
And they do know we're here today and I do believe you have in your handouts the letter from Dr. Robbins in our support and I apologize he's on a cruise and couldn't be here today.
He's the lucky one.
and we are here to answer any of your questions and add any clarity that we possibly can for you.
Thank you.
Okay, that completes your presentation and now we'll move to the opponents for 10 minutes.
We're under the public hearing.
Public hearing is open.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
My name's Adam Ferber.
I'm the lawyer for the Shasta County Office of Education.
Just wanted to kind of identify myself and let you know that I'm here for any questions and to introduce Ms.
Amy Barker from Shasta County Office of Education who has a statement.
Hi, I'm Amy Barker, Executive Director of Administrator Support Services, where I support charter schools and the regular schools.
I oversee and provide support to two of our charter schools as well.
Our office and governing board opposed the grant of Phoenix Appeal.
Our main concern among many is that over time the school's marginally viable budget, as it is called in your staff report, with no 5% reserve and a 655 ending balance for fiscal year 2018-19.
is unsustainable and is a strong predictor of future fiscal instability that will inevitably impact students.
When the school's petition came to us, our office review of the financial plan disclosed 13 substantial concerns about its fiscal viability.
These concerns continue to be present.
Phoenix began operation under Whitmore, as stated earlier,
July of 2017.
However, it did not submit STRS contribution that it deducted from payroll earnings to the county office until January of this year, January 16th of this year.
STRS notified us in November of 2017 that a Phoenix employee account was 120 days past due.
for deductions owned under the STRS buyback program.
Those past due funds for November through January were not remitted until the end of January.
How the school handled those funds during the time raises a red flag.
This is especially true in light of the school's unsuccessful financial history as APL.
We regard Phoenix and APL as one in the same, essentially as a single school without any demonstrated history of fiscal health over an extended time period.
The last minute budget revisions do very little to reassure us it is a good candidate for sustained future success.
We believe that the efforts of our office and our governing board in considering the Phoenix appeal were extensive and conscientious.
We believe that our governing board's denial of the petition was absolutely correct for fiscal instability as well as for other programmatic inadequacies outlined in the reasons we denied the charter back in June.
Nothing that the school has done since then has changed our mind.
We therefore ask the board to deny the appeal.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Jim Cloney.
I'm superintendent for the Shasta Union High School District.
My first visit to the state board, I wish to thank you for your service on behalf of the students of our state.
I know having worked with the board for 10 years as superintendent, it is a thankless job, so I do appreciate that.
Also, I have to say, Shasta Union High School District, I was not aware up until the last couple of years how often Shasta came up in your conversations.
We are aware of that.
So I'm going to make two quick points.
I know we have other folks who need to speak, but the first is to reiterate, and I know this is a point that's made by other districts, is we consider ourselves charter friendly.
We do have two longstanding charters that our district has supported for many, many years.
Shasta Charter Academy, which I know the board is familiar with.
We have supported that charter since the late 90s, and we also have University Preparatory School, which we actually just two nights ago renewed their charter for an additional five years.
So we do consider ourselves good supporters of charters and a good authorization district.
The second point I wanted to make is just with respect to the Phoenix Charter Academy proposal.
Just roughly one year ago, I met with Ms.
Dougherty.
I've known Ms.
Dougherty for many years.
I know many people associated with Phoenix Charter Academy as friends and colleagues.
We had an open conversation, a very transparent one, I believe, when she was looking for a district to consider their charter.
I believe we were very transparent in that conversation about we would certainly do our due diligence, that we held no preconceived notions against Phoenix Charter Academy or APL or either of those two entities.
We believe our process in reviewing the 16 points in the charter was thorough.
And our board did come to a unanimous 5-0 decision to make the denial.
So we certainly encourage the board to support that decision, support our county office's decision.
I know the advisory commission did not make a recommendation, although that recommendation was denial.
And of course, staff from CDE has recommended denial.
So we are here just to encourage the board to follow those recommendations.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Thanks for sticking in through the long day.
My name is Megan Macy.
I am an attorney for Shasta Union High School District.
There is plenty of documentation in the records submitted by our office, but you certainly have a robust staff report from CDE staff.
So I'm not going to belabor the technical points for the reasons that the petition should be denied, but I want to make the point that the reason that the high school denied this petition is because it is a subpar charter petition.
And even given the many opportunities that the CDE staff has given to provide additional information, which we
don't think it's proper in the charter petitioning process, the recommendation is still for denial.
And there's a couple of really big reasons why.
The first is that this is a petitioner with a very negative history in operating charter schools.
And as Ms.
Dougherty herself mentioned, they've made a lot of tactical decisions over time in an effort to
you know, to avoid consequences of their own decision-making.
And that's a concern for Shasta High School District.
The reason for filing Chapter 11 bankruptcy, according to the petitioners, was so they could avoid consequences of the teachers in their district
and they had an onslaught of unfair labor practice charges.
That's just not something that is proper under the EERA, and that's a concern for the high school district.
Secondly, the conditions on the budget.
Moving forward, it's based on anticipated enrollment of 331 students.
Based on their own numbers of the demographics that were given, I think in this last round, they have a current enrollment of 294 students.
So there's continued red flags.
Not going to belabor the issues anymore, but we would just strongly encourage denial of the petition today.
Thank you very much.
Okay, that completes those initial 10-minute presentations and now we're ready for the public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up at the podium?
Ken Burt, Sheila Whitley, Pat Keener, Jeff Rice, Rommel Antone, Eric Premack, Christopher Rothrock, Mercedes Bradley, Sherry Cocking Keener, Cheryl Woodman, Amy Barker, Adam Ferber, Marty Stainbrook, Lisa Core, Michelle Lopez, Ona Heller, Claire Crawford, Jim Cloney, Megan Macy, Carney Rasmussen.
Good afternoon, Sheila Whitley speaking for CTA.
The California Teachers Association strongly opposes the overturning of the local and county decisions in this matter.
In this case, CTA fully supports the department's recommendation to deny this appeal.
We do this for concerns with physical concerns and also the EERA employee rights concerns.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Patrick Keener.
I'm one of the board members for PCA and thank you very much for allowing us to be here today.
Charter schools are a public school of choice.
And as a board member, I believe that I take this job seriously in taking a look at the fiscal accountability for PCA.
I believe they are physically sound.
They're moving in the right direction.
We have been very, very happy with the support that we've got from Dr. Robbins and the Whitmore School District.
that we would probably continue to want to stay under that direction.
Unfortunately, because of all the legal requirements, the legal hassles that PCA is undergoing by the Chester Union High School districts and others within the area, we feel threatened and coerced and intimidated that Whitmore will have to give up the sponsorship and certification.
So I'm here today to ask you to please support our certification through the CDE.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Sherry Kockenkeener.
I'm a teacher at Phoenix Charter Academy.
I've taught for over 20 years.
I've been a teacher there for two years.
I have never worked with a more professional staff or administration.
We do have an organized association.
So as far as my rights as a teacher and what I'm doing, I'm covered there.
I think in Reading, we're unique that
that families get to choose the school that they attend, whether or not they live in that particular homeschool district.
I don't see the difference of that being with a charter school.
Yes, there might be other charter schools in our district,
but they should have the opportunity to continue to go to our charter school, which is Phoenix Charter Academy.
We have many families that couldn't be comfortable in other places.
They weren't given the opportunity at other locations, and they have been with us.
And to close us and not give us this charter would really affect over 300 families.
Thank you.
All righty, board.
My name is Marty Stambrick.
I'm a former APL board member.
I'm well acquainted with the deceptions, half-truths, and overall lack of moral integrity of CTA and some of its members.
I'm currently a very satisfied parent of a son who is a student at PCA.
I'm here to advocate for PCA.
My son's educators at PCA have exceeded my expectations with the openness and communications to further my son's education.
I've found the staff to be very friendly and willing to help with any concerns I've had.
I find it a bit frustrating that I have to advocate for the school of my choice because my local superintendents care more about their future retirement than my son's education.
I hope this board finds in favor of supporting PCA as the state can protect us from the ongoing attacks and nonstop bullying of the CTA, Shasta County Office of Education, and the traditional district superintendents.
so that I can continue to take my son to the public school of my choice.
A parent should not worry whether their child's school will close on a year-to-year basis based on attacks over competitors' public funds.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Christopher Rothrock.
I'm a teacher at Phoenix Charter Academy and I'm here to speak on behalf of my fellow peers.
As you know, we've been under fire by multiple entities and through all this we're just trying to obtain solvency so we can serve our students.
That's what we are here to do.
And in order to ensure that the teachers
remain covered and could put our focus where it needs to be, we have indeed formed an association with 100% involvement from all of our teachers.
Innovation and focus on the individual student has made PCA the school of choice for over 300 students in our community.
Our program is 100% focused on student success, but does not spare the rigor, as is evident by the fact that Phoenix Charter Academy just received its WASC accreditation for three years.
You can imagine with such student-centered work, PCA staff is able to focus on what teachers truly love to do, that is to grow and enrich our students.
We're very excited about the future of this program.
So on behalf of the staff at PCA, I thank you for your time and consideration.
I will be reading a letter from a parent.
My special needs child spent 10 years in Shasta County's traditional public school system.
He attended five different schools in classrooms encompassing general education to special day class.
Last August, I became frustrated to find that his educational plan for the school year involved teaching him shapes, colors, and counting, much like preschool.
My son is 13 years old.
Would you identify yourself for us, please?
Yes, I'm the special ed teacher at Mercedes Brady.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
He was taught nothing in 10 years.
In my frustration, I reached out to PCA and met with their SPED team.
For the first time, I was asked to tell them about my child and about how they could help me educate my son.
The team was truly interested in the academic success of my child, my autistic, nonverbal son.
Time.
is successfully completing language arts, science, social studies at grade level and is excelling in mathematics, working with algebra and geometry.
This is after six months at PCA.
Thank you very, very much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Cheryl Woodman, and I'm reading parts of a letter from the superintendent of Whitmore Union Elementary School District.
You should have this letter in front of you.
Dear California SBE, I'm writing in support of the petition for Phoenix Charter Academy for approval by you.
Whitmore Union Elementary School is a small rural district in Shasta County.
After the Anderson ruling, the learning centers outside of the district boundaries became a major issue.
The districts listed and their attorney continue to claim that the charter schools do not qualify for the exemption stated in Ed Code section 47605A5.
As to date, the district has incurred a total of $31,784 in legal bills fighting for all three charters.
The State Board's approval will remove the specter of a prolonged legal battle over the exemption.
Should the State Board approve Phoenix Charter Academy and decide to delegate oversight responsibilities, Whitmore would be more than happy to do so.
Thank you for your consideration in this matter.
Board, last one for today.
Ramel Antoine with the California Charter Schools Association.
Just really quickly wanted to make a couple of points.
We support PCA based on their track record and what they've been doing so far for students under this authorization under Whitmore.
This 5% reserve that we're talking about, the purpose of the reserve is for schools to offset any unforeseen costs that come up for them.
What we're seeing currently is a playbook in how to exhaust those schools' resources in this reserve to make it so that they're fiscally insolvent, so they're unable to seek reauthorization anywhere else because they can't just make money up.
So this is the second now of many that we'll see coming up under the Shasta decision, and I suggested the board look at the playbook that's going to come up where we exhaust schools' resources to fight cases like these and make it unattractive for districts to approve them.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Jeff Rice with the A Plus Personalized Learning Network Association.
I have worked with Dr. Doherty and her leadership team since 2009 and can personally attest to the fact that they have an unwavering commitment to put students first and to academic excellence and accountability.
You've heard the challenging climate that this school and this leadership team is facing in Shasta County.
Shasta County has become ground zero from the Shasta case.
And I can tell you from personal experience that the contentious nature that exists in that county is becoming more extreme and is not lessening as a result of that appellate court decision.
I find the argument about fiscal instability to be quite ironic.
given the challenging climate and the fact that all of their previous funds were exhausted to defend their right to exist.
It would be like saying that that the culture in London, England in the early 40s was unstable because it was being relentlessly bombed by German warplanes.
This school is solid, serving its students and has been for years and needs your support and protection.
Thank you.
Hi, Claire Crawford with In the Public Interest.
Hopefully this should be more simple than the last one.
This should be a pretty easy decision and so I urge you to deny this petition.
The CDE staff rightly recommends denial due to this school's unsuccessful history.
As you've heard, this is really APL, Academy of Personalized Learning.
APL filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy, was issued a notice of
violation and notice of intent to revoke by the authorizer based in part on academic performance.
This is the same leadership administration and location.
The CDE staff are also raising serious educational and fiscal concerns based on what was submitted for PCA.
In the cases of SBE-authorized Synergy and Paramount, the local and county entities raised concerns that bore out in those schools' failures.
Here you have an actual track record of failure, APLs.
Again, same leadership, same administration, same school location.
It has a track record of failure and should be denied.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Lisa Kaur.
I'm with Young, Mini, and Kaur representing the petitioners.
The Shasta Union High School District has threatened more than once to sue the Whitmore School District for approving this charter for its use of the exemption under 47605.1D, which allows a charter school to operate one facility outside district boundaries but within the county boundaries if there are no facilities within the district boundaries in which it is authorized.
Today, the State Board can support the students that have chosen this charter school, the 320 current students that have chosen this charter school, and their access to the resources that they deserve by authorizing the charter and allowing the school the opportunity to prove its success in fiscal accountability without the diversion of public funds and resources to frivolous litigation.
If you approve, you're approving an already demonstrably successful program which has fought tirelessly for its students against incredible opposition.
You're approving critically important student access to resource center that offers special education services, mandatory testing, labs, and access to instructional materials.
I'm available if there are any questions.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
This is a really interesting case and does have a complex history to it.
If you take something from this, though, the most important message I think that you take from this is that this school is a survivor.
It has withstood assault after assault after assault at the local level and came through operating successfully academically, financially, and operationally.
The stated reasons for denial here are, again, similar to the ones you looked at this morning.
The school, per CDE's own figures, shows a budget reserve of 5.5% in year two and 7.3% in year two and 7.3%
percent in year three.
So it again meets your financial standards that you're supposed to be operating under here.
We've worked with Dr. Dougherty and her team for many years.
She's been through our leadership training and, God help her, came through our CBO training twice.
Very capable team, very strong team, demonstrably likely to succeed even under assault.
Thank you.
California Teachers Association.
So, so far yesterday and today we saw that this board does not care if a petition is not compliant with the Charter Schools Act and it certainly doesn't care if approving a petition will have a negative impact on thousands of district students.
Yesterday we also heard that you are perceived by the charter industry as being an easy authorizer, that charters actually prefer to be rejected by local democratically elected boards
so they can be authorized by you because you will not provide sufficient oversight and accountability, and you will not require charters to follow laws that they don't feel like following, like Government Code 1090.
If you approve this charter, you will be a caricature of a rubber stamp.
You will be saying it doesn't matter if a petitioner previously filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy, that it engaged in authorizer shopping, that it flagrantly violated labor law, that it spent hundreds of thousands of dollars on legal fees rather than students,
that voluntarily closed a charter rather than be revoked, that it illegally discriminated against potential students, that it has zero EL students, and that CDE staff have said that their SPED and EL programs are insufficient and that it is unlikely to succeed.
I urge you to have some respect for the law and for yourselves as authorizers and reject this petition.
Hi, I'm Michelle Lopez representing Phoenix Charter Academy.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young Money and Core.
I want to applaud the CDE and their review process here.
We found that their second review of information is just greatly appreciated and find it to be actually contrary to the last speaker.
part of quality authorizing practices to look at the charter de novo like the Charter Schools Act was intended to be.
That said, I just want to continue with Lisa's conversation about, you know, if this charter is denied, the students here lose the ongoing threats of litigation, the students lose to the ongoing threats of litigation by the Shasta County large school district seeking to monopolize what they deem their sovereign right to educate students.
The districts will think they've won by shutting down every effort made by the charter school to come into compliance with the Anderson decision.
However, these students are not returning to the districts until they offer the unique educational opportunities the students find at Phoenix and why they've chosen that school.
If the charter is denied, there is no winner.
No increase in funds to the school districts, no academic benefits, just loss to those students.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public hearing, so I'm ready for board member discussion.
Board member Strauss.
So, I need, Lisa, I have some clarification.
So, our CD, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Just some clarification.
So, thank you so much.
I mean, this seems really complicated, and I'm not sure we've quite heard one like this, but I'm just trying to see if I understand the facts.
So, this is a charter that is currently authorized by Whitmore.
that Whitmore is saying, state board, you should authorize, but we're glad to continue to oversight.
And they're supporting it.
And so they're operating with a new name, but they're still authorized under Whitmore.
And so if we deny it today,
these kids are still authorized under the Whitmore, is that correct?
The school doesn't close, is that correct?
They are still authorized under the Whitmore.
I don't want to pine upon the validity of the charter approval, but our understanding is that they would continue.
So they're actually, if I understand, and I'm sure there'll be more follow-up from my colleagues,
They're authorized with a different name, and they filed bankruptcy, so now they're trying to change their name and be a new charter, but it's the same kids and the same staff that's asking for the authorization.
They've done that already?
Yes.
They are authorized as Phoenix.
They were previously Academy of Personalized Learning, so it is, from my understanding, the same group.
But yes, they reformed, they pulled that new petition together, presented it before Shasta Union High School District, then to Whitmore.
So they are authorized with that charter under Whitmore.
You're operating with that petition.
And under the Shasta decision, Whitmore's allowed one outside their area.
Is that correct?
Why they're still allowed
If we deny it, they're still allowed to operate outside.
But that's that's my end.
I don't want to opine on any on the on the Anderson decision, but that's my understanding.
But I would let Judy weigh in on that.
And let her let the council talk.
Right.
As the attorney for the charter school testified, they believe they have an exemption under Ed Code, which currently exists that allows an allows a charter school to operate outside of its authorizer boundaries when there is no space available within the authorizer district.
And the other thing, Lisa, and I'm not sure, I know you did a lot of follow-up and asked for extra documentation.
This bankruptcy filing, could you clarify what you know about why they filed for bankruptcy and now are asking again?
Do you know what that was about?
Virginia, do you mind talking about the bankruptcy?
Was it had to do with filing?
I'm sorry.
No, no, it's okay.
Based on the record, there was an unfair labor practice charge from some teachers that were employed by Apple.
The charter school says that they were laid off due to declining enrollment.
The teachers disagreed.
They filed an unfair labor practice charge.
They had some rulings before the Public Employment Relations Board, some hearings going on.
At the same time, they filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy.
As you can see from one of the documents in your electronic red folder, I think there was the bankruptcy court's ruling.
This was from the trustee who said, wait a minute, you seem to be gaming the system.
I think that's what you heard from some of the testimony.
That was in one of your documents.
Okay that board member Rucker.
Well part of what I was going to request was an explanation from Judy about the Shasta decision because we heard in a previous charter school hearing that it also applied to that charter issue and it did not.
So Judy can you just make sure you clarify for us what you know what exactly how this exactly covers what's going on with this charter.
Right, so this one is an issue of a resource center, so it is subject to the Shasta decision.
They were previously authorized by Gateway when they were Apple.
As you know, Gateway, they are located within Shasta, they were not located within Gateway.
At that same time, they were undergoing some of the issues that we had heard regarding the bankruptcy and the labor, so Gateway started revocation proceedings.
They decided to surrender that charter,
rather than be revoked.
And at the same time, based on my understanding, they submitted two petitions, one to Shasta and the same petition, like Lisa said, to Whitmore.
The Whitmore one got picked up.
So at the start of this school year, they're authorized by Whitmore and they closed Apple under Gateway.
Okay and so then my other question then is so and then it's a two-part question.
What happens if we approve and what happens if we disapprove?
What happens if we do not approve this request?
Does the school remain open and operated by whom?
Yes, so like we talked about, I believe the school, their attorney testified that they have an exemption, that they are legally authorized under Whitmore.
They might be subject to some legal challenges, whether or not that's true, but the school would not close immediately unless something, they were revoked or they turned in their charter or a court order, so they would still be open.
So since they're already approved by one authorizer, what do they need this approval for?
Well, they say in their letters that they just want to avoid further court costs and litigation.
I don't see how this approval does that.
Well, they would no longer be fighting because they would be located within Shasta and authorized by you.
So then they would no longer have to satisfy that exemption because they wouldn't be outside of their boundaries.
Oh.
Okay, any other questions?
Liaisons, would you speak please?
So I don't have any questions because I was at the ACCS meeting and heard a lot more testimony there.
I really hate this charter role.
It is so difficult.
It is just so difficult, and it just gets more difficult all the time.
Was that too blunt?
It's very difficult, and I'm now over seven years into it, so there could be a little battle fatigue going on.
I know that the political environment and the legal environment for charter schools has gotten more intense, has grown more intense over the seven years.
I'm absolutely aware of that.
And I know that both sides feel righteous in what they want and feel like they have the right to do.
And they're all, whether it's the district filing suit or the charter school,
pushing back on something, I have no doubt that everyone involved cares most about serving students, and serving students well.
That's why they became educators.
And that's what is most important to them.
Still, the way that the tension, the political tension, and then now increasingly some legal attention has increased is,
making me uncomfortable in the same kind of way that you mentioned, Feliza, member Feliza, in the same kind of way that you mentioned when you felt like some of the ethnic groups were battling over some of these things.
It's just uncomfortable.
It's not what I would like to see.
That said, I am prepared to make a motion
and in preface to it, at the ACCS, although a motion did not, recommendation did not come forward because there wasn't five to vote, five in favor of a single motion, there were a majority of the ACCS, four, that voted to deny this charter school.
and I am uncomfortable with the history of the charter school.
I'm uncomfortable with the fiscal concerns, with the union concerns, with the bankruptcy concerns, with the reauthorization concerns, with the what were referred to as strategic decisions by the operator that
evidently didn't turn out to be that strategic because each one seems to need a fix for something else.
So I'm prepared to recommend that to move the CDE recommendation to deny the request to establish Phoenix Charter Academy under the authorization of the State Board for marginal fiscal viability and unsuccessful history.
I will second.
Seconded, moved and seconded.
Is there any further board discussion of this?
Hearing none, all those in favor of the motion, raise your hand.
Okay, it is denied unanimously.
Okay, we now on to item 24, general public comment.
Do you have any?
There's no one signed up for general public comment.
Okay, I declare the board adjourned.